TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON THE
RESPONSE OF THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. COMPLIANCE OF THOSE
ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES THAT ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES HAVE ACCESS TO
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
THE CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. THE
MEMBER ATTENDING REMOTELY TODAY
IS SENATORS STERN- CENTER IF
YOU HAVE A STAFF PERSON WITH
YOU IN YOUR OFFICE PLEASE
IDENTIFY THAT STAFFER. SO STERN
ARE YOU WITH US. SO WE WILL WE
WILL COME BACK TO SENATOR STERN
I SEE THAT BIT HE IS ACTIVATED
HIS SCREEN. BECAUSE. ALL RIGHT-
TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WITH MEN
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WILL BE USED
WE WILL BE USING. A
TELECONFERENCE OF IS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WEST WHICH
TESTIFIED TODAY BROADRIDGE'S
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL NOW
ANNOUNCE IT. REYES PARTICIPANT
NUMBERS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO EIGHT
EIGHT ZERO THREE TWO TWO. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
USE THE TELECONFERENCES THEM
PLEASE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE JUST A NOTE AND I'LL
REPEAT THIS SEVERAL TIMES. IS
THAT. ON BILLS WILL BE TAKING
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES EACH OF
THEM WILL BE ACCORDED. TWO
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY AND THEN
WHEN WE TURN TO. OTHERS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY INSUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- WE WILL SIMPLY
ENTERTAIN THEM GIVING THEIR
NAME THEIR AFFILIATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL. BOB
WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
MODERATOR DAHLE ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
PRETTY PLEASE. PRESS THERE'S
ONLY ONE TIME AD WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU TO A LINE NUMBER.
THERE MAY BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATE CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER
AT THAT TIME YOU'LL B ON
MUTED. YOU BE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING OR
LISTENING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
IN OTHER WORDS. MAKE SURE YOU
MUTE YOUR DEVICE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN TO START TALKING. I'LL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE.
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IT IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG. LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE JUST IN A NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENCE
SO ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD- SERVICE STERN ARE YOU
WITH US NOW WE WILL WIN SENATE
STERN APPEARS. WE WILL GO OVER
THE PROTOCOL WITH RESPECT TO
REMOTE PARTICIPATION. SO WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN HERE. MONETARILY
BUT FIRST LET'S GO AHEAD AND-
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. FOR BETTER
PLEASE CANCEL THANK YOU FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM UMBERG. AMBERG HERE
BARGES RESERVE BOARD IS PRESENT
YET OVER HERE ABIERTO HERE DID
I SO HERE IT ALSO HERE GONZALEZ
HERE GONZALEZ HERE HERTZBERG.
JONES LAYERED HERE LAYERED HERE
STERN. WHITE HOUSE SKI HERE
KASKY HERE WIENER. WINNER HERE
YOU HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT. BEFORE WE
TURNED OUR FIRST BILL LET ME
MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE GROUND
RULES ARE UNDERSTOOD FOR ALL
BILLS EACH BILL IF THE AUTHOR
SHOULD CHOOSE TO KEEP MAY HAVE
TO IN SUPPORT TO PRIVATE
WITNESSES SUPPORT THE H. B.
LIMITED TWO MINUTES UNTIL
OPPOSITION IS LIMITED TWO
MINUTES- AFTER THAT WITNESSES
MAY TESTIFY AS TO THEIR NAME
THEIR AFFILIATION AND THEIR
POSITION- WE WILL ALLOW A
MAXIMUM FIFTEEN MINUTES PER
SIDE. EACH SIDE WILL BE
ACCORDED EQUAL EQUAL TIME BUT
NO MORE THAN FIFTEEN MINUTES.
ALL RIGHT. NOW LET'S TURN FIRST
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. I ALSO
KNOW THAT SB SIX SIX THREE BY
SENATOR NEWMAN HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM TODAY'S AGENDA. THERE WILL
NOT BE HEARD IF YOU'RE ON THE
PHONE WAITING FOR SB SIX SIX
THREE. THAT WILL NOT BE HEARD
TODAY. WE HAVE EIGHTEEN BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA FIVE WHICH ON
CONSENT. THE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ARE AS FOLLOWS
PHYLUM NUMBER SIX SB SEVENTY
SIX BY SENATOR NIELSEN
FOLLOWING NUMBER EIGHT SB FIVE
NINE ONE BY SENATOR BECKER.
FOLLOW NUMBER ELEVEN SB SIX
FIVE SEVEN BY SENATOR- TROUBLE
WITH AMENDMENTS. FOLLOW NUMBER
TWELVE SB TWO SEVEN TWO BY
SENATOR LAYERED ANDFINALLY
FILE NUMBER SEVENTEEN SP FIVE
ZERO FIVE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THEIR MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CENTER LAYERED MOVES
CONSENT CALENDAR. BALANCE SHEET
ACCOUNTS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR- BURKE-
BURKE HI PORGES. GORGEOUS I CAN
BE AT ALL I HAVE IT ALL I DID
ALSO. YEAH SO I GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
HI JONES LAYERED HI LAYERED I
STERN. WHITE HOUSE GATE HIGH
WEIGHT CAL SKI I WIENER. WIENER
AYE YOU HAVE THAT NINE SO FAR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL I SEE SENATOR
MELINDA THIS IS BEEN WAITING
PATIENTLY BY THE PODIUM THE
LENDERS SB TWO THREE EIGHT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL. TWO
FORTY NINE. THE INTELLECTUAL
DIVERSITY ACT WHICH SEEKS TO
ADDRESS DISCRIMINATION BASED
UPON POLITICAL AFFILIATION AT
OUR SCHOOLS. WRITER STUDENTS
WITH EXPOSURE TO ALL IDEAS AND
PERSPECTIVES IT'S A CENTURY
THAT SHOULD BE CELEBRATED AND
ENCOURAGED INSTEAD WE ARE
SEEING PROFESSORS AND TEACHERS
DO THE OPPOSITE. JUST THE OTHER
DAY IT WAS REPORTED TO SAN
DIEGO TEACHER WAS HEARD A
RESUME THE RATING IS STUDENTS
PARENTS OVER THEIR DISPLEASURE
OF HYBRID LEARNING IN FAVOR OF
FULL IN PERSON LEARNING THE
PARENT WHO EXPOSE THIS TEACHER
WAS QUOTED AS SAYING. BY HELD
ON TO THAT VIDEO FOR THREE
MONTHS AND HARDLY TOLD A SOUL
FEARING RETALIATION.
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATION CODE
PROTECTS VARIOUS
CHARACTERISTICS FROM BULLYING
SUCH AS RELIGION AND ETHNICITY
BUT DOES NOT INCLUDE ONE
POLITICAL VIEW POINTS OR
AFFILIATIONS. IF WE ARE GOING
TO ALLOW SIXTEEN YEAR OLDS TO
PRE REGISTER TO VOTE WHILE IN
HIGH SCHOOL THEY SHOULD BE FREE
OF BULLYING FROM THEIR TEACHERS
AND FELLOW STUDENTS REGARDING
THEIR POLITICAL VIEWPOINTS.
THIS INFLUENCE THE NEGATIVITY
IS MORE VISIBLE ON OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN HARVARD STUDENTS TRIED
TO PREVENT ANY TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS FROM
APPEARING AS SPEAKERS ON CAMPUS
EVEN AS SEVEN UNITED STATES
PRESIDENTS HAVE CALLED HER
PERVERTED SILVA MATER INCLUDING
PRESIDENTS OBAMA. GEORGE W.
BUSH AND JOHN F. KENNEDY THE
TWENTY TWENTY YET ANOTHER
PETITION BY HARVARD STUDENTS
ATTEMPTED TO HAVE THE
EDUCATIONAL DEGREES OF TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
REVOKED. THE CAN THESE PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS DO THESE SORTS OF
THINGS YES THEY CAN BUT SHOULD
WE BE ENCOURAGING IT FOR
TURNING A BLIND EYE TO IT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. NO WE SHOULD NOT.
ANOTHER EXAM THE MISSION
STATEMENT FROM UCLA INCLUDES
THE FOLLOWING. TO FULFILL THIS
MISSION UCLA'S COMMITTED TO
ACADEMIC FREEDOM AND ITS
FULLEST TERMS WE VALUE OPEN
ACCESS TO FREEDOM FREE AND
LIVELY DEBATE CONDUCTED WITH
MUTUAL RESPECT FOR INDIVIDUALS
AND FREEDOM FROM INTOLERANCE IN
ALL OUR PURSUITS WE STRIVE AT
ONCE FOR EXCELLENCE IN
DIVERSITY RECOGNIZING THAT
OPENNESS AND INCLUSION PRODUCE
TRUE EQUALITY. CALIFORNIA IS
NOT THE ONLY STATE TO CONFRONT
THIS GROWING PROBLEM ON FRIDAY
GET MONTANA GOVERNOR GREG
GIANFORTE'S SIGNED TWO BILLS
THAT AIM TO PROTECT FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION AND ASSOCIATION ON
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES IN
THE STATE. IT PROHIBITS
UNIVERSITIES FROM DENYING
RESOURCES TO RELIGIOUS
POLITICAL OR IDEOLOGICAL
STUDENT ORGANIZATIONS EVEN IF
THEY HOLD VIEWS THAT OTHER
STUDENTS MAY FIND OFFENSIVE.
NORTH TO COUNT TO KOTA HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES PASSED A BILL
PROHIBITING ACTIVITY CENTER
MELINDA'S YES I WOULDN'T
ORDINARILY DO THIS BUT BECAUSE
WE HAVE FOLKS LINED UP ON THE
PHONE ON YOUR BILL- I BELIEVE
SB TWO THIRTY EIGHT IS THE
FIRST BILL I'M SORRY STARTED
WITH MY SECOND ONE IT PEOPLE
ARE LINED UP TO TESTIFY. SO
JUST SO WE- BASICALLY DON'T GET
FOLKS. CONFUSE MY POLICY IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND GOING BACK TO S.
B. TWO THIRTY EIGHT SURE OKAY
MY APOLOGIES I THOUGHT WE ARE
STARTING TO FORTY NINE IRATE.
OKAY S. B. TWO THIRTY EIGHT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
TWO THIRTY EIGHT THE DIVERSITY
OF THOUGHT ACT WHICH SEEKS TO
REMEDY THE GROWING TREND OF
CANCEL CULTURE IN OUR SOCIETY
SOCIETY TODAY. THE FOUNDERS OF
OUR CONSTITUTION ENSURING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION TO ROOT OUT AND
PREVENT TYRANNY THEY DID THIS
TO ENSURE A POWERFUL MONARCH
COULD NOT STIFLE THEIR BORDERS
THEIR VOICES OR INSTRUCTOR
LEGISLATURE TO DO SO FOR THEM.
WHEN WE SAW THE ATTACKS AGAINST
ONE SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR
GENDER IDENTITY AS CALIFORNIANS
WE ADDED THEM TO THE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS WHEN WE SAW
ATTACKS AGAINST ONE'S ETHNICITY
ONE TO MARITAL STATUS OR
RELIGION WE ADDED THEM TO
CALIFORNIA'S ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS. NOW IT'S
OUR THOUGHTS IN BELIEF SYSTEMS
THAT ARE FACING CENSORSHIP
CANCELLATION AND ATTACKED AND
IT IS TIME TO PROTECT THEM. IN
TODAY'S SOCIETY WE HAVE LOST
OUR ABILITY TO AGREE TO
DISAGREE. WE HAVE LOST OUR
ABILITY TO LISTEN TO THE
VIEWPOINTS OF OTHERS TO BE
CIVIL AND UNDERSTANDING IN THAT
AGREEMENT. WE'VE TURNED TO
TRIBALISM AND MOB ADVOCACY
INSTEAD SHAMING PEOPLE INTO
JOINING ONE VIEWPOINT
SACRIFICING THEIR OWN JUST TO
AVOID SCRUTINY OR BACKLASH.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE THE RECENT
FIRING AT GINA CARANO FROM
DISNEY'S THE MANDALORIAN WHO
WAS FIRED FOR EXPRESSING HER
OPINIONS ON SOCIAL MEDIA HER
OPINIONS APPARENTLY DID NOT
ALIGN WITH DISNEY'S. BECAUSE
POLITICALLY CHARGED POSTED BY
HER CO STAR IN OTHER DISNEY
ACTORS AND ACTRESSES WERE NOT
MET WITH THE SAME REACTION OR
RESULT. THE EXAMPLES OF THIS
TYPE OF DOUBLE STANDARD IN
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS
DISCRIMINATION HAVE BEEN LAID
BARE FOR US FOR US ALL TO SEE.
ENTIRE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN OFFLINE BY
AMAZON WEB SERVICES ALL STAR
GAMES HAVE BEEN MOVED AND
SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS FROM A
DECADE AGO CAN COME BACK. AND
RUIN A PERSON'S CAREER. AS
LEGISLATORS WE ARE CHARGED TO
REPRESENT ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS NOT JUST THE ONES
WITH WHOM WE AGREE. SB TWO
THIRTY EIGHT MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT WE AS AN ELECTED BODY IN
THE STATE. TELL YOU THE
OPINIONS OF OTHERS EVEN THOUGH
WE MAY NOT AGREE WITH THEM AND
ENSURES THAT POLITICAL
AFFILIATION IS NOT USED AS A
DISQUALIFIER FOR JOB. WHETHER
THAT JOBS AT A STARBUCKS FOR
CRITICAL IT OR DISNEYLAND. IT
ALSO ENSURES THAT EMPLOYEES
WITH NOTORIETY LIKE AMANDA I AM
SEEING WHO LOST HER JOB WITH
THE MAKE UP COMPANY SEPHORA
PROPOSED IN SOCIAL MEDIA. AND
THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIAN CAN
HAVE THEIR PERSONAL VOICE
WITHOUT BEING SHAMED OR WITHOUT
FEAR OF RETALIATION BECAUSE IT
MAY DIFFER FROM THEIR EMPLOYER.
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS TO
PROTECT THE PERSONAL IDEAS AND
BELIEFS WE EACH HAVE FROM BEING
USED AS A LITMUS TEST BEFORE
RECEIVING A JOB OFFER. IN A
COUNTRY THAT PRIDES ITSELF ON
THE FREE EXCHANGE OF IDEAS AND
EXPRESSION. IT IS CONCERNING
THAT POLITICAL LEADERS
CORPORATIONS AND SOCIAL MEDIA
GIANTS WOULD SEEK TO SILENCE
THAT OPPRESSION. SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY DON'T AGREE WITH IT OR
THEY DON'T LIKE IT. THE FIRST
AMENDMENT GRANTS THE PEOPLE OF
THIS COUNTRY COUNTRY IN AN A
LEVEL RIGHT TO FREE SPEECH AND
ASSOCIATION. THIS RATE WILL BE
RAISED IF WE ALLOW THE CURRENT
PRACTICE OF DISCRIMINATION ON
POLITICAL BELIEFS TO CONTINUE.
SEVEN SB TWO THIRTY EIGHT WILL
ACCOMPLISH THREE THINGS FIRST
IT WILL ADD POLITICAL
AFFILIATION TO THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT. TO
PREVENT EMPLOYERS AND LANDLORDS
FROM DISCRIMINATING AGAINST JOB
CANDIDATES AND THOSE SEEKING
HOUSING BECAUSE OF THEIR
POLITICAL AFFILIATION. SECOND
IT ADDS POLITICAL AFFILIATION
OR POLITICAL BELIEVED TO THE
UNRUH CIVIL RIGHTS ACT. AND
LASTLY THAT'S POLITICAL
AFFILIATION TO SECTIONAL
REVENUE TO THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
CODE THE PROTECTION PLOY
PERMANENTLY ANY ADVERSE ACTION
TAKEN AGAINST EMPLOYEE FOR
POLITICAL ACTIVITIES. MANY OF
YOU MAY NOT AGREE OR BELIEVE
THE CANCEL CULTURE OR
DISCRIMINATION BASED UPON
POLITICAL BELIEFS EXIST OR THAT
IT IS A PROBLEM BUT I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT IT DOES EXIST
AND IT IS A VERY REAL PROBLEM
FOR MY CONSTITUENTS IN FOR MANY
OF YOURS. TODAY I HAVE MISTER
STEVE COMBOS WHO'S A TEACHER
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE MY DISTRICT
WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING VIA
TELECONFERENCE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU SIR MELINDA'S
MISTER COMPOST ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. SO WHILE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR MISTER KOPPEL'S
JUST FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
WAITING ON THE PHONE LINES-
THIS IS S. B. TWO THIRTY EIGHT
MELENDEZ NEXT BILL SB TWO FORTY
NINE WILL BE PRESENTED AFTER
THIS BILL. OF THEN SENATOR
NEWMAN WILL BE- PRESENTING ON
S. B. SIX SIXTY. ALL RIGHT A
MISTER MODERATOR MARYLAND THAT
DO WE HAVE MISTER KUMBLE'S. YES
MISTER COMPOSTABLE HEAD. MANY
MISTY COMPASS AND I'VE BEEN
TEACHING FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS.
THE PROBLEM EDUCATION THESE
DAYS IS THAT FOR MANY EDUCATED
AND IS THAT MANY EDUCATORS ARE
WORKING IN A HOSTILE WORKPLACE
ENVIRONMENT. AN EXAMPLE OUR
SCHOOL BOARD HAS DETERMINED
THAT BLM IS NOT A POLITICAL
ORGANIZATION. THAT MEANS
WEARING TO BLM SURE HAVING A D.
L. BLM AS YOUR VIRTUAL
BACKGROUND IS OKAY IT IS ALWAYS
A BLUE LINE FLAG WILL SUPPORT
OF LONG COURSE AND SOMEHOW.
THEY ARE RACIST. I HAVE BEEN
HARASSED DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
AT THE SITE IN ADMINISTRATIVE
LEVEL AT LEAST THREE TIMES.
WHAT IF YOU COLLEAGUES AND I
HAD DISCOVERED THAT THERE WERE
SOME INSIGHT INTO MINISTRY TO
ACCOUNTABILITY ISSUES ALONG
WITH THE MISAPPROPRIATION OF
FUNDS. WE TRIED TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES ONLY TO FIND OUT
THAT HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
COMES AT THE PRICE TO PAY. YOU
TRY TO RESOLVE ACCOUNTABILITY
ISSUES VIA THE COMMUNICATION
PROCESS THINGS RARELY CHANGER
GET DONE. WHERE DO THEY TAKE
YOUR ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS. AN
ISSUE SERIOUSLY. THIS WILL LEAD
YOU TO FILE GRIEVANCES INFORMAL
COMPLAINTS CONCERNS AND
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS WHEN YOU
DO THIS WE FOUND OUT THE HARD
WAY. THEY NEVER FORGET AND DO
NOT APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
NOW THE SITUATION IS ALREADY.
AFTER FOUND A SUBSTANTIATED
COMPLAINT. LABELED AS BEING A
TROUBLEMAKER EVEN THOUGH YOU
WERE JUST MAKING SURE THAT IT
COVERS BOTH POLITICS AND THAT
YOUR SITE WILL BEING CMPLIANT
WITH SPECIAL ALLOCATION OF
FUNDS. BECAUSE THEY FOUND THE
FORMAL COMPLAINT WHENEVER I TRY
TO TRANSFER OUT OF THE OUT OF
THE SITE WHERE I WAS BEING
HARASSED THESE DIFFICULT FOR
ANOTHER SITE. WITHIN THE
DISTRICT WHERE THEY WOULD HIRE
ME I INTERVIEWED FOR SEVERAL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WERE
AVAILABLE AND DID NOT GET THE
POSITIONS. OF MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES WOULD INTERVIEW FOR
POSITIONS IN WHICH THEY HAD
PROPER CREDENTIALS OR
EXPERIENCE MET ALL THE JOB
REQUIREMENTS AND YET THEY WERE
NEVER HIRED. THEY ALSO DID NOT
HAVE ANY COMPLAINTS IN THEIR
PROFESSIONAL PILOTS. WE HAVE
SEEN PEOPLE WITH NO EXPERIENCE
PLUS EXPERIENCE UNTIL WE DO NOT
EVEN HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
CREDENTIALS NECESSARY FOR THE.
JOB GET HIRED. OVER THEM. YOU
REPRESENTATIVES ALSO. ISSUES
TIMES. BECAUSE THAT CAN ALSO
YOU TO BE. UNFAIRLY GENERAL WE
ARE SO TO BE IT. MORE WITHIN
THE LEFT WING INTO TO OF PUBLIC
AT. SOMETIMES WE'RE BEING.
UNFAIRLY BECAUSE OF OUR
POLITICAL AFFILIATION. ARE
CONSERVATIVE VOICES NOT ONLY
BEING SILENCED WE ARE DELIGHTED
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS FOR
HAVING A DIFFERENT OPINION. OR
DIVERSITY OF SPOT. THAT DOES
NOT ALIGN WITH THE PROGRESSIVE
POLITICAL AGENDA THAT HAS
INFILTRATED PUBLIC EDUCATION.
COMMISSION BECAUSE IT WILL
CANCEL ABOUT COMPUTER THE
DEPLETION POSITIONS. AND
OPPORTUNITIES JUST BECAUSE WE
THINK THAT EDUCATION SHOULD BE
ABOUT EDUCATIONAL ISSUES. LIKE
LOW MATH AND LITERACY SCORES.
INSTEAD OF THE POLITICALLY
CHARGED JUST THE GENDER. WITHIN
THE PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM. I
TESTIFYING TODAY AT THIS
HEARING CAN PUT ME AT RISK OF
DOORS BEING CLOSED TO FUTURE
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AND
OPPORTUNITIES. WITHIN THE
INSTITUTION OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION. BUT I THINK IT IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAT I SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE OF. THE
EXPERIENCE OF THOUSANDS OF
EDUCATORS. MANY EDUCATORS ARE
SILENCE AND FEAR VERBALLY
SHARING THEIR THOUGHTS. ON
PUBLIC EDUCATION BECAUSE OF
THEIR POLITICAL. AFFILIATION
INCLUDING URGING TO SUPPORT
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY EIGHT.
THANKS AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE MY EXPERIENCE TODAY AND
TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR MY
STORY. AND CONSIDER MUCH PART
POSITION. PUBLISHED THANK YOU
JUST CAN'T ONE OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT I SEE ONE PERSON
GALLERY IN SOME NO BOB ALL
RIGHT LET'S TURN ROOM TO
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE ALL RIGHT FOR THOSE OF
YOU ON THE PHONE WITH
INTENSIFIED SUPPORT PLEASE GIVE
US YOUR NAME YOUR FILIATION IN
YOUR POSITION ALL RIGHT MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD LINE UP
THOSE IN SUPPORT ON S. B. TWO
THIRTY EIGHT. THAT WOULD BE
GREAT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. SERVICE LINE ONE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS SHERRY SHY AND I SUPPORT S.
B. TWO THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO A LINE TO FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. VERY GOOD
TO THE GEORGE LAW'S SOS AND
THEY ARE CURRENTLY IN ORANGE
COUNTY CALIFORNIA. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT S. FIFTY TWO THIRTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO GO LINE TO FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIX OF THE
LINE TWO SIXTY PLEASE. I'M
SORRY. NEXT BEST MODERATOR. THE
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE. THREE
FIFTY NINE. LINE THREE FIFTY
NINE. RIGHT NEXT MISTER
MODERATOR. THE NEXT AVAILABLE
ONE TO SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS MAINO
YOUNG I'M STRONG SUPPORTER SB
TWO THIRTY EIGHT KAMALA. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
FOURTEENTH FEES YOU THIRTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. AND TO LINE
THREE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS TONY ARE
VOLATILE CAPITOL RESOURCE
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF SB TWO THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU. NEXT ONE THREE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
SHERRY COMIC HERE- I REMEMBER
NEED TO DO THEM AND I'M A
STRONG SUPPORTER AND AFTER VOTE
YES ON S. B. TWO THREE EIGHT.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO A LINE TO
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LOOKS LIKE THE WIND IS
CONNECTED WILL MOVE ON THE LINE
TO EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE TWO EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MOVING ON NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE THREE OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS BRENDA BROWN I
NAY TEACHER MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER AND PLACERVILLE
CALIFORNIA UP NORTH AND I AM
STRONGLY SUPPORTED. SB TWO
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
STRUGGLING TO TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS CAROL AND
STAND IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT TO
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU. NEXT TO
A LINE ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS ELLEN WAY
AND I'M A FARMER IN STANISLAUS
COUNTY AND I LIVE IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY AND I'M VERY
PROUD OF OUR SENATOR MELENDEZ
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AND URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT TO THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ZERO ONE
THREE OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I DIDN'T JENNIFER GREGORY
AND CALLING FROM A BIRD AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THIRTY
THREE. I GIVE. NEXT OVER THE
LINE THREE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS B. SAYS.
I'M ALSO RESIDENTS IN COACHELLA
VALLEY I HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO ARE TEACHERS AND I STRONG
SUPPORT SB THREE THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT. TO GET
ALIGNED AT THREE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY NAME
COULD BE IN THE KAISER AND I AM
A RETIRED TEACHER FROM LONG
BEACH UNIFIED WITH OVER FORTY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE AS A MEMBER
OF THE CITY OF RETIRED. I HOPE
YOU WILL JOIN ME IN STRONGLY
SUPPORTING AT TWO THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO TO ONE
THREE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN DESERVE
AN ISSUE WITH THE PHONE LINES
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT THE
EIGHTH PERSON THAT THEY'VE
CALLED ON THAT IS NOT THERE I'M
NOT AWARE OF ANY ISSUE BUT- AND
I AND I SEE. SYSTOLE SAID
SHAKING NO THERE'S NOT AN ISSUE
I DON'T KNOW IF PEOPLE ARE.
TIRED OF WAITING OR WHAT MAY
BE. A BUT IF. IF YOU'RE
LISTENING AND YOU WERE CALLED
UPON AND YOU DID NOT. HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
COULD DIAL BACK IN AND WILL
WILL- GET TO YOU. ALL RIGHT
MISTER MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT OVER THE LINE THREE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE THREE TWENTY
SEVEN. POSSIBLY OF YOUR ME BUT
NONE. IT WILL BE NINE IN A
TORTILLA. WHAT MY NAME IS
DOROTHY- TOOL AND- PROPERTY TAX
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY.
FROM ABOUT YES I'M TWO THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. WELCOME AND
THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH THE
PHONES I'VE BEEN DISCONNECTED
FOUR TIMES. RT THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. NOW TOTALING THREE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
I'M NANCY MADSEN A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER IN COACHELLA
VALLEY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB TWO THIRTY EIGHT AND URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE TWO OH
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LISA
NAVARRO FROM CHINO HILLS
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT HE TO THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT IN LINE TO
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME- YES WE CAN GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
ANNA JANE KRAMER FROM THE BAY
AREA I STRONGLY SUPPORT OUR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS AS
PROVIDED FOR BY SB TWO THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT RIVER LINE TO TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KAREN MCCURRY HANDS I RESIDE IN
MARIETTA I'M ONE OF MELISSA
MELENDEZ CONSTITUENTS I CREATE
THE WORK SHE DOES AND I AM ALSO
URGING A YES VOTE ON SB TWO
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE THREE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RENDON BEERS
FROMONTARIO CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO THIRTY. THANK YOU.
THE NEXUS LINE THREE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS STEPHANIE TELE AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF LIVING
DOWN. THANK YOU. LEXICAL ONE
ONE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BECKY
CARNEY AND I'M A VOTER FROM
NEWPORT BEACH AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB TWO THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO A LINE TO NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
BRENDA CAMPBELL I'M A VOTER IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I AM
STRONG IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
TWO THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU.
MEXICO ONE TWO FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIXTURES
COMMITTEE ON OUR OWN STRONG
SUPPORT AND- I ALSO WAS
DISCONNECTED EARLIER. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO THE LINE THREE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
WEEKEND. THIS STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE S. B. THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
THANK VERY MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
TO IT ONLINE THREE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
SANDRA BAUMAN- I RESIGNED
RIVERSIDE AND I'M CALLING IN TO
OFFER MY STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL TWO THREE EIGHT AND
I URGE A YES VOTE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE TWO SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
ROBIN COOK AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE L. G. B. AND STAY
IN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
BOTH BILLS. THANK YOU- AND I
WAS A WILL TO RELY THAT I HAD A
WRITTEN A LOT AND I WAS AND SO.
ACTUALLY WILL ENTERTAIN AND
PROMULGATE. ANY WRITTEN
INFORMATION YOU CARE TO SUBMIT
ON THIS BILL YOU CAN SUBMIT IT-
LOOK GOOD THE WEBSITE FIND HOW
TO SUBMIT WRITTEN. TESTIMONY
THE NEXT PLEASE OKAY. R. A.
DICKEY. NEXT WE GO TO LINE
THREE TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH THIS RON EDWARDS CAL. I
URGE A YES VOTE SUPPORT TO THE
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANKS TO GO
TO LINE THREE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS NATALIE L.
AND I OPPOSE A B. SIX THREE-
OKAY AT THE THINK. THAT'S NOONE
STILL WE HEARD LITTLE WHILE.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE NOT. AND RIGHT
NOW ON B. TOOTH EIGHT. THAT.
THE CARD PARTY THANK YOU. AND
GOT A LINE A TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHAT DO YOU NEED. SERVICEMEN
FOR GO TO NAY. NEXT. TWENTY
FOUR A TWO YEAR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO. HELLO WORLD TO. YES
GO AHEAD OR TO YES GO AHEAD HI-
I RELUCTANTLY DO NOT SUPPORT
THE DOES REFLECT THAT CERTAIN
BELIEVE WE'RE WE'RE RIGHT ON AS
B. TO EIGHT THOSE IN SOME. ALL
RIGHT MISS MATTER ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTY. EXCELLENT THREE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS A LEASE ARE MEANT AND I
RESIDE IN CORONA CALIFORNIA AND
I SUPPORT. ET THIRTY THANK YOU.
THAT COULD GO LINE. ONE SEVENTY
THREE GO AHEAD. A LITTLE
MOUNTAINS CAL AND I'D LIKE TO
URGE THE SENATE BILL THIRTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
AMOS MODERATOR I'M GONNA GIVE
IT ANOTHER FEW SECONDS FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT BECAUSE WE HAD
SOME TECHNICAL GLITCHES STYLE
IN. FOR S. B. TWO THIRTY EIGHT
IN THE MEANTIME- I THINK MOST
OF US IN THE CHAMBER NO BUT IF
YOU'RE LISTENING- YEAH. EIGHT
JURIES CONVICTED- EX POLICE
OFFICER DIRECTS OFTEN OF TWO
COUNTS OF MURDER AND ONE COUNT
OF MANSLAUGHTER IN THE DEATH OF
GEORGE GEORGE FLOYD OTHER WORDS
CONVICTED ON ALL COUNTS- OF
THIS MATTER IS OR ANYONE ELSE
ON THE PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT
OF AS TWO. EIGHT WE DO HAVE ONE
LINE CHEWING UP JUST ONE MORE
PLEASE BE ONE. OKAY AND ONE
THREE THIRTY SO PLEASE AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M IN FUTURE
REALLY. NUMBER- I NAME IS
MICHAEL CLARK FROM G. CAL. I AM
VERY FROM ABOUT DOLLARS. MARIO
THE WIFE OF A SMALL ON IN THE
BUSINESS MIGHT AND I STRONG
SUPPORT- CENTER MELENDEZ AM A
APRIL. RUSSIAN IN THE IN THE
GALLERY THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION
LETS GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION
SEMATARY LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE WHO'S IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. TWO THIRTY EIGHT. AND THOSE
IN OPPOSITION OF SB WO THIRTY
EIGHT HE'S PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. JUST ONE WALL
GATHER THE LINE NUMBER. CYCLE
GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IS ACTUALLY
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION THIS MODERATOR THE
NEXT A LITTLE LINE FOR- TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I
RELUCTANTLY DON'T SUPPORT THE
BILL JUST BECAUSE THE FACT.
HOLD NOT WANT TO HIRE PEOPLE
WHO THAT MAGICALLY OPPOSE THEIR
BELIEVES. ALL RIGHT ORDER YOUR
NAME. BEEN SORRY THE NAME. THEN
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER AND. THEIR NEXT OVER THE
LINE. FOUR OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS LINDA
CLEARANCE I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB TWO THIRTY EIGHT ALL RIGHTY
THANK YOU- THIS MODERN BUT ALSO
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWO
THIRTY EIGHT. AND THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE FOR ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ALAN QUINN
I'M A RESIDENT FROM LIKE ELSA
AND I ACTUALLY I AM IN SUPPORT
OF IT BUT THE TECHNICAL
PROBLEMS- YOU GUYS HAD
DISCONNECTED THE CALL OR AND MY
LINE WAS TO NINETY SEVEN SO I
DID NEED TO MAKE SURE YOU GUYS
ARE WHERE I SUPPORT. SB TWO
THIRTY EIGHT ALREADY THANK YOU.
THIS MODERATOR. ANYONE ELSE ON
THE PHONE. WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN REGARD TO SB TWO THIRTY
EIGHT. THIS AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE FOUR OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CLAUDIA
FROM LOS ANGELES. ANDI'M
CALLING IN REGARDS TO BE
OPPOSED TO IT BECAUSE IT GOES
AGAINST OUR CONSTITUTION AND
ALSO FOR OUR WRITING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE MISSED
MODERATOR. WE SHOULD. ONE THREE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS TO BE ON AN MONTCADA
I. GET A CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT
TO- SHOW MY SUPPORT AND URGED
AND YES VOTE ONLINE- SB TWO
THIRTY EIGHT AND ALSO THANK MY
FROM THE MONDAY. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. LET'S GO TO LINE THREE
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS SHERRY AND I'M A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER I SUPPOSE S. B.
TWO THIRTY NINE. TWO THIRTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATE IF YOU COULD GIVE US
AN ESTIMATE AS TO HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE ON THE LINE- WISHING
TO TESTIFY THAT WOULD BE USEFUL
YOU CAN SEND IT BY TEXT IF YOU
LIKE. ALL RIGHT NEXT CALLER.
BOB THAT'S A GOOD ONE TO TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS LAURIE WELL I AM GOING TO
GET A RETIRED TEACHER. AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF SB. THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT. TWENTY THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A LITTLE
ONE THREE NINETY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD SIR. TWENTY THREE
NINETY THREE OF ONE IS A. ALL
RIGHT. MODERATOR IF THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE CHAMBER. THIS BILL.
SHE HELLO HI YES MA'AM ARE YOU
TESTIFYING ON SB. TWO THIRTY
EIGHT. CAN YOU NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
HI NATALIE ALVAREZ MALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. IN THE ARE YOU
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION SB TWO
THIRTY EIGHT. I'M IN OPPOSITION
OF ALL AGES THIRTY EIGHT. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE MR MODERATOR. WE DO
HAVE TWO MORE LINES OF QUEUED
UP HERE ALL RIGHT FOR SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JACKIE ROSA AND I OPPOSE SB TWO
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
ACCORDING TO THE. FIVE THIS
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
I'M NOT VOTE FOR TWO THIRTY
EIGHT AM. THREE SEVEN DEBATE OR
NOT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT OTHER CALLERS
MISTER MODERATOR. WE HAVE NO
OTHER THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA BRING
IT BACK TO THE CHAMBER NOW- I
SEE CENTER BOARDS HAS
MICROPHONE UP CENTER BORDERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I WANT
TO COMMEND THE- THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. BECAUSE
EVEN THOUGH I THINK. THAT THERE
ARE DIFFERENT PROVISIONS WITHIN
OUR- STATUTORY AUTHORITY. I
REALLY APPRECIATE TAKING A
GANDER. THAT THE ALLEGED
COUNSEL'S OPINION ON THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT. SOMETHING THAT
CAUGHT MY ATTENTION. WAS THE
CONCLUSION SAID IF I MAY MISTER
CHAIR IF I COULD READ FROM THE
REPORT ONE SENTENCE SURE GO
AHEAD. IT IS OUR OPINION THAT
IN THE ABSENCE OF A LEGITIMATE
BUSINESS INTEREST JUSTIFYING A
DISTINCTION. ON THE BASIS OF
POLITICAL BELIEF OR AFFILIATION
THE OWNER CIVIL RIGHTS ACT
PROHIBITS DISCRIMINATION ON THE
BASIS OF POLITICAL BELIEFS OR
AFFILIATIONS. SO I HAVE A KIND
OF ZONE IN ON THE ABSENCE OF A
LEGITIMATE BUSINESS INTEREST.
SO I DO BELIEVE THAT. THERE
HAVE BEEN FOLKS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM THAT
HAVE BEEN DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST- I DON'T NECESSARILY
FIND AT THAT ONE PARTY HAS A
SUPERIOR POSITION OVER THE
OTHER WHETHER BEYOND THE LEFT
CENTER OR THE RIGHT. I JUST
KNOW THAT. IT DEFIES LOGIC IT
DEFIES WHAT WE DEEM TO BE OUR
FIRST AMENDMENT. CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS OF ASSOCIATING OF
BEING PART OF AN ASSEMBLY AND
EXPRESSING THOSE SO LONG AS
IT'S NOT. HI INTERFERING WITH
THE WORK PLACE- BEEN IT SHOULD
HAVE NO BEARING ON AN
INDIVIDUAL'S CAPACITY TO BE
EMPLOYED OR TO BE HOUSED- IT
CETERA. BUT THAT CONCLUSION IF
I MAY. OFFER A REQUEST TO THE
AUTHOR THROUGH THE CHAIR. IS
THAT A LEGITIMATE BUSINESS
INTERESTS JUSTIFYING A
DISTINCTION IS AN INTERESTING
CHOICE OF WORDS THAT LEDGE
COUNCIL IS OFFERING. SO THE
QUESTION IS. IT DISNEY FOR
AMAZON OR ANY OTHER MAJOR-
EMPLOYER FORTY INDUSTRY- ENTITY.
CALCULATES OUT THAT IT WOULD
HURT THEIR BUSINESS INTEREST BY
ALLOWING EMPLOYEES WHO MAY BE
AFFILIATED WITH ONE POLITICAL
FACTION OR PARTY. IS IT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT GIVES
RISE TO AN ALLOWANCE. M. NO IT
DOESN'T MEAN YOU STILL HAVE
YOUR SOUL OF AFFORDED THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS YOU WOULD ANY
OTHER TIME WITH RESPECT TO
HIRING AN EMPLOYEE THIS IS. IT
IT'S DECLARATIVE OF THE UNRUH
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT AGE AS YOU SO
APTLY POINTED OUT. BUT IT
DOESN'T TAKE AWAY THE ABILITY
FOR EMPLOYER TO METE OUT WHO
MEETS THE REQUIREMENTS AND WHO-
WOULD YOU KNOW BE BEST SERVED
IN THAT POSITION I WILL- TO
DIVE A LITTLE DEEPER INTO THE
LEGAL DETAILS- MORGAN BRANCH.
IS HERE IF YOU WANTED TO ADD TO
THAT- HE'S HERE FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANT ASSISTANCE MORGAN IF
YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD TO
THAT. IT IT'S NOT NECESSARY WAS
AN INTELLECTUAL CURIOSITY OKAY
I THINK BECAUSE WE'VE HEARD
THESE THAT WE'VE HEARD THESE
DISCUSSIONS ARE POSITIONS. MADE
BY. MAJOR INDUSTRIES YOU KNOW
COCA COLA OR WHATEVER THAT.
THERE WERE EIGHT DEARER THEY
COULD BE ARGUING THAT THEY DO
NOT WANT TO EMPLOY INDIVIDUALS
THAT MAY BE AFFILIATED WITH THE
POLITICAL INTEREST GROUP OR
POLITICAL PARTY BECAUSE IT MAY
HURT THEIR BOTTOM LINE
FINANCIALLY IT IS THAT
JUSTIFICATION. THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE LEGAL
OPINION I SEE WELL YOU KNOW
AGAIN IT'S LIKE ANY OTHER
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY IF I
MEAN YOU COULD- IT WOULD BE A
ONE POLITICAL AFFILIATION AND
SHE USED TO WORK FOR A COMPANY
THAT HAS AN OPPOSING VIEWPOINT
AS LONG AS YOU'RE ABLE TO DO
THAT JOB AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THEY WISH. YOU TO DO THAT JOB
AND DON'T LET YOUR OWN
POLITICAL YOU KNOW IDEOLOGY GET
IN THE WAY THEN THERE'S NO
REASON FOR THEM TO DENY YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR WORKING TO WHEN
IT STARTS TO BECOME A FUNCTION
OF YOUR- IS WHERE THE- IS
EXACTLY AND I WANT TO GET I
WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR THAT
EVEN THOUGH I THINK. THERE ARE.
ENOUGH PROTECTIONS FOR THIS
TYPE PULL BELIEF OR AFFILIATION
BILL. IT'S HELPFUL WHEN WE
OPENLY DECLARE THROUGH
LEGISLATION THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT WE INTEND TO DO. IS TO
DISALLOW DISCRIMINATION BASED
ON AFFILIATION. BECAUSE
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
MIGHT HAVE PROCLIVITIES GOING
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER. AND
THAT'S JUST NOT WHAT AMERICA IS
ABOUT. FREE MARKET PLACE OF I.
IS WHAT WE ARE ABOUT AS LONG AS
IT DOES NOT INTERFERE WITH THE
WORK PLACE. DIRECTLY THEN I
THINK THOSE INDIVIDUAL SHOULD
HAVE THAT FREEDOM. THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU CENTER BOARD JUST-
CENTER GONZALEZ IS YOUR
MICROPHONE UP. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- SO JUST HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS- I ACTUALLY
LOOKING TO THE ANALYSIS AS WELL
AND I DO AGREE WITH- THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT AS SHE HAD MENTIONED
IN HERE THAT WOULD BE FORCING
BUSINESSES AND EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS IN THE WORKPLACE
IS TO TOLERATE STRONG OPPOSING
VIEWS AND POTENTIALLY HATE
SPEECH I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT FIRST AND
FOREMOST IF I CAN POSE THAT
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR. AND
THEN THE SECOND IS. I HAVEN'T
SEEN IN HERE AND PERHAPS I'VE
MISSED IT WHAT IS POLITICAL
AFFILIATION. WHAT IS DETERMINED
BY THAT IS THAT A POLITICAL
AFFILIATION WITH THE SPECIFIC.
POLITICAL LIKE DEMOCRAT
REPUBLICAN INDEPENDENT OR IS IT
JUST ANYONE BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME GROUPS THAT AFFILIATE
POLITICALLY BUT THEY'RE NOT.
ASSOCIATED WITH ANY PARTICULAR.
GROUP IN THAT IN THAT SENSE.
MISTER CHAIR FOR ME SURE
SUDDENLINK YOU SO MUCH AND
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER GONZALEZ- SO WITH
RESPECT TO- PROVIDING A
DEFINITION OF POLITICAL BELIEF
OR POLITICAL AFFILIATION- IT
YOU NOW WE MY STAFF HAS
OFFERED TO WORK WITH THE-
COMMITTEE TO BETTER DEFINE
THESE TERMS SEVERAL TIMES
ACTUALLY AND THAT REQUEST WAS
DENIED TO ITS OWN IS THAT WE
DIDN'T TRY. TO DO THAT BUT
THERE WAS NO INTEREST- IN
WORKING TO FURTHER DEFINE THAT-
I WILL SAY THOUGH THAT THE
ABSENCE OF A DEFINITION I DON'T
THINK- IS FATAL FOR THIS BILL
BECAUSE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
TERMS JUST WITHIN THE UIVERSE
OF A RIGHTS ACT BETTER
UNDEFINED- WHICH INCLUDE RACE
COLOR ANCESTRY. MARITAL STATUS
CITIZENSHIP PRIMARY LANGUAGE
IMMIGRATION STATUS NATIONAL
ORIGIN ACCOMMODATIONS I MEAN
THERE'S A WHOLE HOST OF TERMS
THAT ARE UNDEFINED AND YET WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO APPLY THE LAW
EQUALLY WITHOUT YOU KNOW IT I
AM VERY SPECIFIC DEFINITION
WITH WHICH TO DO SO- SO I JUST
WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT I KNOW
THAT THE ANALYSIS DID. SPEAK TO
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT IS. THIS-
BUT AGAIN. THERE'S A NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA CODES THAT YOU KNOW
LACK- AND DEFINITION AND YET
WE'RE STILL ABLE TO CONDUCT OUR
BUSINESS. THANK YOU- SENATE
WHITE HOUSE GIVE A QUESTION BUT%
YES THIRDS I DID READ THE
REPORT- BUT LET'S CANCEL AND-
CONCLUDING THAT IT IT APPEARS
AS THOUGH. THE POLITICAL
BELIEFS WOULD BE PROTECTED THE-
IT BROUGHT TWO KEYS. THE
ANALYSIS BEFORE AS PART.
REESE'S MANY CONCERNS ABOUT
FROM A POLICY- THE POINT
BEGINNING ON PAGE EIGHT OF
WHETHER YOU KNOW WORKED IT IS
INVOLVED PARTISAN- PERFECT. BUT
POLITICAL PARTISAN WORK
WHETHER- THE EMPLOYER WOULD
HAVE TO DISCRETION TO- CHIU
SOMEBODY THAT THEY THOUGHT THAT
WOULD BE WOULD BE ON THEIR TEAM
IF THEY FOR THEY THEY FIT INTO
THEIR THEIR WORK OR IS IT IS IT
ACTUALLY NECESSARY TO GO
THROUGH A VARIETY OF. SCENARIOS
WERE. THE MOTHERS AGAINST
SOMEBODY COMES IN WITH TEACHERS
WITH MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK
DRIVING AND GO VEGAN AND
THEY'RE PLAYING FOR A BARBECUE
WHISKEY BAR- OPPORTUNITY-
EMPLOYMENT YOU'VE GOT- PEOPLE
WORRIED ABOUT OR THIS IDEA THAT
WE'RE TURNING THE WORKPLACE.
INTO THE TOWN SQUARE WHERE
PEOPLE CAN COME IN AND HAVE TO
DISCUSSIONS TO TALK ABOUT SANDY
HOOK IN A GUN SHOP THAT WOULD
BE DISRUPTIVE TO THE BUSINESS-
TO. THROUGH THOSE POINTS THAT
WERE RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR'S RESPONSE
BILL GIVEN THAT IT APPEARS THAT
THE TERRORISTS TESTS ALREADY
PROTECTS A TRULY AGREE EACH
PERSON. FOR THEIR HOLDING THEIR
POLITICAL BELIEFS. VEGAS ANYWAY
KASKY CYLINDERS OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE GATE. ARE THERE IS A LOT
TO UNPACK. SO WHAT WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO START WITH BECAUSE
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS EACH OF
YOUR CONCERNS. OF THE WORK THE-
FIFTY. EMPLOYERS SONORA CASKEY-
IN YOUR MIND. THIS IS START
WITH THE WITH THE WORK SITE THE
EMPLOYER HAVING TO ACCOMMODATE
DISCUSSIONS OTHER PEOPLE IN
THERE AND THEN GO TO HIRING
THOSE PEOPLE- THAT MIGHT NOT
FIT IN OR MIGHT BE DESTRUCTIVE
TO THE WORK ENVIRONMENT. OKAY
SO YOUR FORGIVE ME BUT YOUR
SPECIFIC CONCERN ABOUT
DISCUSSIONS IN THE WORK PLACE
CENTERS AROUND. WHAT I JUST I
DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
CONCERN IS THAT ARE YOU
CONCERNED THAT- I EMPLOYER
COULDN'T. HAVE ANY CONTROL OVER
CONVERSATIONS AT WORK. I MEAN
MISTER CHAIR BUT IT'S A WHITE
CAL THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
THAT YOU COULDN'T DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST SOMEBODY'S POLITICAL
PULL- OUR POLITICAL BELIEFS AND
HIRING THEM YOU WOULD HE WOULD
BE FORCED TO HIRE SOMEBODY THAT
LET'S SEE IS A VEGAN AND IS A
MOTHER AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING
AND SHE SHE'S COMING INTO YOUR
BARBECUE WHISKEY SHIP WHICH AND
SHE'S CONFRONTATIONAL SAYING I
NEED THIS JOB YOU CANNOT. USE
MY POLITICAL BELIEFS TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST ME TO GIVE
ME THIS JOB SURE IN IN A
SITUATION LIKE THAT IF SOMEONE
WERE TO COME IN AND SAY I WANT
THIS JOB AND I NEED THIS JOB
AND IF YOU DON'T GIVE IT TO ME
IT'S GOING TO BE BECAUSE OF MY
POLITICAL AFFILIATIONS- I WOULD
IMAGINE THAT AT PROSPECTIVE
EMPLOYER WOULD FIND A WHOLE
HOST OF REASONS NOT TO HIRE
THAT PERSON BASED ON. THE
PERSONALITY WITH WHICH THEY
HOPPED INTO THE INTERVIEW WITH
THE MEAN AN INTERVIEW IT'S NOT
JUST BASED ON THE THINGS ON
YOUR RESUME NOT JUST ON YOUR
SPECIFIC SKILL SET A
QUALIFICATION IT'S BASED ON A
LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE
HOW YOU KNOW YOUR YOUR DEMEANOR
WITHIN THE INTERVIEW HOW AN
EMPLOYER MIGHT THINK YOU WOULD
INTERACT WITH THE REST OF THE
EMPLOYEES I MEAN THERE'S A
WHOLE HOST OF THINGS IT'S NOT
JUST BASED ON THE FACT THAT
SOMEBODY. HAS A T. SHIRT ON
THAT SAYS THERE BEGIN AND BY
THE WAY BEING A VEGAN OR
ANYTHING ELSE IS NOT A
POLITICAL AFFILIATION SO. I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT COMES
INTO THE CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU SO. SKI BUT I THINK MAYBE
TO PUT A FINER POINT ON YOUR
QUESTION SO I CAN ASK IF I
COULD POSE A QUESTION SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU ARE IN
LEADERSHIP OF A PRO LIFE
ORGANIZATION SOMEONE COMES IN
THE INTERVIEW THEY HAVE ALL THE
QUALIFICATIONS YOU EXTEND AN
OFFER. AND THEN THEY SAY I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THIS
OFFER BUT YOU SHOULD KNOW ON
IBM VICE PRESIDENT OF NAY ROUTE.
WITH THAT AT THAT POINT IN
TIME. IS IT YOUR VIEW THAT THAT
IF THAT PERSON SHOULD BE HIRED
BY THE PRO LIFE ORGANIZATION
WOULD THEY HAVE A CAUSE OF
ACTION UNDER THIS BILL. MORGAN
YOU WANT TO TAKE THAT ONE. OKAY
YES- THIS IS JUST A RUSE NO WAY
NINE STRUCTURE THIS B. I DON'T
THINK YOUR MICROPHONES ON MORE
THAN ONE SECOND SO IT PUTS. TEN
DAYS AGO. JUST TO REFRESH YOUR
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR WOULD.
THE MEMBER OF NARAL HAVE A
CAUSE OF ACTION ARISES AFTER
THEY'VE ACCEPTED AN OFFER OF
EMPLOYMENT IS THAT YOUR
QUESTION RIGHT AND THAT OFFER
THEN IS RESCINDED BASED ON THE
FACT THAT THERE. ACTIVITIES ARE
ANTITHETICAL TO THE
ORGANIZATION'S PURPOSE. AN
AFFILIATION. OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD IT SEEMS UNCLEAR BUT IF
THERE WAS KNOWN PROSPECTIVELY
YOU KNOW FOR THE EMPLOYER THAT
THIS PERSON HAD THESE BELIEFS
THAT YOU KNOW THE PRO LIFE
ORGANIZATION. WHO'S
INTERVIEWING SOMEONE WHO
PASSIONATELY BELIEVE IN THE
RIGHT TO AN ABORTION. I WOULD
READ THE LAW TO SAY THAT THE
FOR THE EMPLOYER COULD
RATIONALLY CONCLUDE THAT THAT
WOULD NOT BE A GOOD CANDIDATE
FOR THAT JOB JUST BASED ON. HOW
DEDICATED THEY WOULD BE TO
THEIR WORK SO IF. YOU KNOW THE
MISSION OF THE ORGANIZATION IS
TO PROMOTE ONE BECAUSE BUT- YOU
WERE INTERVIEWING A CANDIDATE
WHO BELIEVES IN THE OPPOSITE OF
THAT BECAUSE AN EMPLOYER COULD
RATIONALLY CONCLUDE THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO WORK VERY
HARD FOR ME OR THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO WORK WELL WITH.
MEMBERS OF THE TEAM SO I THINK
IN THAT SITUATION. THAT WOULD
BE A PERMISSIBLE. IT WOULD BE
PERMISSIBLE FOR AN EMPLOYER TO.
NOT HIRE THAT PERSON IT
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY BE ON. A
POLITICAL AFFILIATION GROUNDS
BUT JUST ON THE RATIONAL
BELIEF. TAKING POLITICAL
AFFILIATION INTO CONSIDERATION
BUT ON A RATIONAL BELIEF THAT.
THEY'RE JUST SIMPLY NOT A
SUITABLE EMPLOYEE FOR THAT
POSITION. SORRY THANK YOU AT
THAT THE EXCEPTION MAY SWALLOW
UP THE RULE BUT MANY EVENTS
CENTER WIENER. THANK YOU. I IS
A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR. SEVEN
SO THIS IS AN EXAMPLE THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP IN THE ANALYSIS ONE
THAT I USE WAS IN FRONT OF. ME
BEFORE I READ THE ANALYSIS SO
SOMEONE. UNDER THIS IS A SORT
OF BECOME LAW- AND SOME WOULD
APPLY FOR A JOB IN THE COURSE
OF THE INTERVIEW SAID EITHER
THEY MENTIONS OR IT WAS JUST A
TERM FROM THE SOCIAL MEDIA-
THAT THERE ARE- A MEMBER OF THE
**** MOVEMENTS- ON. THE WORD
ABOUT THEIR OTHERWISE OTHER
THERE IN TERMS OF THEIR SKILLS
FOR THE JOB. THAT THERE THERE'S
QUALIFICATIONS FOR THE JOB AND
THERE'S NO INDICATION THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE. TRY TO DO THINGS
THAT WORK BUT THEY ARE A MEMBER
OF THE **** MOVEMENT AND THEY
CELEBRATED ALSO ALERTS THAT ARE
SENT TO SOME TAKING A- INTO AN
EXTREME EXAMPLE THAT
UNFORTUNATE DOES EXIST- WHAT
GOT EM. SAWYER- BE ABLE TO RE
ON. THE PERSON A MEMBER THE NOT
MOVEMENT TO GET TO. AND ALL
TIME IN THE IN THE SECOND PART
OF IT HAVING SOMEONE WHO IS-
SIMPLY. AND THEN THEY FIND OUT
THAT THEY'RE THAT THEY'RE THEY
WERE PARTICIPATING IN A ****
MARCHERS IN VIOLENCE OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. BUT THERE
HAS BEEN A FULL **** MARCH WITH
SWASTIKAS CETERA WOULD IT BE
ABLE TO TERMINATE THAT PERSONS
OF THE SORT OF SIMILAR
QUESTIONS. OKAY I WILL AND-
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS AND THEN
I AM GONNA ASK MORGAN TO JUST
ADD ON TO THAT FROM A LEGAL
PERSPECTIVE- BUT AGAIN THIS
GOES BACK. TO- IT'S AN EXTREME
EXAMPLE THAT WAS GIVEN IN THE
ANALYSIS BUT NONETHELESS THAT'S
YOU KNOW. THE ONE WE WILL-
ADDRESS A- IT IS. UNLIKELY THAT
SOMEONE WHO IS A MEMBER OF THE
**** MOVEMENT WOULD WANT TO GO
WORK FOR A NERD OR ON
ORGANIZATION THAT- YOU KNOW HAS
THE EXACT OPPOSITE VIEWS BUT
FOR THE PURPOSES OF ARGUMENT-
I'M EMPLOYER STILL HAS THE
RIGHT TO VIEW YOU KNOW YOU AS A
CANDIDATE FOR EMPLOYMENT. IN
YOUR ENTIRETY NOT JUST WHAT'S
ON THE PAPER BUT HOW YOU COME
ACROSS IN THE INTERVIEW WHAT
YOUR INTERESTS ARE HOW WILL YOU
INTERACT WITH THE REST OF THE
EMPLOYEES HOW YOU FIT IN. TO
THAT PLACE OF BUSINESS WILL IT
BE A GOOD FIT FOR EVERYONE
INVOLVED IT'S NOT. THE IT'S IN
THE SO IT'S NOT BASED JUST ON
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE PART OF
SOME- MOVEMENT AND IT'S ALSO
NOT BASED ON JUST THE FACT THAT
YOU HAVE THE CERTAIN
EDUCATIONAL DEGREE THAT IS
REQUIRED OF THE JOB THERE ARE A
WHOLE HOST OF THINGS. THAT ARE
CONSIDERED- MORGAN DO YOU WANT
TO TAP IN ON THE LEGAL. AGAIN
SENATOR GOING FORWARD I THINK
PART OF MY ANSWER WOULD DRAW
FROM WHAT I PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED TO THE CHAIRS THAT.
IN PERSPECTIVE WE HIRING
SOMEONE NORTH- AN EMPLOYER
COULD. PROBABLY RATIONALLY
CONCLUDE BASED NON NOT ON
DISCRIMINATORY REASONS THAT
HIRING THIS PERSON WITH THESE
EXTREME IDEOLOGICAL BELIEFS AND
NATIONAL SOCIALISM WOULD SIMPLY
BE A BAD CANDIDATE FOR
EMPLOYMENT AT YOUR OFFICE
BECAUSE OF. HOW IT WOULD AFFECT
ALL OF THE OTHER EMPLOYEES BUT
AS TO THE QUESTION ABOUT. COULD
AN EMPLOYER TAKING ANY ADVERSE
ACTION AGAINST THE EMPLOYEE FOR
THEIR OFF. FURTHER THEY'RE
ACTIVE IN THE POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES WERE. BELIEVES
OUTSIDE OF WORK. BASED ON WHAT
I READ IN THE LABOR CODE
SECTIONS ELEVEN OH ONE ELEVEN
OH TWO AND SOME OF THE CASE
LAWS THAT DISCUSSES IT THAT
WOULD BE PROHIBITED AND THAT'S
ALREADY CURRENT LAW THERE'S
ALREADY BROUGHT BROUGHT
PROVISIONS. IN CURRENT LAW THAT
ENJOYING. LAWYERS FROM.
PENALIZING THEIR EMPLOYEES FOR.
THEIR THEIR PERSONAL POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES ABSENT ANY OTHER
EVIDENCE THAT IT IMPEDES THE
WORKPLACE. AND IF I COULD
FOLLOW UP SO APART FROM.
DISSIPATION OF FORMAL ACTIVITY
LIKE SAY I'M A MEMBER OF THIS
PARTY WHAT ABOUT THEIR AGAIN
OFFICE OFFICE HOURS ARE JUST
POSTING THINGS ON SOCIAL MEDIA-
POSTING YOU KNOW. POSTING FOR
EXAMPLE IT'LL TELLER WAS YOU
KNOW THE GREATEST LEADER EVER
OR- OR YOU KNOW THE- YOU KNOW
DAD. YOU KNOW JEWS AND LGBTQ
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ROUNDED UP AND
PUTTING CANCER WHATEVER VIEWS
SOMEONE MIGHT. HAVE OFF HOURS
ON THEIR PERSONAL SOCIAL MEDIA-
THAT'S EXPRESSING. POLITICAL
OPINION WHAT EMPLOYER BE ABLE
TO SAY YOU KNOW WHY YOU CAN'T
WORK HERE ANYMORE- BECAUSE THAT
IS SO ANTITHETICAL. TO ONE YOU
KNOW THE VALUES OF INCLUDE OF
EXCLUSIVITY OF OUR OF THE
GROCERY STORE THAT. I'VE YOUR
CASHIER- ABSE ANY DIRECT
EVIDENCE THAT IT IS CAUSING
PROBLEMS REAL PROBLEMS IN THE
WORKPLACE- JUST BASED ON. WHAT
I'VE SEEN WITH THE LABOR CODE I
DON'T BELIEVE THEY COULD NOW
I'M- RIGHT AND THAT'S SAYING
RETURNING ABOUT CURRENT LAW NOT
MUCH WHAT THIS BILL DOES. SO
ALTHOUGH I DON'T KNOW IF THE
MARKET. DISPUTE ABOUT THAT BUT
I PROJECT A VERY FRANK OKAY I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE RECORD
THIS BILL DOESN'T ADDRESS YOU
KNOW OUR CHANGE WHAT THE
QUESTION THAT YOU'RE ASKING
EXISTING LAW ALREADY ADDRESSES
AT AND I WOULD ALSO JUST CHIME
IN AND AGAIN I'M NOT AN
ATTORNEY BUT- IF. WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING NINE STATEMENTS MADE
ABOUT IN ANTI SEMITIC
STATEMENTS AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE THAT. I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT FALLS INTO THE REALM OF
POLITICAL IDEOLOGY AS MUCH AS
IT DOES- YOU KNOW FROM AN- HM
YEAH I MEAN THAT'S A WHOLE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES- AND I
DIDN'T UNFORTUNATELY ANTI
SEMITISM KNOWS NOT ONLY ONE
POLITICAL PARTY SOUND. ALREADY
THANK YOU A SINGLE FOR THE
MICROPHONE CENTREBOARD
DISPOSABLE RAZOR MICROPHONE UP
SIR BORDERS. YES I WAS GONNA
AND ON THE MOVE THE BILL RIGHT
SURFBOARDS SUPPOSED TO BILL- ON
SATURDAY FOR THE DISCUSS
SEVERAL INTO. CHEMICALS AM I DO
CHAIR THING YOU- I WANNA THINK
YOU FOR THE DISH OF DEBATE WANT
TO THANK YOU WHO IN AND SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- I.
IF I REALLY TRULY BELIEVE THAT
WE GO THE CIVIL THE- EXCUSE ME
THE UNRUH- CIVIL RIGHTS ACT.
YOU KNOW ALREADY STATED THIS IS
PROTECTED I DO FEEL WE DO MAKE
NEED TO MAKE THIS DECLARATION
WITHIN OUR CODE- TODAY'S VOTE.
IF THE BAIL IF THE BILL FAILS
HI YOU KNOW MY FEAR IS IT'S
GOING TO GIVE A GREEN LIGHT TO
FROM. CENSORSHIP THEINTENT OF
THIS BILL IS TO ALLOW THE FREE
EXCHANGE EXCHANGE OF IDEAS
AMONGST A POPULATION FULL OF
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES AND OUR
COUNTRY IS FOUNDED ON THESE
PRINCIPLES THAT'S WHY WE THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE CONSIDER
OURSELVES A DELIBERATIVE BODY.
I AM AN ORGANIZATION A MEMBERS
FREELY CAPABLE AND WILLING TO
DEBATE IDEAS AND THIS IS MOST
CERTAINLY AN IDEA WORKS
PRESERVING. WE SHOULD NOT
DIMINISH YOUR SUPPORT ACTIVE
SILENCING AND CENSORSHIP SO
SENATORS- I WILL LEAVE YOU WITH
THIS THOUGHT. AS WE ALL KNOW
SOCIAL MEDIA SO THE FACEBOOKS
INSTAGRAMS TWITTERS OF THE
WORLD THEY ARE COMMON
COMMUNICATION MEDIUMS NOT ONLY
FOR US FOR CHILDREN. AND
IMAGINE IT TEN YEARS FROM NOW.
TWELVE YEARS FIFTEEN YEARS YOU
KNOW WHEN THOSE CHILDREN.
BECOME ADULTS CENTER PLAYING
FOR THEIR DREAM JOB IN A TWEET
IS DISCOVERED SEEING HOW THEY
SUPPORTED YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
OR USE SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI-
OR YOU CENTER BORJAS. AND THEY
WERE DENIED THAT JOB BECAUSE OF
THEIR DECLARATION OF THAT
SUPPORT. AND THEN IMAGINE HOW
YOU WOULD FEEL IF YOU KNEW TEN
YEARS AGO THAT YOU HAD THE
POWER TO ENSURE SOMETHING LIKE
THAT WOULD NOT HAPPEN TO THEM-
TODAY'S TARGETS ARE ONE
PARTICULAR GROUP. TOMORROW'S
TARGETS COULD BE AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT GROUP AND I DO THINK
IT IS TIME THAT WE SET THE
POLITICAL. DIFFERENCES ASIDE
AND RECOGNIZE THIS FOR THE
PROBLEM THAT IT IS BECOMING AN
ADDRESS IT NOW AND ADDRESS IT
SWIFTLY AND WITH THAT I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SIR
MELINDA'S- CHIEF COUNSEL
ESTRADA WE CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. IS THAT SPEED TO THIRTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR MELENDEZ-
MOTION SENATOR BOARD YES THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE ALL.
AMBERG NO PORGES. GORGEOUS HI
TELL YET- CARRY IT OR NOT
VOTING AWESOME. NO THE SO YOU
KNOW GONZALEZ NOW GONZALEZ NO.
JONES LAYERED STERN WAIT
HEALTHCARE E. L. Y. CASKEY NO
WIENER NO WIENER NO SO FAR YOU
HAVE ONE TO FIVE WE'LL WE'LL
PUT THAT BILL ON CALL ON THE
NEXT RETURNED TO SENDER
MELINDA'S BILL SB TWO FORTY
NINE. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
ON THE PHONE- WISHING TO
TESTIFY ON S. B. TWO FORTY NINE
WE HAVE SOME CHALLENGES OF THE
PREVIOUS BILL. SO WE WILL TAKE.
TESTIMONY PROP FROM THOSE WHO
ARE THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TWO MINUTES EACH AND
THEN. OPPOSITION AND THEN FOR
THOSE ON THE PHONE IF YOU WILL
DIAL IN- AND FOLLOW THE PROMPTS.
PROVIDE US YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
SO- SEN LINDA'S SB TWO FORTY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND BEFORE I BEGIN WITH THIS
BILL I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT I REQUESTED
RECONSIDERATION OF A BILL TO
SAYS B. TWO THIRTY EIGHT- IS
THERE IS THERE A MOTION. IN
CENTER BOARD JUST MOVES
RECONSIDERATION WITHOUT
OBJECTION ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH- I SAID THIS IS GOING
TO SOUND A LITTLE FAMILIAR
SINCE I'VE ALREADY GONE THROUGH
HALF OF THIS ONCE ALREADY SO
BEAR WITH ME. BY MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL TWO
FORTY NINE THE INTELLECTUAL
DIVERSITY ACT WHICH SEEKS TO
ADDRESS DISCRIMINATION BASED
UPON POLITICAL AFFILIATION AND
OUR SCHOOLS. ARE SCHOOLS AND
CLASSROOMS ARE OFTEN THE
BIRTHPLACE OF IDEAS IN
POLITICAL FIGHTS THE PROVIDER
STUDENTS WITH EXPOSURE TO ALL
IDEAS AND PERSPECTIVES A
CENTURY THAT SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED AND ENCOURAGED.
HOWEVER TODAY E ARE SEEING FOR
TOO MANY PROFESSORS AND
TEACHERS DO THE OPPOSITE. THE I
JUST THE OTHER DAY IT WAS
REPORTED AS SEEN DIEGO TEACHER
WAS OVERHEARD ON ZOOM BE
READING A STUDENTS PARENTS.
BECAUSE THEY WERE EXPRESSING
THEIR- DISPLEASURE WITH THE
HYBRID LEARNING AND WANTED FULL
IN PERSON LEARNING. THE PARENT
WHO EXPOSES T. WAS QUOTED AS
SAYING I HELD ON TO THE VIDEO
FOR THREE MONTHS AND HARDLY
TOLD A SOUL. RETALIATION
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATION CODE
PROTECTS VARIOUS
CHARACTERISTICS FROM BOWLING
SUCH AS RELIGION AND ETHNICITY.
BUT IT DOES NOT INCLUDE ONE
POLITICAL VIEWPOINT OR
AFFILIATIONS. IF WE ARE GOING
TO ALLOW SIXTEEN YEAR OLDS TO
PRE REGISTER TO VOTE WHILE IN
HIGH SCHOOL. THEY SHOULD BE
FREE OF BOWLING FROM TEACHERS
AND FELLOW STUDENTS REGARDING
THEIR POLITICAL AFFILIATIONS.
THIS IMPLEMENTS AND NEGATIVITY
IS MORE VISIBLE. ON OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
HARVARD STUDENTS TRYING TO
PREVENT. RAMPANT MINISTRATION
OFFICIALS FROM APPEARING AS-SPEAKERS ON THEIR CAMPUS EVEN
THEIR SEVEN U. S. PRESIDENTS
HAVE CALLED HER IT'S ALMA MATER
INCLUDING. PRESIDENTS OBAMA
GEORGE W. BUSH AND JOHN F.
KENNEDY. IN TWENTY TWENTY
ANOTHER PETITION BY HARVARD
STUDENTS ATTEMPTED TO HAVE. THE
EDUCATIONAL DEGREES OF TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
REVOKED. NOW AS I SAID EARLIER
THIS IS A PRIVATE INSTITUTION
CAN THEY DO THIS YES OF COURSE
THEY CAN'T SHOULD THEY BE DOING
THIS NOW SHE WE BE. ENCOURAGING
AND TRYING TO MOTIVATE THEM TO
NOT ENGAGE IN THIS TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR IN CALIFORNIA
ABSOLUTELY JUST LIKE WE DO WITH
A WHOLE HOST OF OTHER ISSUES.
THE MISSION STATEMENT FOR UCLA
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING. IT SAYS
TO FULFILL THIS MISSION UCLA'S
COMMITTED TO ACADEMIC FREEDOM
IN ITS FULLEST TERMS WE VALUE
OPEN ACCESS TO INFORMATION FREE
AND LIVELY DEBATE CONDUCTED
WITH MUTUAL RESPECT FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FREEDOM FROM
INTOLERANCE AND ALL OUR
PURSUITS WE STRIVE AT ONCE FOR
EXCELLENCE AND DIVERSITY
RECOGNIZING THAT OPENNESS AND
INCLUSION PRODUCE TRUE QUALITY
QUALITY. CALIFORNIA IS NOT THE
ONLY STATE TO CONFRONT THIS
GROWING PROBLEM IN MONTANA
THERE GOVERNOR SIGNED TWO BILLS
THAT AIM TO PROTECT FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION AND ASSOCIATION ON
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES IN
THE STATE. IT FOR UNIVERSITY
FROM DENYING RETIREES. TO
RELIGIOUS POLITICAL OR
IDEOLOGICAL STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS EVEN IF THEY HOLD
VIEWS THE OTHER STUDENTS MAY
FIND OFFENSIVE. THE NORTH
DAKOTA HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
PASSED A BILL PROHIBITING
ACTIVITY FEE FUNDING
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON.
A
STUDENT ORGANIZATIONS VIEWPOINT.
COOLEY HAD TO SETTLE A LAWSUIT
FOR CHANGE FOR CHARGING A
SECURITY FEE. FOR BEN SHAPIRO
THAT WAS SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
THAN THE FEE THAT THEY CHARGE
FOR SUPREME COURT JUSTICE SONIA
SOTOMAYOR. OUR THOUGHTS IN
BELIEF SYSTEMS ARE FACING
CENSORSHIP CANCELLATION AND
ATTACKS AND IT IS TIME TO
PROTECT THEM HOW CAN WE EXPECT
OUR STUDENTS TO LEAVE OUR
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES.
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT OTHER
PERSPECTIVES AND THOUGHTS EXIST
IF WE ALLOW THIS SELF SILENCING
OR BULLYING TO CONTINUE. SB TWO
FORTY NINE MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
WE VALUE THE EDUCATION OF OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR EXPOSURE TO
OPINIONS OF OTHERS. EVEN IF WE
DON'T AGREE WITH THAT. IT ALSO
ENSURES THAT EDUCATORS CAN NOT
RETALIATING IN STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS ON CAMPUS BASED
UPON THEIR POLITICAL
AFFILIATION OR BELIEFS. TODAY'S
HYPERPARTISAN AND POLARIZED
WORLD IS ONLY EXASPERATING THE
TRANS OF ONE SIDED DIALOGUES
THAT IF LEFT UNCHECKED. IT'S I
MEAN WE'RE IN COURSE TO DESTROY
THE VERY FABRIC OF OUR COUNTRY
AND THE THINGS THAT WE BELIEVE
IN. HERE TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE IS CHRIS ACOSTA
STUDENT WHO INJECTS PRINCE'S
FIRST HAND MR WILL WAIT FROM
PRAGER UNIVERSITY- HE WAS
WITNESSES. HAND HIMSELF THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- AND I
BELIEVE MY WITNESSES ARE READY
TO TESTIFY. THANK YOU CENTER
MELINDA'S- MISTER. IT'S LOW
COST AND MISTER WITH IF YOU ARE
THE PHONE WILL BE- FORTY TWO
MINUTES EACH. MISTER WITH
MISTER RECALLS. AT YOU MISTER
SENATOR MY EXPECT MY SUPPORT
BILL TWO FORTY NINE I CONTACT
SEVERAL AND OF TWO TWENTY ONE I
WAS DROPPED FROM AN ON MY
COMPUTERS CLASS AT COLLEGE THE-
MICRO FELIX ONE THAT COMMENTED
ON OF MY TIME THAT NEED TO
CHANGE BROKER AT TIME APPROACH.
I NEVER CORPORATE MONTH
POLITICAL BELIEVES RADIOLOGY
AND IN MY SENSE I WOULD SIMPLY
DROP FOR SUPPORTING THE
PRESIDENT ONLINE PROFILE
PICTURE AFTER BEING DROPPED IN
THE CLASSIC MEDIALLY LOOKED FOR
ANSWERS AS TO WHY AND I TURNED
OTHER PROFESSORS WHO ASSURED ME
THAT THERE WAS NOTHING IN
SCHOOLS WILL BUT THAT WOULD
JUST HAVE BEEN DROPPED FROM THE
CLASS. AFTER I WAS SURE THAT
WAS DROPPED OR DISCRIMINATE
YOU'RE- A DISCRIMINATORY REASON
I FILED ALL THE NECESSARY
GRIEVANCE. PAPERWORK WITH THE
SCHOOL I RECEIVED NOTHING FROM
SCHOOL AND WITH THE DEADLINE TO
MIGRATE MACHINE LEARNING I
CONTACTED. SENATOR WHO BOUGHT
TO HELP ME GET BACK IN THE
CLASS. ONE EXPERIENCE I HAD
WITH THIS PROFESSOR IN THE
CLEAR VIOLATION OF FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS IT WAS A
PAINFUL REMINDER THAT IN
TODAY'S HYPER POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT IT'S REPUBLICANS
COULD FACE AN UPHILL BATTLE. I
THINK EVERY DAY EVERY DAY JUST
TO HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. I'M EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL TO BETTER MELENDEZ
THANK YOU COULD. YOU COULD
FORTY NINE BECAUSE IT OFFERS
ALONG WITH THE POLITICAL
PROTECTION STUDENTS. ADDING
CRITICAL CONDITION TO LOOK AT.
THE CHARACTERISTICS WITHIN THE
EDUCATION CODE WON'T JUST COVER
CONSERVING. IT COMES EVERYONE.
COLLEGES AND SHOULD BE TO TRY
TO OPEN OUR MINDS EVERYTHING
THE DOCTOR NOT PROTECT PEOPLE'S
FEELINGS FROM IDEAS THAT CHECK
TO. I'M NOT THE ONLY STUDENT TO
EXPERIENCE SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
ANY CONSERVATIVE FRIENDS WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED THE SAME WAY
MANY OF THEM ARE SCARED TO COME
FORWARD OR SPEAK ABOUT THE
BRANCHES BUT I FEEL. THAT IT'S
NECESSARY FOR SOMEONE TO SPEAK
OUT. YOU GOT YOUR NOTE AMEMBER
OF THE THEY'RE STILL BE. ON OF
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE.
CONSERVATIVE AND POSSIBLY.
PRESIDENTIAL OCULUS STORY WE
SHOT A LOT OF GOOD EVEN IF THE
DISK WITH FIVE BUT MATTER I'M
WRONG OR DO YOU ATTORNEY BY
PRESS. THANK EVEN OTHER
STUDENTS LIMON A PRETENSE. ARE
WE ALL TO DEBATE YEAH. ABOUT
YOU GUYS FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
TECHNICAL FORTY NINE DANGER ALL
OF THE HELP STUDENTS REGARD
WHAT AFFILIATION. THANK YOU.
MISTER CALLS. MR WITT. MISTER
WHERE ARE YOU WITH US.
MODERATORS MISTER WITH ON THE
PHONE. IF MR WHICH APPEARS OF
WILL TURN TO THE GALLERY THAN
ROOM ONE TWELVE MISTER WITH
APPEARS WILL PROVIDE HIM WITH
THE- OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
BOB WAS ANYONE THE GALLERY
WHICH IS A TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO FOUR NINE. NOW HOW
ABOUT ROOM ONE TWELVE NO. ALL
RIGHT LET'S TURN THE PHONE
LINES MISTER MODERATORS MISTER
WITH AVAILABLE. ALL RIGHT LET'S
BEGIN PHONE TESTIMONY OF MISTER
WILL APPEARS WILL WILL TAKE HIS
TESTIMONY ALL RIGHT. THOSE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FOUR NINE. IN THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO FOUR NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WILL START
WITH WINE THREE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN HERE.
BECAUSE RACHEL CORCORAN AND I'M
AN ATTORNEY AND HIGH COURT THE
BILL THANK YOU. THE NEXT OVER
THE LINE THREE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE SO- CONCERNED
CITIZEN AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
WILL GO TO WARREN THREE OH TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANNY YES GO
AHEAD GO AHEAD- YEAH HI THIS IS
JENNIFER GREGORY AND I LIVE IN
LOVE OR ANY AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE STUFF. THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT TWO SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON THIS IS
ROCKY PROCURED FROM CALIFORNIA
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ACTUAL ONE ONE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS BECKY CARNEY FROM
NEWPORT BEACH I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY NINE THE
MARGIN CHORE YEAH. THANK YOU.
PLEXCOIN ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SHERRY
SHIED FROM SOUTH LAKE TAHOE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY NINE.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ABOUT TEN
MORE IN Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GEORGIE. I AM NOT CITIZENS IN
COLLEGE COUNTY AND I'M A
SURVIVOR OF CHINESE COMMUNITY
CUT CHINA COMMUNIST PARTY
MONITORING CAN ON THE SQUARE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE DEAL
BECAUSE- OF THE FREEDOM I AM
SPEAKING. IN THIS COUNTRY THANK
YOU. YES A LITTLE LINE THREE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS BRENDA BROWN I'M A
TEACHER AND POSSIBLE CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONG SUPPORT AT THE TWO
FORTY NINE. THANK YOU. FLEX A
LITTLE ONE THREE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES THIS
IS A- HI THIS IS TONY ROSE ALL
OF THE CAPITOL RESOURCE
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF SB TWO FORTY NINE. THANK YOU.
TRANSACTION DECLINED THREE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
THREE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTER AN IDOL WRECKS
HAVE TURNED HIS COMPUTER AND
THREE TIMES TODAY ALL RIGHT
MA'AM GO AHEAD MA'AM GO AHEAD
YOU'RE ON- MY NAME IS NANCY
MANSION IN A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWO
FORTY NINE AND URGED COMMITTEE
TO VOTE YES THANK YOU. MEXICO
TO LINE FOR SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHICAGO COMMITTEE CURE
FROM- MURRIETA CALIFORNIA AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO FORTY NINE ENERGY SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT A
LITTLE NINE THREE EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS LEE
AGAIN VERY IN CHINO HILLS
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
I WOULD APPRECIATE A YES VOTE
ON THIS ON SB TWO FORTY NINE A
STRONG SUPPORTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT OVER THE
LINE THREE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS B. SAYS
THAT AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT. AND I SUPPORTED
COMMITTEE VOTING YES SUPPORTING
SB TWO FORTY NINE IS NOT
SUPPORTED TO ME THAT WOULD BE
PROMOTING CENSORSHIP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT TO THE LINE
THREE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE THREE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS THE
BEYOND ONE POINT THREE MILLION
IN CALIFORNIA AND I AND
SUPPORT- SB TWO FORTY NINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR I'M INFORMED MR WITT
HAS DIALED BACK IN. IF MR WITT
IS ON BUT LET'S GO AHEAD AND
ALLOW HIM TO TESTIFY- IF HE'S
NOT WILL CONTINUE AND THEN IF
HE WILL I SUPPOSE DIALING AGAIN.
SO MISTER MODERATORS MISTER
WITH AVAILABLE. CHECKING JUST A
MOMENT.
OKAY IF HE'S THERE
COULD HIT ONE THEN ZERO. RIGHT
BUT LET WHILE WE CONTINUE WITH
THE CALL IN WITNESSES. AND THEN
I WILL COME BACK TO SEE IF
MISTER WHICH IS ON THE LINE. I
MISS MODERATOR GO HEAD. OKAY
WELL WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
STRUCTURE OF THIS TELEGRAM IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
TWENTY THREE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS MAN GO AHEAD. ALL
RIGHT LET'S MOVE THE NEXT
CALLER. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JUST. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. I AND MY NAME IS
PEGGY WILSON AND- MY HUSBAND
OWNS A SMALL BUSINESS YEAR AND
JENNA BARBARA AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF BILL CHIU
FORTY NINE I URGE THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR IT. ARE NOW
AGREEING WITH THE OTHER WOMAN
SHOULD NOT VOTE FOR THIS YEAH
HI THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S GO
TO THE NEXT CALLER. IN MEXICO
LINE FOR SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FOUR SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO. YES GO AHEAD
DESPITE FOR SIXTY. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE GET A GO
AHEAD. GREAT MY NAME IS JACKIE
I. AM IN FAVOR OF STT FORTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. MEXICO LINE FOR SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LISA POSSIBLE WITH INTACT AND
WE SUPPORT SB TWO FOUR NINE
THANK YOU. THE NEXT LITTLE AND
THREE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ME. HELLO LAST YEAR WHEN
IT'S OPEN THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU VERY YES WE CAN. I AM SO
SORRY GOOD AFTERNOON AARON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BY MARCELLA
CLARK I ANSWERED NOT CALIFORNIA
I AM THE WIFE OF A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND I ALSO OWN A
SMALL BUSINESS MYSELF. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
I STRONGLY. SUPPORT EIGHT THREE
TWO FORTY NINE AND I GET MULLIN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALL
PLEASE. OKAY JUST ONE MOMENT.
THIS MODERATE DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE ONLINE. AND LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE LINED. THREE TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS RON
EDWARDS FOR THE CALIFORNIA AND
I SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE MISSED MODERATOR.
YES WE HAVE LINE FOR SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GET
AFTERNOON THIS IS LISA NAVARRO
FROM CHINO HILLS CALIFORNIA AND
I JUST WANTED TO OFFER MY
STRONG SUPPORTER SB TWO FORTY
NINE THANK YOU. HI ANYONE ELSE.
IT LOOKS LIKE. WE HAVE TWO MORE
THOSE QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT SHE
GOT A LINE TO TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE SAID OKAY THEN SENT
AGAIN- I THINK THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL BECAUSE THE
CALLER BUT ABLE TO CURRENT
THANK YOU MA'AM ARE YOU IN
SUPPORT. I AM IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BYE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. S.
B. WE'RE GOING TO TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI LARRY
CULTURAL NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ANDERSON I'M IN SUPPORT OF IT
HE TO FORTY NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COLLISION HERE. ALL RIGHT IF IS
THAT WE LOCATED MISTER
WITNESSED MODERATOR. HE IS ON
THE MAIN LINE- MY SERVICING BE
ASKING TO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
HE WILL BE ABLE TO COMMENT. ALL
RIGHT SO MISTER WHICH IF YOU
CAN HEAR ME IF YOU PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AND WILL YOUR
TESTIMONY. IN THE MEANTIME IS
MATER IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO FORTY NINE.
JUST A MOMENT I'M NOT SURE. IF
WE HAVE ONE SHOWING UP FOR THAT
FOR. IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A
LINE FOR SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT IS TIME FOR. SOME
PEOPLE IT HI YES YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION. YEAH MY NAME IS WILL
WED I'M A POLITICAL COMMENTATOR
CULTURAL COMMENTATOR FOR OREGON
RESIDENT WE MISTER WITT
WELCOME- YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU SO I WANTED TO COME
ON AND TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
EXAMPLES OF. CONSERVATIVES
BEING. CENSORED AND BEING
TREATED UNFAIRLY ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES IT'S ACTUALLY A
RAMPANT PROBLEM THAT I KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T LIKE TO
KNOWLEDGE BUT SHE'S ACTUALLY
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT JUST LAST
WEEK AT MY ATTENTION- BLACK
LIVES MATTER PROTESTERS CAME
DESTROYED THE EVENT AND THEN
THEY ENDED UP KICKING ME OFF OF
CAMPUS. BECAUSE I WAS MAKING
PEOPLE ON SAFE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WORKED WITH
BLACK LIVES MATTER WE HAVE AN
EXAMPLE OF VERY SCARED YOU KNOW
WHO GOT BAD GRADES BECAUSE A
PROFESSOR TOLD US THAT THE
CONSTITUTION WAS IN A GOOD
SOURCE OF INFORMATION WOULD YOU
TRY TO USE IN A PUBLIC SPEAKING
CLASS WITH RYAN PALMER
SUSPENDED FROM HIS HIGH SCHOOL
FOR A WEEK. FOR DEFENDING HIS
CONSERVATIVE BELIEFS THAT THE
SCHOOL LABELED AS HATE SPEECH
COOLEY JAMISON HARASSED BY
STUDENTS FOR HER CONSERVATIVE
POLICE AND ALL THE SITUATIONS I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO REMIND YOU
ALL THAT THE PROFESSORS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION SAID NOTHING SO
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES OF COURSE
CHILDREN FIGHT IN THEIR
DIFFERENCES IN POLITICAL
OPINIONS THAT'S ALL WELL AND
GOOD. BUT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO THE
PROFESSORS AREN'T SUPPORTING
STUDENTS BEING ABLE TO HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION THAT'S
WHERE YOU HAVE A REAL PROBLEM
WE HAVE DANIEL SUBPOENA CAL
STATE MONTEREY BAY WAS FORCED
TO QUIT A WATER POLO TEAM
BECAUSE YOUR COACH AND ALL THE
OTHER STUDENTS. ON THE TEAM
WERE ALL ON THE FAR LEFT. INBECAUSE SHE WAS A CONSERVE. SHE
BALK THERE AND YOU. FRENCH IS A
STATE- I PROFESSOR MARKETS
RELIGIONS AND CONSERVATIVE
VIEWPOINTS DURING CLASS. AND IS
IT OKAY STILL SILENCERS IN
CLASS BY PROFESSORS FOR BEING
CONSERVATIVE. AT CSUF. THIS
HAPPENS ALL OVER ALL THE TIME
WHERE CONSERVATIVES BEING
CENSORED FREE SPEECH AND
EXPRESSION. SHOULD BE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF AMERICANS
EDUCATION THE SADLY THAT'S-
DEFINITELY NOT THE CASE HERE IN
AMERICA AND WHAT THE STUDENTS
ARE HAILED AS BRAVE AND STRONG.
WHAT CONSERVATIVE STUDENTS ARE
SHUNNED AND PUNISHED FOR HAVING
A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION. IF THE
DEMOCRATS AND EVERYONE HERE
WANTED TO REALLY SUPPORT FREE
SPEECH. AND THAT AND INACTION
MEANINGFUL CHANGE AND THEY
WOULD LOOK TO ADVANCE THE
SANCTITY OF FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION FOR ALL STUDENTS ON
CAMPUS. NOT JUST ELECTED. EVEN.
THE CONSERVATIVE ONES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER WITH. ALL
RIGHT MISS MODERATOR IF WE GO
BACK TO THE PHONE LINES. ON I
REALIZE THIS IS BEEN A BIT
DISJOINTED BUT WE HAVE TWO MORE
MINUTES SO GO AHEAD. OTHER ANY
ANYONE ELSE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO FOUR NINE.
ONE FOUR THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MARYLAND-
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FORTY NINE AND AT THE AGE OF
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A LINE THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THESE GREAT- TESTIMONIES THAT
HAVE COME FORWARD THANK YOU
<c.magenta>A'AM. THOUGHT AMANDA TAX</c>
CALLED PLEASE. IT'S NOT EVEN
HERE THANK YOU MA'AM. SIX
COLLEGES ONE MOMENT WE WOULD
GIVE THE LINE NUMBER. OKAY
WE'LL GO TO LINE FOR TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS MARYLAND I'M CALLING
FROM STANFORD NO COUNTY. AND
SUPPORT OF BILLS CHIU FORTY
NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
WE HAVE NO OTHER COLORS AND
CHIARI THANK YOU- LET'S NOW
TURN TO THE CHAMBER. BOTH I'M
SORRY OPPOSITION YES- I HAVE NO
ONE LISTED IN PRINCIPLE
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO FORTY NINE
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE IN
A PRINCIPAL WITNESS. HEARING
NONE ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN TO
THE GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY SEE NO WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
OPPOSITION. LET'S NOW TURN TO
THE PHONE LINES THOSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWO FORTY NINE PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR PHILLY A SHOP IN
YOUR POSITION. MISTER MODERATOR.
AND FOR OPPOSITION WE HAVE
LINED THREE FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT RIGHT. ONE
THREE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD HELLO. YES. HI I'M IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL BECAUSE
IT'LL LET THE DEVIL OR THE
PITFALLS AND HOUSE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER.
WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME OKAY. ALL RIGHT NOW
LET'S COME BACK TO THE CHAMBER.
ANYONE WISHING TO ASK QUESTIONS
COMMENTS I SEE OF CENTER BOARD
JUST AS YOUR MICROPHONE UP
CENTER BORDERS. AND SENATOR
JONES LET'S GO TO SIR JOHN'S
FIRST. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I JUST WANTED TO- RECOGNIZE
THE AUTHOR ON THIS BILL THIS IS
THIS IS IN THE SPEAKER THAT
CALLED IN MISTER WITT THIS IS
A- YEAH I THINK A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL- I'M REMEMBERING
BACK- WHEN I WAS A SINGLE
STATE. I WAS A SENIOR STATE
NINETEEN NINETY NINETEEN NINETY
ONE WHEN PETE WILSON WAS
GOVERNOR. AND THEY WERE
REBUILDING THE BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION BUILDING- THAT
YEAR SO THERE IS A BIG WOODEN
WALL AROUND THE CONSTRUCTION
SITE OF THE BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION BUILDING WHICH I
WAS THAT'S WHAT I WAS MAJORING
IN SO. I WAS THERE QUITE A BIT
AND THE STUDENTS HAD TAKEN. IT
UPON THEMSELVES TO MAKE IT AT A
WALL A FIRST AMENDMENT
EXPRESSION WALL I DON'T KNOW IF
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
COLLEGE EVER THOUGHT THE TEST
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN OR NOT. BUT
BUT THOSE OF YOU MAY REMEMBER
PETE WILSON WASN'T SO POPULAR
WITH COLLEGE STUDENTS BACK THEN
I WASN'T POLITICALLY ACTIVE-
WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE- NOR
MOTIVATED BUT I DID APPRECIATE
THE- THE DIALOGUE OR THE DEBATE
OR CONTROVERSY OR- YOU KNOW
JUST WATCHING THE DIFFERENT
SIDES OF THE ISSUE AND THE
ISSUE BACK THEN WAS A PRETTY
SIMPLE ONE- P. WILSON- AND THE
LEGISLATURE WAS RAISING FEES AT
THE ON THE CSU SYSTEM- FAIRLY
DRAMATICALLY. AND ALLOW THE
STUDENTS DID APPRECIATE THAT I
THINK EVEN ONE DAY- AND I DON'T
THINK I WOULD AGREE WITH THIS
BUT IT I BELIEVE IT'S PROTECTED
BY THE FIRST MINUTE THEY THEY
BURNT AN EFFIGY OF. PETE WILSON
I THOUGHT THAT WAS- UNFORTUNATE.
BUT- THE DIALOGUE WAS IMPORTANT
AND THE DEBATE WAS IMPORTANT
AND I THINK THAT IT ADDED
CERTAINLY TO MY EXPERIENCE AS A
COLLEGE STUDENT- AS AN AS AN
ENGAGED COLLEGE STUDENT EITHER
SIDE OF THE ISSUE- BUT FOR THE
FOLKS THAT WERE ENGAGED ON THE
EITHER SIDE OF THE SHOULD
CERTAINLY WAS IMPORTANT FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD. MY OLDEST SON AND
MY DAUGHTER BOTH OF GRADUATE
FROM ST YOU STATE NOW MY OLDEST
SON WHEN HE GOT TO SENIOR STATE
ABOUT. EIGHT YEARS AGO I HIS
FIRST. SEMESTER THERE WAS A
RELIGIOUS DEBATE GOING ON A PRO
LIFE- PRO ABORTION DEBATE GOING
ON. ON CAMPUS AND- HE ENGAGED
IN THAT CONVERSATION. AND
REALLY- AND THAT THAT GOT TO BE
A VERY SERIOUS CONVERSATION BUT
AGAIN. IT WAS HEALTHY- IT WAS
IT'S PROTECTED UNDER FIRST
AMENDMENT. AND IS ADDS TO. THE
DOOR OF WHAT MAKES AMERICA
GREAT IS THIS ABILITY FOR.
OPPOSING VIEWS. TO BE ABLE TO
ENGAGE SOMETIMES A VERY
PASSIONATE- BUT PEACEFUL
MANNER. AND SO I I'M I'M GONNA
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL I'LL
MAKE THE MOTION FOR APPROVAL
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE MISTER
CHAIR AND- JUST WANTED TO I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR. WORKING
SO DILIGENTLY ON THESE FREE
SPEECH ISSUES THANK YOU RIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER JOHNSON OR
JOHNS CENTER BORDERS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN. OR MAKE CERTAIN THAT
WE- TAKE A STEP BACK THE- S. B.
444-494-4249 EXCUSE ME. IS NOT
TWO THREE EIGHT THEY'RE TOTALLY
DIFFERENT PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
WITH- I THINK. DRAMATICALLY
DIFFERENT- CIRCUMSTANCES I KNOW
IN THE LAST BILL THERE WAS-
SOME WORST CASE SCENARIOS THAT
WERE BROUGHT FORWARD I THINK IT
MEANS LESS SOME FOLKS A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE- I WILL I
PARTICULARLY WASN'T BUT I THINK
SOME FOLKS MAY HAVE BEEN. BUT
TWO FOUR NINE IS TOTALLY
DIFFERENT. AND I'VE MENTIONED
THIS ON THE FOR MANY TIMES- I
TAUGHT FOR OVER TEN YEARS AND I
GOTTA TELL YOU SOMETHING THAT.
THE MARKET PLACE OF IDEAS IN
SCHOOLS. SEEMS TO BE DEGRADED
AT LEAST TO ME. NOW I HAPPEN TO
GO TO VERY LIBERAL ARTS SCHOOLS
WHEN I WAS GOING THROUGH MY
COLLEGE GRAD AND POST GRAD
EXPERIENCE. BUT ESPECIALLY LAW
SCHOOL PROFESSORS WANT. YOU TO
ENGAGE ON ON ISSUES CAN TAKE
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES EVEN IF
YOU DISAGREED WITH THEM THEY
WOULD ASK YOU TO TAKE THE
OPPOSITE PERSPECTIVE. AND
FASHION AN ARGUMENT EVEN THOUGH
YOU PERSONALLY DISAGREED WITH
THAT. I THOUGHT THAT WAS
FANTASTIC TRAINING AND I THINK
WHAT THIS DOES IS IT HIGHLIGHTS
THE NEED FOR US TO FOSTER IN
OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM. THAT SENSE
THAT WE NEED TO EXPLORE AND BE
EXPOSED TO THESE DIFFERENT
IDEAS. ARM AND NOT ALLOW FOR
THERE TO BE A PREVAILING WISDOM
CULTURE AND I THINK THAT IT HAS
CERTAINLY TAKEN ITS COURSE.
WHERE YOU MAY OF PHILLY- IN ONE
DIRECTION ON THE SPECTRUM OR
WHATEVER- WHATEVER PART OF THE
COUNTRY YOU MAY LIVE IN I THINK
THAT IS DANGEROUS AND WE SHOULD
FIGHT THAT AT EVERY TURN.
BECAUSE I WANT WHEN MY BOYS GO
TO SCHOOL. I WANT THEM TO BE
CHALLENGED. BECAUSE IF THEY ARE
PART OF THE PREVAILING WISDOM.
PROCESS WITHIN THEIR NOT GOING
TO BE CHALLENGED APPROPRIATELY
INTELLECTUALLY. AND I WANT THAT
TO HAPPEN. I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
EVERY SCHOOL IS FOSTERING THAT
APPROACH AND I THINK WHAT THIS
DOES IS IT REINFORCES THAT THAT
THIS THAT SCHOOLS ARE PETRI
DISHES THEIR EXPERIMENTS OF
THOUGHT. THAT IS THE BEAUTY OF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE EXPERIENCE
WHICH MAKES IT THE GOLD
STANDARD AROUND THE GLOBE. AND
I THINK THAT OVER GENERATIONS
THAT HAS SUBSIDED SOMEWHAT AND
I DON'T LIKE IT. SO I THINK
WHAT THIS DOES IT REALLY
REAFFIRMS THAT IF YOU HAVE AN
AFFILIATION FOR A MIND SET. ON
THAT YOU WERE GIVEN. A DEGREE
OF EQUAL PROTECTION IN THE
EDUCATIONAL INTELLECTUAL
PROCESS AND I THINK THAT IS
IMPORTANT BUT FOR THOSE OF OU
WHO MIGHT STILL BE IN THE
MINDSET OF THE LAST BILL. WE
WERE DEALING WITH. THIS IS
DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT ONCE
AGAIN. IT FURTHER SPECIFIES TWO
FOUR NINE DOES FURTHER
SPECIFIES THAT NO PERSON SHALL
BE SUBJECTED TO DISCRIMINATION
ON THE BASIS OF THEIR POLITICAL
IF IT FILIATION ANY PROGRAM OR
ACTIVITY CONDUCTED BY AN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION. HATE
SPEECH AND HATE ORGANIZATIONS.
ARE NOT ALLOWED. IN IN- IN IN
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES YOU
MAY HAVE INDIVIDUALS AT A
SPELLS THOSE THINGS BUT
ORGANIZATIONALLY- THEY'RE NOT
TO BE PERMITTED TO THIS IS
DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT I THINK
THE CONCERNS THAT WE HEARD
BEFORE SHOULD BE RELATIVELY
ASSUAGED BY THIS AND IF WE ARE
FUNDING STATE PROGRAMS I WANT
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT WE HAVE
CRITICAL THINKERS AND WE CAN'T
DO THAT. IF WE ALLOW
INTELLECTUAL INERTIA TO BE THE
DOMINANT CULTURE OF COLLEGE.
THANK YOU SIR BORDERS ASSEMBLY
CASKEY. MISTER CAREY. I
APPRECIATE THE INTELLECTUALS A
CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENT AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO- AS- WITH
DESIRE AND I DO TOO HAVE A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR I'M ON
PAGE EIGHT OF THE STAFF REPORT.
TALKING RAISING THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER WE'RE GING TO BE
MANDATING. NEW TRIP- POLITICAL
NEUTRALITY- AND IF THAT WAS IS
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT. AND IS IT
TOO I GUESS CN EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS BE SUED- UNDER THE
BILL F THE PROGRAMS AND-
ACTIVITIES ARE NOT POLITICALLY
NEUTRAL MEDICAL WITHIN ABOUT.
SEVEN FORCE TALKS ABOUT IF YOU.
HAVE ONE PAGE OF KARL MARX
SHIFT HAVE. ONE PAGE OF ADAM
SMITH AND IF IT'S NOT. FIFTY
FIFTY THAT YOU- OF CAUSE OF
ACTION MAY ARISE SO I'D BE
INTERESTED IN IT. AUTHORS
OPINION. MR YES CENTER
MELINDA'S THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU CENTER
ACCOUNTS YOU FOR THE QUESTION-
IS SO NO THE BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE POLITICAL NEUTRALITY
ANYMORE DAN SCHOOLS ARE
REQUIRED TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE YOU KNOW A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS IN IN
TEACHING THE CLASSES A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF LIBERTARIANS WE DON'T
REQUIRE THAT THIS IS NOT
REQUIRING POLITICAL NEUTRALITY
THIS IS REQUIRING- FAIRNESS AND
HOUSE ALL STUDENTS ARE TREATED
IRRESPECTIVE OF THEIR-
POLITICAL IDEOLOGY OR BELIEFS I
WANT TO- COMMENT THOUGH ON
BECAUSE A LOT OF DISCUSSION HAS
BEEN TAKING PLACE ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS- AND I YOU
KNOW I WILL TELL YOU. ARE I WAS
A BIT TAKEN ABACK AT THE
EXTREME EXAMPLES THAT WERE
GIVEN IN THE ANALYSIS AND IT.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A THIS IS A
TOPIC WORTHY OF DISCUSSION AYE.
AYE I JUST WAS CURIOUS AS TO
WHY SUCH EXTREME EXAMPLES WERE
USED- TO DEBATE THIS VERY REAL
ISSUE AND- I. YOU KNOW I WILL
JUST TELL YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN-
ON A PERSONAL LEVEL I FOUND I
THINK WE CAN DO COMMITTEE
ANALYSES WITHOUT- OUR SUCH
VULGARITIES EXPRESSED I DON'T
THINK THAT WAS NECESSARY I
THINK THAT WAS OVER THE TOP AS
A WOMAN I WAS OFFENDED I WAS
INSULTED I'M SURE THE FEMALE
MEMBERS OF MY STAFF. DIDN'T
APPRECIATE SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
THAT WAS USED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS I GET THAT HE WAS
TRYING TO MAKE THAT POINT. BE
THAT AS IT MAY I THOUGHT I
WOULD GO ON THE RECORD AND SAY
THAT BUT MR RIGHT COMES KEY TO
YOUR POINT IT DOES NOT REQUIRE
POLITICAL NEUTRALITY AB GRADE
IF EVERYBODY WAS YOU KNOW A
LITTLE MORE OPEN MINDED IN
NATURE BUT THAT'S JUST NT
REALITY. WE CAN LEGISLATE THAT
EVEN IF WE TRIED. ALL RIGHT I
SEE NO THEIR MICROPHONES UP
YOUR COMMON DESERT CENTER
MELINDA'S- CENTER JONES HAS
MOVED THE BILL- SETTLED
MELENDEZ BEFORE YOU CLOSE AND I
HATE TO. CREATE ANY CONFUSION
HERE BUT GOING BACK TO THE
PREVIOUS BILL THE OTHER WAS
MOTION FOR RECONSIDERATION.
THAT MOTION IS NOT PROPER UNTIL
THERE'S BEEN AN ACTUAL
DETERMINATION OF THE FATE OF
THE BILL AND SO AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I ASSUME THAT
MOTION WILL BE RENEWED- BUT
LET'S NOW TURN TO. S. B. TWO
FORTY NINE FOR YOUR CLOTHES IF
YOU SHOULD SO CHOOSE WONDERFUL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- I
WILL TRY TO BE BRIEF IN MY
COMMENTS I KNOW YOU HAVE MANY
MORE BILLS TO GO THROUGH SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU- FOR THE VERY
BRIEF DEBATE THAT WE HAD ON
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. AND WE'VE
SPENT A LARGE PART OF THIS
AFTERNOON SO FOR DISCUSSING
WHAT I VIEW TO BE A VERY
CHALLENGING ISSUE TO TACKLE
WHICH IS YOU KNOW WHAT IS
SPEECH IN WHAT SHOULD OR
SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. IF STUDENTS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO EXPLORE VALUE AND
BELIEF SYSTEMS THAT ARE NOT
THEIR OWN IT'S GOING TO LIMIT
THEIR EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE.
AND THAT'S NOT- GOING TO HELP
THEM CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO
HELP THOSE. WHO THEY MAY
EVENTUALLY WORK FOR. THAT
NOBODY IS ASKING FOR A QUOTA
SYSTEM OR A TALLY. OF RENO
REPUBLICANS VERSUS DEMOCRATS
VERSUS LIBERTARIANS IS FOR ITS
SPEAKERS ARE INFLUENCERS ARE
TEACHERS. NO ONE IS CALLING FOR
EQUITABLE RATIOS- OF PROFESSORS
TO BE HIRED ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
EITHER WHAT I WE ARE CALLING
FOR IN THIS BILL. IS TONING
DOWN THE RHETORIC ON OUR
CLASSROOMS AT SEEK TO
CHALLENGER SILENCE VIEWS THAT
HAPPEN TO BE DIFFERENT. WE
EXCUSE ME PRESIDENT BARACK
OBAMA. SAID AT A TOWN HALL IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THESE ARE
HIS WORDS. I DON'T AGREE THAT
YOU WHEN YOU BECOME STUDENTS AT
COLLEGES. HAVE TO BE CODDLED
AND PROTECTED FROM DIFFERENT
POINTS OF VIEW. HE WAS
DISCUSSING HOW COLLEGES ARE NOT
JUST SPACES FOR LEARNING
SKILLS. BUT ABOUT BROADENING IN
KNOWLEDGE BASE WHEN HE SAID
FURTHER THAT THE WAY TO DO THAT
IS TO CREATE A SPACE. FOR A LOT
OF IDEAS ARE PRESENTED AND THEY
COLLIDED PEOPLE ARE HAVING
ARGUMENTS IN PEOPLE ARE TESTING
EACH OTHER'S THEORIES IN
OVERTIME. LEARN FROM ONE
ANOTHER. THIS IS WHAT WE WANT
OUT OF OUR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AND IN OUR
CLASSROOMS- I WILL CLOSE WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ROAD AND ALSO NOTES TO YOU ALL
ONCE AGAIN THAT THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SAM LINDA'S- SHE
COUNCIL STRATEGY CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS S. B. TWO FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR MELENDEZ WITH A MOTION
BY SENATOR JONES THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION-
BURKE- THE ADDAMS. ADVISORY
COUNCIL I SEE IT SENATORS STERN
IS HERE SO LET ME GO OVER- HIS
PARTICIPATION- SENATOR STERN.
AYE AYE CITY YOU'RE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY DO YOU
HAVE A STAFF MEMBER THAT'S
PRESENT WITH YOU. I DO IT'S MY
DISTRICT DIRECTOR JENNY WOLF
ALL RIGHT- I THINK YOU KNOW THE
PROTOCOL FOR DISSIPATING
REMOTELY PART THANK YOU.
BENCHING COUNSEL IF YOU CALL
THE ROLL YES THE MOTION ON SB
TWO FORTY NINE IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION. UMBERG
HELP AMBERG NO PURCHASE ON
PORTIS I GOT A YELLOW. DID I
SELL. GONZALEZ NOW GONZALEZ NO
HERTZBERG. JONES HI JONES I
LAYERED NO LAYERED NO STERN- NO
STERN NO WHITE HOUSE SKI NO
WHITE HOUSE SKI NO WIENER NO
WIENER NO YOU HAVE TO DO. FOR
ABOUT TWO TO SIX WITH SOME
FOLKS NOT SOME SENATORS NOT
VOTING ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL THANK SYMBOL IN THIS
ALL RIGHT- WELL I SEE CENTER
NOBODY'S BEEN HERE FOR A WHILE.
SB SIX SIXTY JUST- FOR
INFORMATIONAL PURPOSES. THOSE
OF YOU THAT CONCERNED ABOUT
TIME WE ARE ON TRACK TO FINISH
BEFORE THE FIRST COMMITTEES
MEET TOMORROW MORNING AT NINE
AM JUST SO YOU KNOW. SO ALL
RIGHT. SEVEN NEWMAN SB. SIX
SIXTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS- I'M
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF SB SIX
SIX ZERO AS THE CHAIR HAS
ALREADY NOTED I HAD ANOTHER
BILL SB SIX SIX THREE WHICH I
HAVE WITHDRAWN. THEIR VERY
DIFFERENT BILLS AND SO SB SIX
X. THREE IS NOW TO YOUR BILL-
UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF S. B.
SINCE. SB SIX SIX THREE IS A TO
YOUR BILL CORRECT THAT IS
CORRECT SIR I JUST TOOK SB SIX
SIX ZERO IS TODAY'S BILL. IT'S
A TODAY BILL. UNDER ITS
PROVISIONS SB SIX SIX ZERO.
WILL ELIMINATE COMMON PRACTICE
IN THE GATHERING OF SIGNATURES.
FOR BALLOT MEASURES WHICH
INCENTIVIZE THE WILLFUL
DECEPTION OF VOTERS. SB SIX
SIXTY WILL TAKE NECESSARY
IMPORTANT STEPS TOWARDS
SAFEGUARDING THE INTEGRITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S INITIATIVE.
REFERENDUM AND RECALL PROCESS
WHICH- CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF A
NUMBER OF STATES WHOSE
CONSTITUTIONS EXPRESS REVISED
ITS CITIZENS WITH TOOLS TO
DIRECTLY ADDRESS ABUSES OF
GOVERNMENT OR MALFEASANCE. BY
PUBLIC OFFICIALS IN THE FORM OF
THE INITIATIVE THE REFERENDUM
AND THE RECALL EFFORT SOME
HISTORICAL BACKGROUND AND
CONTEXT. AS YOU MAY BE AWARE
THESE ADMIRABLE AND USEFUL
CONSTITUTIONAL DIRECT DEMOCRACY
PROVISIONS DATE BACK MORE THAN
A CENTURY. WHAT ARE THE RESULTS
OF THE EFFORTS OF A GROUP OF
PROGRESSIVE REFORMERS LED BY
THEN GOVERNOR HIRAM JOHNSON.
WHO THEN WENT ON TO BECOME
CALIFORNIA'S LONGEST SERVING
REPRESENTED THE UNITED STATES
SENATE. UNTIL HIS TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS IN OFFICE WAS RECENTLY
ECLIPSED BY OUR OWN CENTER
DIANNE FEINSTEIN. AS A RESULT
OF THE HEROIC EFFORTS OF
GOVERNOR JOHNSON AND HIS
SUPPORTERS. CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTITUTION THROUGH THE
INITIATIVE REFERENDUM AND
RECALL MAKES EXPLICIT
PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW FOR THE
CITIZEN READ TO TAKE ACTIONS
OUTSIDE OF THE NORMAL
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. IN ORDER
TO ENACT OR REPEAL LEGISLATION
OR TO REMOVE A CORRUPT OR
MALFEASANCE ELECTED OFFICIAL
FROM OFFICE. TO THE ORIGINAL
FRAMERS WAY OF THINKING THE
INITIATIVE REFERENDUM AND
RECALL REPRESENTED A MEANS FOR
THE LITTLE GUY. TO ACHIEVE
DIRECT CURATIVE AND REFORMIST
ACTIONS THAT ELECTED INVESTED
INTEREST MIGHT OTHERWISE SPORT.
BECAUSE THE FRAMERS OF THE
INITIATIVE REFERENDUM AND
RECALL REGARD THESE PROCESSES
AS POPULIST ACTIONS OF LAST
RESORT. THE DELIVERY PROVIDED
THAT IN ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR
THE BALLOT PROPONENTS OF ANY OF
THESE DIRECT TO THE VOTERS
PLEASE BESIDES. WOULD FIRST BE
REQUIRED TO GATHER A SUFFICIENT
NUMBER OF VOTER SIGNATURES TO
VALIDATE THE LEGITIMACY AND
POPULAR SUPPORT FOR SUCH AN
ACTION. OVER THE YEARS
ESPECIALLY IN RECENT DECADES
HOWEVER SOMETHING VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THE FRAMERS
INTENDED HAS TRANSPIRED THESE
TOOLS ARE DIRECTOR MARCUS C.
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED. BY THE VERY.
MONEY INTEREST THEY WERE
ORIGINALLY CREATED TO OFF SET.
AS THESE FUNDED GROUP WITH X.
INCREASINGLY EXPLICIT SELF
INTERESTED MOTIVATIONS HAVE
BECOME EVER MORE ADEPT AT
USING. THE INITIATIVE
REFERENDUM AND RECALL PROCESS
IS TO THEIR BENEFIT. SOMETHING
OF AN ARMS RACE AROUND THESE
PROCESSES HAS ENSUED ESPECIALLY
AS IT PERTAINS TO SIGNATURE
GATHERING. AT THE CENTER OF
THESE EFFORTS A SMALL NUMBER OF
SPECIALIZED FIRMS WITH
EXPERTISE INSECURE GATHERING
HAVE RISEN TO THE FORE. AND
OFFER THEIR SERVICES TO REPORT
TO PROPONENTS SEEKING TO PLACE
A MEASURE ON THE BALLOT. ONE OF
THE PRINCIPAL TACTICS USED BY
THE SPECIALIZED ENGINEERING
FIRMS IS THE DEPLOYMENT OF WELL
TRAINED PROFESSIONAL SIGNATURE
GATHERERS. TYPICALLY THE
SIGNATURE GATHERS ARE PAID ON A
PER SIGNATURE OR COMMISSION
BASIS ALSO KNOWN AS A BOUNTY.
AT A RATE DETERMINED BY THE
MARKET AS IT IS ASSESSED AT
THAT TIME. DEPENDING ON THE
NATURE THE INITIATIVE THE
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE DISTRICT
THAT TIME OF YEAR FOR
COMPETITION WITH OTHER
EMISSIONS AT ANY GIVEN TIME THE
COST PER SIGNATURE CAN VARY
WIDELY FROM AS LOW AS TWO
DOLLARS PER SIGNATURE GATHERED.
TO AS HIGH AS TWENTY DOLLARS.
BECAUSE BOUNTY PAID SIGNATURE
GATHERS ARE INCENTIVIZED TO
OPTIMIZE THEIR YIELD BASED ON
HOW RAPIDLY THEY CAN SECURE
SIGNATURES FROM VOTERS. THEY
FREQUENTLY TRAFFIC MISDIRECTION
MISLEADING INFORMATION AND
OUTRIGHT FALSEHOODS IN ORDER TO
INDUCE AS MANY VOTERS AS
POSSIBLE TO SIGN IN THE
MINIMUM. AMOUNT OF TIME.
AGAINST THIS BACKDROP THE
DETERMINING FACTOR GETTING
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT TOO OFTEN
HAS LESS TO DO WITH ITS POLICY
MERITS. IN THE DEPTH OF ITS
PROPONENTS POCKETS OF COURSE
THIS ISN'T EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE
OF WHAT THE FRAMERS ORIGINALLY
HAD IN MIND. AS THE DIRECT
RESULT OF THESE PERVERSE
INCENTIVES THE PAPER SIGNATURE
SYSTEM HAS SUBVERTED THE
ORIGINAL IDEALISTIC INTENT. OF
CALIFORNIA'S FOUNDERS WHO
ENVISIONED A PEOPLE POWERED
SYSTEM OF REFERENDA IN
PROPOSITIONS VALIDATED BY
DEMONSTRATED PUBLIC SUPPORT.
AND WHICH WOULD SUCCEED OR FAIL
ON THEIR MERITS NOT ON HOW WELL
THE SYSTEM CAN BE GAMED.
INITIAL REFERENDUM AND RECALL
PROCESSES CAN AND SHOULD PLAY
AN IMPORTANT AND VALUED ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA POLITICS AND ITS
GOVERNANCE. IT HAS BECOME CLEAR
HOWEVER. THAT UNDER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM DRIVEN BY FOR SIGNATURE
ABOUT. THERE ARE SCANT. FOR
DETERRING ACTORS WHO WILLFULLY
MISLEAD VOTERS AT THE EXPENSE
OF THE INTEGRITY OF THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS. SB SIX SIXTY
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
PROHIBITING THE PRACTICE OF
PAYING SIGNATURE GATHERERS ON A
PER SIGNATURE BASIS WHEN
COLLECTING SIGNATURES. TO PLACE
A STATE OR LOCAL INITIATIVE
REFERENDUM A RECALL ON THE
BALLOT. TO BE CLEAR THIS
MEASURE WOULD NOT PROHIBIT
PAYMENT FOR SIGNATURE GATHERING
THAT IS NOT BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF SIGNATURES OBTAINED
SIGNATURE GATHERS COULD STILL
BE PAID. AN HOURLY WAGE OR
SALARY AT THE DISCRETION OF THE
PROPONENT. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE ASSURANCE AND
TRANSPARENCY TO THE VOTERS AND
ITS ENFORCEMENT PROVISION WILL
PRINT PERMIT BOTH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. AND ANY PERSON TO
BRING A CIVIL CLAIM UNDER THE
SECTION FOR PERSECUTION PAYMENT
PRACTICES. EMPLOYERS WHO
VIOLATE THE PROVISIONS OF SB
SIX SIXTY WOULD BE SUBJECT TO A
FINE OF TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. OR FIFTY DOLLARS PER
SIGNATURE FRAUDULENT GATHERED
WHICHEVER AMOUNT IS GREATER.
THIS GOOD GOVERNMENT MEASURE
WILL SERVE TO STRENGTHEN OUR
RECALL REFERENDUM AND INITIAL
PROCESS BY ENSURING THAT VOTERS
ARE AWARE OF EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'RE SIGNING. AND NOT BEING
DECEIVED. ULTIMATELY SB SIX
SIXTY WILL HELP TO RESTORE
INTEGRITY AND PUBLIC CONFIDENCE
IN CALIFORNIA'S PROVISIONS FOR
DIRECT DEMOCRACY. OTHER STATES
SUCH AS COLORADO MONTANA AND
OREGON HAVE ALREADY EXAMINED
THE ISSUE SURROUNDING PAID
SIGNATURE GATHERS AND ADOPTED
LEGISLATION PROHIBITING PERSON
SHOULD DOWNEY PAYMENTS.
REQUIRING INSTEAD THAT PAYMENT
FOR SIGNATURE GATHERING MAY
ONLY BE MADE ON AN HOURLY OR
SALARIED BASIS. IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO DO THE SAME. OUR
DEMOCRACY AND OUR GOVERNMENTS
WILL BE THE BETTER FOR IT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THIS AFTERNOON. THANK YOU
CENTER NEWMAN- STAND THERE ARE
NO PRIMER WITNESSES THAT IS
ADDRESS IT. ALL RIGHT- THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES THE GALLERY
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES THE- MISTER
MODERATOR YOU. LIKE TO UP THE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SIXTY. OF THE U. THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINES PLEASE PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
MISTER MODERATOR. AND WE HAVE
LINES THREE EIGHTY SEVEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN. ONE IS OPEN THREE
DAYS OF. LOS COLINAS COLOR. THE
NEXT COLOR BE LINE TO FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ADMINISTRATION THE GUY IN THE
LINEUP CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
MAC MAC BAKER INTENT WAS CLEAR
THIRTY TWO YEARS AGO. I KNOW MY
FELLOW COLLEGE STUDENTS LOST
THEIR LIVES WITH THE FREEMEN
THANK YOU SIR ARE YOU ON THE
BOARD OF SB SIX SIXTY. THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO THE NEXT
CALLER. WE HAVE KNOWN NONE
OTHERS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN OPPOSITION
I HAVE NO OPPOSITION WITNESSES
LISTED HERE- I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO
LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE LINES.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD TURN THE
PHONE LINES FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. SIX SIXTY.
OPPOSITION OF SIX SIXTY WE HAV
LINE THREE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. ONE THREE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT NEXT
WITNESS. LINE THREE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THREE
NINETY SIX. RACHEL CORCORAN I'M
AN ATTORNEY AND I OPPOSE. THE
BILL THANK YOU. NEXT YEAR ONE
THREE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS JOHN
CULLUM I'M CONSTITUENTS OF
MISTER NEWMAN FROM POTENTIAL
I'M AYE OPPOSED LEGISLATION.
FOUR FIVE SIX SIX ZERO I
BELIEVE THANK YOU SIR ALL RIGHT
TO GO THE NEXT CALLER. AND NEXT
ONE IS TWO THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I AM HEARING IS
FRESHER WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. NEXT. SIX ZERO
ONE THREE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS WEEKEND HERE
AND I AM ALSO CONSTITUENTS
INNER NEWMAN'S I AM ENOUGH
OPPOSITION TO USE SB SIX
SIXTEEN APPRECIATED NOBLE
CLEATS THANK YOU. IN MEXICO
LINE FOR- TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE FOUR OH TWO. HELLO YES TO
GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS BEEN
HELD IN SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX-
I REPRESENT CDC DOGO FOR
QUESTION COURSE LAST WEEK WE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
IT ANTI CAPITALIST THANK YOU
SIR NEXT CALL. ACTUALLY GO TO
LINE ONE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME THIRTY
KEARNEY AND I'M AND SENATOR MAN
DISTRICT AND I OPPOSE THE SIX
SIXTY THANK YOU. SPECIAL ONE
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH WE WILL OPEN SANTA
BARBARA CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SMARTER IF YOU GIVE US AN
ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY CALLERS
DURING Q. THAT WOULD BE GREAT
LET'S GO THE NEXT CALLER. BUT
LIKE WE HAVE THREE MORE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THE LINE
THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. TWENTY THREE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SCOTT KAUFMAN OUR DRIVERS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION OPPOSED
THANK YOU. SPECIAL LINES FIVE
OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS A BEYOND A MONCADA
CALLING FRIEND HERE TO
CALIFORNIA AND I AM STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANKS TO GET ONLINE TO
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
THIS IS K. THEN ST FROM PALM
DESERT I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE FOR
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARYLAND AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I'M
CALLING FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. I HAVE
NO THE OTHERS YOU CAN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WILL GIVE A COUPLE
SECONDS HERE ANYBODY ELSE LINED
UP INTO THE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. SIX SIXTY.
ALL RIGHT I SEE LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE FLOOR I SEE SIR
WHAT COUNTS HIS MICROPHONE IS
OFFICER ONE CASKEY MESSAGER
HAVE TWO QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR ONE NOTWITHSTANDING THE
FACT THAT I HAVE VOTED FOR
THESE BILLS- IN THE PAST. AS A
LEGISLATOR GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER GOVERNOR BROWN
AND GOVERNOR FEET- NEWMAN OUR
NEW SOME HAVE SUB PRESCIENT GO
AHEAD OF. YOU HAVE A- DETAILED
MEASURES PREVIOUSLY PASSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND SHOWING
THEIR RELUCTANCE TO. ERECT
BARRIERS TO CITIZENS
PARTICIPATION I'D LIKE TO HEAR
FROM THE AUTHORS- RESPONSE TO
HIS SIDE. THE EXERCISE IN FACT
NOT SATISFYING THE GOVERNOR.
BUT IT'S A NEWMAN AND THANK YOU
MR SENT AWAY BECAUSE HE- AS YOU
NOTED SIMILAR BILLS HAVE BEEN
FEATURED IN THE PAST THE VETO
MESSAGES TYPICALLY- HAVE- SURE
FOCUSED ON ON ONE OF TWO POINT.
ONE WAS GONNA AND YOU'VE HEARD
I FOR THIS ANY OPPOSITION TO
ALL THAT THERE IS INSUFFICIENT
DOCUMENTATION OF FRAUD WITHIN
THE- THE IN A PAPER SIGNATURE-
BUT PROCESS- WHICH-
UNFORTUNATELY IS THE CASE- BUT
ONLY INSOFAR AS IT'S VERY HARD
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM. TO
INSTIGATE PROSECUTION OR ANY
OTHER ACTION AGAINST A
FRAUDULENT SIGNATURE GATHERING
PRODUCT OF PRACTICES THAT THE
SECOND. AND PROBABLY MORE
COMMONLY REFERENCED ARGUMENT IS
THAT IT WOULD RAISE THE COSTS.
OF DIRECT DMOCRACY BY LIMITING
THIS PARTICULAR PRODUCT PROCESS
WHICH IS REGARDED AS MORE
EFFICIENT AND THEREFORE MORE
COST EFFECTIVE THAN OTHERS. AND
I WOULD POINT OUT A COUPLE
THINGS ONE IS. THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF THE FRAMERS ACTUALLY
DID NOT CONSIDER COST. AS A AS
A METRIC OR BASIS FOR
VALIDATING AND AFTER IT WAS
WITH THE YOU KNOW THEY
ESTABLISHED. UNDER THE
PROVISIONS FOR THE RECALL
INITIATIVE THE REFERENDUM EIGHT
TO LIVE REALLY RIGOROUS
THRESHOLD OF SIGNATURES OR
SHARE OF THE BRITISH FOR
ELECTRIC THE PRIOR ELECTION.
AND IF YOU COULD SECURE THOSE.
IF OU COULD MEET THAT
THRESHOLD IT WAS VIEWED AS
VALIDATION OF THE JSON
LEGITIMACY AND VALUE OF AN
EFFORT. AT NO TIME IN NINETEEN
TWELVE TODAY ANTICIPATE THE
CHANGES WHICH WERE TO COME UP
AND IN PARTICULAR THE ABILITY
TO RAISE MONEY TO DO SO
DIGITALLY- AND THEN TO HIRE
SPECIALIZED FIRMS THAT. HAD
EXPERTISE. AND HIGHLY TRAINED
PERSONNEL IN THE CONDUCT OF
THESE EFFORTS. AND SO. THE
INCENTIVES THAT THE SYSTEM
CREATES FAR CLEARLY DISTORT IF
I THINK ANYBODY WHO HAS
ENCOUNTERED A SIGNATURE GATHER
IN FRONT OF YOUR LOCAL GROCERY
STORE AS HAD SOME EXPERIENCE OF
KIND OF THAT THE THREE CARD
MONTE- OF HAVING PETITIONS
PRESENTED TO YOU EXPLAINED IN A
VERY QUICK WAY PLEASE SIMPLY
SON. AND THE REASON IT'S DONE
THAT WAY IS BECAUSE THE-
PRACTITIONERS GET PAID PER
SIGNATURE. AND THE BEST MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO OPTIMIZE THEIR
YIELD. IS TO TALK QUICKLY INTO
SAY WHATEVER IT TAKES FOR YOU
AS- A CITIZEN CROSSING THEIR
PATHS TO SIGN. AND SUBMIT THE
YOU KNOW THAT THIS ARGUMENT
THAT YOU KNOW IT'S SOMEHOW THAT
THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
THEREFORE THE FAIREST WAY TO DO
THIS. I WOULD ARGUE IS FLAWED
AND I THINK IT'S PROOF OF THAT-
I WILL CITE. A PARTICULAR
EFFORTS OF THE- EFFORT THAT
ACTUALLY SUCCEEDED IN GETTING
PROP TWENTY FOUR. ON THE LAST
BALLOT I THINK IT'S VERY
TELLING THEM INSTANTLY A
GENTLEMAN NAMED ALASTAIR
MACTAGGART. WHO'S A REAL ESTATE
DEVELOPER BASED IN SAN
FRANCISCO. FILED A BALLOT
INITIATIVE THAT HE CONTRIBUTE
FREE MILLION DOLLARS WHICH
SPENT A TOTAL OF ONE POINT SIX
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
COLLECT SIGNATURES THAT THEY
CAME DOWN TO FOUR DOLLARS AND
FORTY SIX. CENTS PER REQUIRED
SIGNATURE AND IN SO DOING HE
WAS ABLE TO LEVERAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO NEGOTIATE WITH
HIM DIRECTLY- AND TO PUT THE
PROPOSITION ON THE BALLOT. AND
IT IS EXPECTED THE CHANGE
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY LAWS UNDER
THREAT OF THE USE OF MONEY. TO
EXPLOIT THESE CONSTITUTION
REVISIONS WHICH IN NO TIME
ANTICIPATED ANY OF THIS. THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION YOU KNOW
WHY HAVE PREVIOUS GOVERNOR'S.
VETO THE BILL- I DON'T KNOW THE
DATE FULLY CONSIDERED. THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS PRACTICE.
AND I THINK OVER TIME YOU KNOW
DATING BACK TO SENDER LANDAU UP
THROUGH THE MOST RECENT EFFORTS
I THINK THE NET IMPACT OF THIS
PRACTICE HAS BECOME CLEAR OVER
TIME. AS WE BECOME MORE AWARE
OF THE ABUSES THAT THIS
PRACTICE TENDS TO ELICIT. THE
SECOND QUESTION IS CHAIR ALL
RIGHT BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A
CLUSTER OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS HIGH PAYING
FOR VALUE BUT- YOU KNOW THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS IS
SUPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE EVEN AT THE LOWER
LEVEL. IT WILL HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT ON DIRECT DEMOCRACY AND
IF THE AUTHOR COULD. COMMENT ON
THAT I MEAN THEY THEY INDICATED
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY. DIRECT
EVIDENCE OF SEVERE FRAUD OR
HOWEVER THEY FREE THE FREE STEP
BUT BUT ON THE JUST THE- GARDEN
VARIETY SORT OF RECALL
INITIATIVE ON A LOCAL LEVEL
DATE. OR NOT THEY'RE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CHILLING
EFFECT VERSUS THE HIGH PAID YOU
KNOW STATEWIDE ISSUES H. I. I.
I'M SORRY BUT I'M NOT SURE WHAT
WHAT YOU'RE. DESCRIBING WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU FOR THE CHILLING
EFFECT. WELL THE LEAD BELIEVES
THAT IMPEDING COMPENSATION FOR
SIGNATURE GATHERERS FOR A
REFERENDUM A RECALL OR
INITIATIVE. COULD INTERFERE
WITH AND HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT
ON THE CITIZENS RIGHTS OF
DIRECT LEGISLATION THROUGH THE
INITIATIVE AND REFERENDUM
PROCESS AGAIN AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT SO. THAT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME
MISREPRESENTATION RECENTLY AS
TO THE- MECHANICS OF THIS BILL.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT PROHIBIT
THE PAYMENT OF SIX AGO. IT THAT
FIGURES TO BE PAID ON AN HOURLY
OR SOME OTHER BASIS YOU KNOW
NON COMMISSIONER NON
INCENTIVIZE BASIS. TO WHATEVER
EXTENT THE PROPONENTS FEELS
USEFUL AND EFFECTIVE IN
ACHIEVING THEIR GOALS. WHAT IT
ENDEAVORS TO DO IS TO REMOVE
THOSE. THOSE PERVERSE
INCENTIVES THAT I REFERRED TO
EARLIER. AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT
OBSERVE IN RESPONSE TO THE
LEAGUE'S COMPANIONSHIP
COMPLAINT- THE OPPOSITE MIGHT
BE TRUE. THAT THE VALIDATION OF
AN EFFORT TO PUT SOMETHING ON
THE BALLOT AT WHATEVER LEVEL.
IS MOST CREDIBLE BUT WHEN THE
PEOPLE INVOLVED ARE DOING IT
FOR THE RIGHT REASONS IN THE
RIGHT WAY. AND SO YOU KNOW I
I'M AGAIN. THAT THERE WAS A
CALLER WHO WHO. DESCRIBED THIS
IS ANTI CAPITALIST IT'S NO SUCH
THING. AGAIN THAT PROPONENTS
COULD PACING SHE GOES ANYWAY
WHAT WE WANNA DO IS ENSURE GOOD
ACTORS. AND TRANSPARENCY AND
INTEGRITY IN THAT REALLY. TRUE
TO OF COURSE THE SECTIONS IN A.
THANK YOU. BEING ANYONE ELSE I
SEE NO OTHER MICRO THREE IS
THERE MOTION SIR WHAT MOVES
BILL SIR NEWMAN CLOSE AGAIN IN
A THANK YOU MISTER SHE SO AS OF
MAY- OTHER STATES HAVE SIMILAR
EXAMINE THE IS YOU'RE PAGE
FIGURE. AHEAD OF LET'S FOR
CHRIS ABOUT PAYMENTS SECURE
THERE'S- I DO BELIEVE STRONGLY
AND I THINK YOU AGREE- THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNANCE IN ITS
POWER WILL BE IS YOUR MATE
URGED TODAY RISK ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU BECAUSE
ACCOUNTS HE'S MOVE THE BILL.
SHE CAN STRATEGIC THE ROLL THIS
IS A B. SIXTY BY SENATOR WITH
THE MOTION BY SEN WAIT GIVE
THEM IS PASS BUT FOR BE RE TO
THE COMMITTEE A PER. UMBERG BY
AMBERG I BORJA. CABALLERO
COMING INTO NOT VOTING IN ASAL
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HEARD. J.
THE JONES NO LAYERED I LAYERED
ICE. RIGHT. HAVE SB THREE
EIGHTY BY CENTER EGGMAN CENTER
EGGMAN THANK YOU ONE SECOND
LET'S CLEAN THE PODIUM. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE CENTER
EGGMAN. WE ARE MOVING ALONG AT
A RAPID CLIP. I THINK- I SAID A
MOMENT AGO WE SHOULD BE GOOD TO
MAKE THE NINE O'CLOCK COMMITTEE
HEARINGS TOMORROW I THINK WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE DONE BY AT
LEAST FIVE AM CELL. THANK YOU
SENATOR EGGMAN CLOSURES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
AFTERNOON AT MISTER HAIR AND
MEMBERS WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
A COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT
TEMPERATURE CAN DO YOU- EXCEPT
THE MEMBERS THIS PROPOSAL
ANALYSIS I DO PRESENT I DO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT SIGN.
THANK YOU VERY WELCOME. IS
GONNA SAY WHO WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT A COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT
PRESENTING AT MEDICAL AID IN
DYING WOULD BE THE LEAST
CONTROVERSIAL BILL. YOU'D BE
HEARING ON A- ON A COMMITTEE
DAY. BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT'S GONE
INTO THIS ON AGAIN EXCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS. AND I'M HERE TODAY
PRESENT SB THREE EIGHTY A BILL
THAT WILL MAKE SOME REVISIONS.
TO THE END OF LIFE OPTION ACT
THAT WAS AUTHORED. IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN I WENT INTO
THE- INTO EFFECT IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. SINCE INITIAL PASSAGE
OF THIS BILL AS AS I COMMITTED
I'VE HAD. AT LEAST TWO
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS AND HEARD
FROM. THE INPUT FROM.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT PROVIDERS HOSPITALS
PATIENTS FAMILIES AND MORE. AND
THROUGHOUT THOSE HEARINGS WE
DID FIND SOME THINGS THAT
NEEDED TO BE UPDATED AND
ADJUSTED. AND SO AFTER FIVE
YEARS OF IMPLEMENTATION THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE HERE TODAY TO DO-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS BET
WAS CONSISTENTLY IN IN COMING
UP WAS THE ISSUE OF SOMETIMES
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH TIME BETWEEN
THAT INITIAL ASK. AND WHEN THE
PATIENTS ACTUALLY ABLE TO.
UTILIZE AT THE ACT- STAY FROM
KAISER PERMANENTE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHOWS THAT ABOUT
APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD OF
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS TO
REQUEST THE AID IN DYING.
BEFORE IT DIES BEFORE
COMPLETING THE TIME CONSUMING
PROCESS WHICH INCLUDES A
FIFTEEN DAY PERIOD- IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. OREGON THE STATE OF
OREGON WHICH HAS OVER TWENTY
YEARS OF HAVING THIS IN EFFECT.
AUTHORIZED A WAIVER OF THE
FIFTEEN DAY WAITING PERIOD
BETWEEN ORAL REQUEST TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE- AND IN NEW MEXICO
ALSO JUST REDUCE THEIR WAITING
PERIOD TO TWENTY EIGHT TO ADD
FORTY EIGHT HOURS. AND THIS IS
OFTENTIMES A REAL. MAKE THE ASK
TO THEIR INITIAL PHYSICIAN THE
INITIAL ATTENDING PHYSICIAN
THINKING THAT PERSON IS GOING
TO. PARTICIPATE THAT PERSON AND
SAYS NO THEY DON'T HAVE TO TRY
TO FIND SOMEBODYELSE TO DO
THAT INITIAL ACT OF. THAT
SOMETIMES TAKES A WHILE AND
THEN TO WAIT AN ADDITIONAL
FIFTEEN DAYS BEFORE THE FIND
SOMEBODY ELSE. TO BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH. AND DURING THAT TIME
BECAUSE THIS THIS BILL BACK TO
REQUIRES THE PERSON SELF
ADMINISTER. SOMETIMES THAT TIME
THEY HAVE LOST THEIR BILLY TO
SWALLOW. TO THEIR HAND TO
MOUTHS. WERE VARIETY OTHER
THING I CAN PER. THEM FROM
BEING ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE LAW.
AS AS IT IS WRITTEN- SO WE
BELIEVE THAT FIFTEEN DAY
WAITING PERIOD IF CAN CAN BE
WAIVED. AND THAT IS WE'RE
SUGGESTING TO MOVE THAT TO
FORTY EIGHT HOURS INSTEAD-
THERE'S NO NEED FOR PEOPLE TO
SUFFER- NEED LISTING DURING
THAT TIME- ED. CURRENTLY
ANOTHER ISSUE AT THE END OF
LIFE OPTION ACT IS THE
PHYSICIAN NEEDS TO REMIND THEM
THE PERSON THAT THEY MAY NOT
TAKE IT AT A PUBLIC SETTING
SOMETIMES THIS PREVENTS
CONFUSION FOR HOSPITALS OR
OTHER HEALTH PROVIDER FOR
BUSINESS BECAUSE NOT IT
SHOULDN'T JUST BE OUTSIDE- BUT
CERTAINLY HEALTH CARE STANDARDS
SETTING IS ALL RIGHT IF THAT
HEALTHCARE SETTING PARTICIPATES
IN THE MEDICAL AID IN DYING
NOTHING IN THIS CHANGE- SAYS
THAT THE OF A HEALTH CARE
FACILITY MUST PARTICIPATE BUT
REDUCING THAT THE WITH THE
PHYSICIAN DOESN'T NEED TO
CONTINUE TO SAY THAT- AS- THIS
BILL WILL ALSO REQUIRE THAT THE
DATE OF ALL ORAL AND WRITTEN
REQUEST MUST BE DOCUMENTED.
ENSURING THAT TIME WE ASK
ACCESS SO THE PERSON PASSED
OFTENTIMES MISADVENTURE THAT'S
NOT DOCUMENTED SO THEN THERE
BECOMES A QUESTION WHEN DID
THAT FIFTEEN DAYS ACTUALLY
START SO THIS SAYS A POSITION
MUST DOCUMENT AT THAT TIME IF
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
PARTICIPATE- THEN THEY DOCUMENT
THAT AND THEN TRANSFER THE
PATIENT'S RECORDS IMMEDIATELY
UPON REQUEST AND FINALLY THIS
BILL WILL ALSO REPEAL THE
SUNSET DATE AGAIN THIS HAS BEEN
IN- IN EXISTENCE NOW IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OVER FIVE
YEARS WITH- ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
PEOPLE HAVE UTILIZED IT SO AS
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE IT'S A
VERY SMALL IT IS VERY-
TARGETED- BUT WE ALSO KNOW.
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO GET
THE PRESCRIPTION NEVER EVEN GO
THROUGH AND TAKE IT AT THE END
OF HAVING THAT PRESCRIPTION
THERE THAT PROVIDES THEM THE
PEACE OF MIND. THAT THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO DIE PEACEFULLY
AGAIN NOT EVERYBODY IS GOING TO
UTILIZE THIS BUT FOR PEOPLE WHO
DO. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE ACCESS AND THAT THE
BARRIERS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED. HAVE BEEN REMOVED.
THANK YOU SAID I CAN ESTIMATE
DR CHANDANA- BOB BANERJEE AND
JULIUS TRIAL. IS YOUR PRINCIPAL
WITNESSES IS THAT RIGHT. THAT'S
CORRECT YES. RIGHT CONDUCTED
BANERJEE'S ON. YEAH HERE OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FOR GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY HI MY NAME IS-
TRUMP ABOUT AGAIN I'M LIKE
THOUSAND PARTICIPATION IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
A VERY RECENTLY ELECTED
COMPASSIONATE TOWARDS THE BOARD
MEMBER AND I HAVE SUPPORTED
MULTIPLE PATIENTS IN THE OPTION
OF MEDICAL AID IN DYING OVER
THE YEARS I SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA SELECT OPTION AXE
AND MEDICAL AID IN DYING IN
CALIFORNIA FOR MY PATIENTS
BECAUSE IT'S A PART. TOOL FOR
VULNERABLE PATIENTS TO MAINTAIN
ECONOMY OVER WHAT'S HAPPENING
TO THEM AND THEIR. BODIES YOUR
IN THEIR LIVES BUT THE LAW
OBVIOUSLY TO BE IMPROVED THAT'S
THANK YOU BACK THEN THE DELL.
THREE EIGHTY NOT ALL TO. ARE
ABLE TO ACCESS OF LIKE I. THE
LAW CONTAINS FAR TOO MANY UP.
WILL BE TO ACCESS THE LOS DALY.
AND EXCESSIVELY. MANY DIE
NUMBER. THAT NEED TO FIFTEEN
SUFFERING DURING THE- DAY
WAITING. SB EIGHTY. UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS. YOU MAKE MEDICAL AID
IN DYING MARC. TO PATIENTS. IT
WOULD REDUCE THE WAY PERIOD TO
FORTY HOURS THE STATE MEETING
THAT NEW. LARGEST TO LAST MONTH.%
IT WOULD HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT
OF THE PEOPLE THE MEDICAL AID
IN DYING. THEN THE WEBSITE. AND
ENSURE PATIENT KNOW IF THE
DOCTOR WILL SUPPORT THEM. FORTY
EIGHT HOURS I FEEL IS THE TIME
THEN YOU CAN THAT THE CREATION
HAVE BEEN. OF THE TOP WE AND
BEFORE THEY GET TO THE POINT I.
SUPPORT THE- ADDITIONALLY THE
END OF BOX NOT THE SEPTIC FIRE
AT THE END OF TWO TWENTY. WE
JUST CANNOT LET THAT HAPPEN. SB
TWO EIGHT MAKE THE COMPACT LOVE.
AND I KNOW HOW MY HAVING
ADOPTION TO ME IS. AND IT YOU
CAN IT I STRONGLY ITS AT THE
PRESENT. THANK THANK YOU
BANERJEE. TO YOU ON THE. I AM
GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU FOR
THE TOPIC. TO TEST. TODAY SAID.
OF BILL THREE. MY NAME IS TO
STROUD. INTO NINE IN STOCK.
STYLE BY ACTIVE. HEALTHY FATHER
BURIED STROUSE IT WORLD
RENOWNED PROFESSOR OF
PHILOSOPHY AT UC BERKELEY FOR
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS. WITH
KHALIL BLACKSTONE MY MULTI FORM
THE DEADLIEST FORM OF BRAIN
CANCER. WITH HIS AGGRESSIVE
TUMOR ALREADY AT AN ADVANCED
STAGE DOCTORS GAVE MY DAD. A
PROGNOSIS. UP TO MONTHS GIVE OR
TAKE. DOCTORS TOLD US THAT HIS
COURSE UNDER. BUT THAT HE MIGHT
EXPERIENCE EXCRUCIATING
HEADACHES SEIZURES PARALYSIS
LOSING THE ABILITY TO SPEAK OR
SWALLOW AND MOST IMPORTANT TO
MY DAD LOSING THE ABILITY TO
THINK. MY FATHER SAID THAT HE
HAD NO INTEREST IN THE
LONGEVITY OF HIS LIFE
INDEPENDENT OF THE QUALITY OF
THAT LIFE SO AS SOON AS HE
ENTERED OFFICE HE PURSUED THE
OPTION OF MEDICAL AID IN DYING.
THE FIFTEEN DAY WAITING PERIOD
CREATED NEEDLESS SUFFERING FOR
MY DAD AT AN ALREADY IMPOSSIBLE
TIME IN HIS LIFE. GOOD
CONDITION WAS RAPIDLY
DETERIORATING AND HE WORRIED
EVERY SINGLE DAY ALL DAY ABOUT
WHETHER HE WOULD LIVE LONG
ENOUGH TO GET THE MEDICATION OR
IF HE WOULD STILL BE CAPABLE OF
TAKING IT ONCE IT ARRIVED. WHEN
THE MEDICATION FINALLY ARRIVED
IT BROUGHT TREMENDOUS RELIEF TO
MY FATHER IT EMPOWERED HIM TO
REFLECT ON AND EXPRESS HIS
WHICH IS ABOUT HIS DEATH.
LUCKILY HE DID NOT EXPERIENCE
THE PAIN NAUSEA OR SEIZURES
OFTEN ASSOCIATED WITH BRAIN
CANCER. AND ULTIMATELY HE DID
NOT INGEST THE AID IN DYING
MEDICATION HE DIED PEACEFULLY
THE WAY HE WANTED SURROUNDED BY
FAMILY. EVEN THOUGH HE DIDN'T
TAKE THE MEDICATION THE
PRESIDENT OF THE MEDICATION AND
THE OPTION TO TAKE IT WITH HIM
PIECE OF MIND IT ALLEVIATED HIS
FEAR AND ANXIETY ABOUT THE PAIN
AND SUFFERING IF YOU WOULD BE
FORCED TO INTO WORK WITHOUT IT.
AT THE MOST AGONIZING TIME IN
ALL OF OUR LIVES IT PRODUCTS
COMFORT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE EIGHTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR OF. ALL
RIGHT FROM OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT I SEE NONE IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NOT IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES MISTER MODERATOR AND
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF COULD QUEUE
UP. IN SUPPORT WE'LL HEAR FROM
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
EIGHTY. MISTER MODERATOR. IN IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTEEN GO
TO LINE FIVE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE BY. TWENTY TWO.
OKAY WE'RE GOING FIVE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROCKSTAND GOLD
ON THE AFTER THE AMERICAN
NURSES ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MARK. SURE HI.
TRYING TO GO TO LINE FOR TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR
ROBERT REPRESENTING THE
MEMORIAL CARE MEDICAL GROUP
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FATHER
OF EMILY ROSE OLVERA WRONG
SUPPORT SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY THANK YOU DR AGNES.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE FOR THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS STEPHANIE
CAMPBELL OR ORANGE COUNTY I'M
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. NEXT A LITTLE LINE NUMBER
FIVE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS I'VE BEEN CALLING
FROM MOUNTAIN VIEW CALIFORNIA
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SPELLS. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE THE FOUR
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SIGN ME UP THE TRACK CALLING ON
BEHALF OF COMPASSION AND
CHOICES ACTION NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
EIGHTY THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
NEXT OVER THE LINE TWO ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS DOCTOR
SERRA PENDER MY FILIATION OUR
HOSPICE BEREAVEMENT
COORDINATOR- GERONTOLOGY
DEPARTMENT CHAIR PERSON A
COLLEGE PROFESSOR CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST AT A MEDICAL
HOSPITAL AND IS A ROMAN
CATHOLIC- STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU SO THE
LINE FIVE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH I'M SUZANNE SINGER
ON THE RABBI OF TEMPLE BETH EL
IN RIVERSIDE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE EIGHTY. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HELLO MY NAME IS
ANNA HONEY CUT WITH THE LOTUS
WITH THE FOUNDATION CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND SENATE BILL
THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ELECTS A LITTLE WINE FOR
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MARK APPLE AND THE
FAMILY MEDICINE THE CAUSES CARE
POSITION IN MENDOCINO COUNTY
FOR THE PAST FORTY FIVE YEARS
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
EIGHTY. THANK YOU. EXCELLENT
ONLINE THREE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DOUGLAS
GARIBALDI I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
METASTATIC MELANOMA FOR FOUR
AND A HALF YEARS AGO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE EIGHTY. THANK
YOU. OKAY IT WILL GO TO ONE
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIT AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BARBARA GLAZER WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE. WHAT I WOULD CALL AN
IN BETWEEN POSITION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO LESS AMENDED. WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS TOPICS FROM THE
SPONSORS ON AMENDMENTS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
WORK TO RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ACTUALLY
ONE FIVE OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS DR CATHERINE ZAHN
WITH FORREST I'M A PROFESSOR OF
FAMILY MEDICINE AT UCSF
NATIVITY DODD AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE EIGHTY. THANK
YOU. SIX ZERO ONE FIVE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I AM DOCTOR
RYAN SKILLED VOCAL IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SP THREE
EIGHTY. THANK YOU. TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAN DE IS I AM
BRITNEY MALARKEY HAS BEEN. I
SUPPORT SB THREE EIGHTY AND I
THINK SENATOR EGGMAN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE FIVE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
PATRICK MCMILLAN I AM A
PHYSICIAN MEDICAL DOCTOR IN THE
FRESNO CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY.
THANK YOU. AND THAT'S A LITTLE
ONE FIVE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS BONNIE
MCKEE AGAIN THE GRASS VALLEY MY
MOTHER USED MEDICAL AID IN
DYING I'M A THERAPIST AND
SOCIAL WORKER AND I SUPPORT SB
THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE
IN THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHTY- LET'S
NOT TURNED OPPOSITION I
UNDERSTAND THAT- MISS MARYLAND
GOLD FROM THE DISABILITY RIGHTS
EDUCATION DEFENSE ONE IS ONLINE
OPPOSITION. YES I'M HERE. THANK
YOU MISS COLD CLIMATE. YEAH
THANK YOU. WELL IT'S PAST
SUPPORTERS POINTED TO THESE
PROVISIONS AS A CENTRAL PARTS
TO ENSURE THAT PATIENTS ARE
PROTECTED WHY ARE THESE SO
CALLED SAFEGUARDS NOW
EXPANDABLE WHERE THEY ACTUALLY
PERHAPS NOT THE CENTRAL LET'S
START WITH THE REMOVAL OF THE
SUNSET PROVISION THE BILL'S
AUTHORS HAD INCLUDED IT SHOWS
THAT THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
COULD HAVE ALL SIDES CLOSELY
EXAMINED THE DATA REPORTED BY
THE STATE. NOW FIVE YEARS
PREMATURE THIS BILL SEEKS TO
ELIMINATE THAT PROVISION. AND
THAT REVIEW. LET US CONSIDER
THE SHOT STATE CALIFORNIANS
GATHERING AND REPORTING.
THERE'S NO INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT PATIENTS BONUSES EVEN MORE
UNLIKE IN OTHER STATES WHERE
THIS IS LEGAL. THERE ARE NO
STATISTICS ABOUT REFERRALS FROM
FOUGHT FOR PSYCHOLOGICAL
EVALUATIONS UNLIKE IN OTHER
SEARCH STAGE THERE ARE NO
REASONS FOR PATIENTS GAS
REQUEST UNLIKE. SIMILAR STATES
ELSEWHERE. THERE IS NO DATA
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AFTER
INGESTION SUCH AS HOW WANTED TO
CHECK FOR THE LETHAL DOSE THE
CARBON CONSCIOUSNESS AND DEATH.
AND THE PATIENT EXPERIENCE ANY
COMPLICATIONS SUCH AS
REGURGITATION OR HUGE SERVICE
FOR WAKING UP INSTEAD OF DYING
ALL OF WHICH HAVE COME TO LIGHT
IN OTHER STATES. NOW IT IS NOT
WE THESE THINGS DIDN'T HAPPEN.
IT'S THAT EITHER WE HAVE NOT
ASKED IF THEY HAPPEN. DO WE NOT
CARE IF THEY HAPPEN MY
ORGANIZATION CARES FOR WE DID
ASK WITH THE ANSWERS AREN'T
MADE AVAILABLE TO ANYONE. SURE
THERE NO ONE IS REQUIRED TO BE
PRESENT AT THE TIME OF
INGESTION NOT THE PRESCRIBING
DOCTOR NOR ANY OBJECTIVE
WITNESS WHO COULD REPORT BACK
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. SO THERE'S NO
WAY TO KNOW WHAT OCCURRED. MOST
EGREGIOUS CALIFORNIA HAS
ADMITTED TO ARBITRARY
DESTRUCTION OF THE UNDERLYING
DATA EVERY THREE YEARS. BUT THE
ONE INFORMATIONAL HEARING IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REVEALED THAT THE DATA
COLLECTION THE STATE DOES TWO
SHOWS A LACK OF COMPLIANCE WITH
THE LAW. BUT THAT THE STATE HAS
NO ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT. HOW CAN
CALIFORNIA REMOVES THE SUNSET
CLAUSE WHILE NORRINGTON SHOWN
MUCH CRUCIAL DATA. WHICH
IRRESPONSIBLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO REMOVE THE
SUNSET PROVISION WITH NO REAL
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS. ALSO LOOK
TO THE FIFTEEN DAY COOLING OFF
PERIOD THAT IS BEING REMOVED
I'M A MEDICAL STUDY IN THE
LANCET JOURNAL FOUND THAT
PATIENTS WILL TO LIVE AND
FLUCTUATE 30% IN A TWELVE HOUR
PERIOD. MANY PEOPLE REQUESTING
ASSISTED SUICIDE IN FACT CHANGE
THEIR MINDS SHANDONG LIVING
DECADES BEYOND THEIR PROGNOSIS.
A BAD DAY SHOULD NOT MEAN A
DEATH SENTENCE A FEW HOURS
LATER. AND ONE MORE TIME. THE
KEY ISSUE OF SYSTEMIC INEQUITY
IMPASSIONED CHOICES- SO MANY
PROPONENTS OF THIS KIND OF BILL
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY AND IT WAS
JUST TESTIFIED OR GIVING THEIR
MEET YOU ALSO HAS BEEN CALLING
ON CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS TO
PERMANENTLY RE AUTHORIZ THE
LAW CHANGES TO REMOVE SO CALLED
BARRIERS ESPECIALLY FOR QUOTES
UNDERSERVED ETHNIC RACIALLY
DIVERSE AND RURAL COMMUNITIES.
SHOULD WE BE MORE WORRIED THAT
THESE COMMUNITIES LAUGHTER EVEN
BASIC PRIMARY CARE NOT TO
MENTION SPECIALIZED CARE SUCH
AS CANCER CARE PALLIATIVE CARE
AND HOSPICE CARE RATHER THAN
SHORT CUTTING PRIORITY ACCESS
TO LEGAL DRUGS- I THANK YOU-
AND I MARILYN GOLDEN WITH THE
DISABILITY RGHTS EDUCATION AND
DEFENSE FUND. THANK YOU MS GOLD
BAR RIGHT NOW LET'S TURN TO
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION I SEE
NO ONE IN THE GALLERY TO SEE
NOAH ROOM. ONE TWELVE LET'S
TURN TO THE PHONES. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU'D ASKED TO
KEEP UP. ENOUGH TO S. THREE A-
PART OF THOSE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO AN
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU YOUR
LINE NUMBER AND I WILL CALL YOU
BY YOUR LINE NUMBER. I WILL GO
TO NUMBER IS FIVE. FOUR AGAIN
FIVE TO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE AND SHARE
MEMBERS THIS IS WEEKS AWAY HE
GETS WITH THE QUOKKA GROUP ON
BEHALF OF. JESUS CHRIST OF
LATTER DAY SAINTS IN OPPOSITION
TO THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CORRECT AND NOW A COAT TO LINE
OF. THREE SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE
THE CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. RIGHT AN
ALKALINE- FIVE THREE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS THE WORST
I TELL I'M A NURSE OF SIX YEARS
IN HOSPITAL ADMINISTRATION
FACULTY. CRITICAL CARE HOSPICE
CARE TRAUMA CARE UNIT- I AM
DEFINITELY SUPPORT OF THAT
THREE EIGHTY. OKAY THANK YOU
OUR NOT TAKEN OPPOSITION. AND
WE'LL GO TO THE LINE UP FIVE
THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AGAIN LINE NUMBER FIVE THREE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING
OUT OF THE LINE OF FOUR NINE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS SET AND NOT
ALVAREZ ESQUIRE I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SALVADOR ALVAREZ INSTITUTE FOR
NONVIOLENCE. OUR FOUNDER SAL
ALVAREZ SERVED AS FOUNDING VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE LOTUS OF
FUNDACION CHAIRED THE NATIONAL
ELECTORAL COMMISSION AND WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE PASSAGE OF
EIGHTY EIGHT. AND THE CREATION
OF THE CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
EXCHANGE WITH SENATOR ADEQUATE.
HEALTH CARE INEQUITIES PRECLUDE
NOT ARNOLD I AM HAVING ACTUALLY.
YOU ARE ARE YOU IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. HE. THREE THANK YOU
NEXT. FOR SEVERAL LINE OF THE
THREE SEVEN LINE IS A- FINALLY
YES- WILL THING I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE ROY TO AND NAME OF
COMPASSION ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU BYE NEXT CALL. A LINE OF
FIVE ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FOR NOW NOT OPPOSED AT
THE TIME MY NUMBER MANY MANDATE
BE AGAIN. I'M I'M THE WAY TO A
GREAT DAVID HERE WAS DENIED AND
PEOPLE DIED IN THE FIFTEEN DAY
WAITING. BLUELINE OF FIVE BY
YOU LINE OPEN. A LINE NUMBER.
THE SPEAKER WHO CENTER FLOATED
WITH THE CAL GAS CON. IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. CORRECT
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP THE THREE
EIGHT IS A- HI THIS IS TONY
ROMA'S OUR WITH CASH REEF IN IN
OPPOSITE. SB EIGHTY YEAH. AND
NOW. TWO ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS BOB NAYLOR FOR
FIELD DEAD AND COMPANY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL FORTY EIGHT HOURS
IS TOO SHORT THANK YOU THANK
WON'T GROW OKAY LINE UP TO FIVE
TWO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME'S THE SHOP WHILE
THIRTY- FROM CALIFORNIA LACK
AND I FIRMLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. I'M GOING TO LINE UP
TO FIVE TO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I CAN LINE FIVE TO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON A
GOLD MINE OF THREE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS B. SOSA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS I'VE BEEN
WITH MY LOVED ONES. AND THE
LINE THREE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I GET A LINE FREE
AIRLINE. YEAH I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
HEART WILL GO LINE OF ONE NINE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME'S MIKIE CARNEY. I LIVE IN
NEWPORT BEACH AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THE LAST LINE WE HAVE A
GOOD TIME IS FLYING THREE EIGHT
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
ENTERTAINER HILLS AND I ALSO.
FEEL STRONGLY PLEASE VOEPEL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THAT WAS THE LAST TIME WE EVER
Q. PLEASE GO AHEAD ALL RIGHTY-
WE'VE HEARD NOW FROM SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION- BRING IT BACK TO
THE FLOOR BUT BEFORE WE TAKE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
FLOOR JUST ONE HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENT- WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE SB SIX FOUR TWO BY CENTER
COM LONGER NEXT SO WILL NEXT
TAKE UP SB SIX FOUR TWO BY
CENTER COM LOGGER AND THEN WILL
TAKE UP SB 555% REQUIRE AND
THEN SB FIVE NINE EIGHT BY
SENATOR PAN. SOUL OF QUESTIONS
I SEE NO MICROPHONES RAISED-
CENTER EGGMAN CHUCK CLOSE. I
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT AND THE
OPPOSITION I THINK THIS IS A
VERY EMOTIONAL ISSUE IT ALWAYS
HAS BEEN AND ALWAYS WILL BE TO
ONE THING SO MANY OF US RESIST
EVEN THINKING ABOUT IS THE END
OF OUR LIFE BUT IT COMES FOR
ALL OF US. AND I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE A
CHOICE ABOUT THEIR LAST DAYS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU- ALL RIGHT SIR
EARLIER MOVES A BILL. CHICKENS
ASTROLOGY CALL THE ROLL. YES
THIS IS SB THREE EIGHTY BY
SENATOR ADMIN WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR LAYERED THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE I AM BERG BY GORGEOUS.
CABALLERO HI DEBBIE AT ALL I
DID I SO. DEPRESSED SO I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. JONES LAYERED
LAYERED I STERN. RIGHT STERN I
WAKE OWSKI HI MY CASKEY I
WIENER. WIENER I BALLOTS EIGHT
ZERO SO FAR ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT
THAT BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
CENTER EGGMAN NOW WE'RE PAGING
CENTER COM LONGER. SO JUST TO
REVIEW THE BIDDING- NEXT WE'LL
HEAR SB SIX FOUR TWO BY SENATOR
COM LONGER THEN WILL HERE. S.
B. FIVE FIVE FIVE BY SEVEN
REQUIRE THEN SB FIVE NINE EIGHT
BY CENTER PAN. OKAY. UHHUH YEAH
SO. WE HAVE A POSSIBILITIES TO
MICHAEL. WHAT IS THE.
SENATE
KAMLAGER THAT WAS FAST ALL
RIGHT. LET'S NOW TURN TO S. B.
SIX FOUR TWO- SILICON LONGER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. I'M GONNA
BE GIVEN OF A SIGNAL TO WAIT
YEP. WHAT. OKAY- ALL RIGHT- I
UNDERSTAND CENTER COME ARE YOU
GONNA LEAVE FOR A MOMENT OF
WILL WILL WAIT JUST A MINUTE
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT HERE WE GO.
SENATE KAMLAGER WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
PERFECT WELL. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND- MUCH APPRECIATED FOR THAT
ACCOMMODATION MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I AM. HERE TO ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB. SIX FOUR
TWO THE PATIENTS OVER PROFITS
ACT. SB SIX FOUR TWO WILL
PROTECT PATIENTS MEDICAL
DECISIONS BY PREVENTING PRIVATE
EQUITY FIRMS HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES. OR ANY OTHER ENTITY
THAT IS NOT LICENSED TO
PRACTICE MEDICINE FROM
INTERFERING CONTROLLING. OR
OTHERWISE LIMITING A PATIENT'S
MEDICAL CARE FOR NON MEDICAL
REASONS. THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
HAS SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGED IN
THE PAST FEW DECADES ONE TREND
THAT HAS IMPACTED PATIENT CARE.
IS THE RAPID PACE OF MERGERS
AFFILIATIONS IN ACQUISITIONS.
THESE TRANSACTIONS GIVE
COMPANIES TREMENDOUS POWER TO
DICTATE PATIENT CARE. EVEN IF
THEIR MOTIVES ARE PROFIT DRIVEN
AND DISCRIMINATORY. FOR EXAMPLE
CEOS CAN IMPOSE POLICIES THAT
PROHIBIT PHYSICIANS FROM
DELIVERING EVIDENCE BASED CARE
TO PATIENTS EVEN WHEN THEIR
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES ARE
EQUIPPED AND STAFFED TO DELIVER
THESE SERVICES. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY DANGEROUS IN URGENT
AND EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
BECAUSE FOR SO MANY PATIENTS
LIVING IN RURAL AREAS THERE ARE
SIMPLY NO OTHER OPTIONS FOR
RECEIVING CARE. DESPITE THIS
FACT AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES ARE
RESTRICTING THE TYPES OF CARE
AVAILABLE ON THEIR PREMISES.
RESTRICTIONS ARE NOT EVIDENCE
BASED MORE GROUNDED IN MEDICAL
SCIENCE. PUT PATIENTS LIVES AT
RISK AND SHOULD HAVE NO PLACE
IN OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. TO
MAXIMIZE PROFITS COMPANIES
OFTEN CUT UNPROFITABLE MEDICAL
PROCEDURES THAT BILLING QUOTAS
REQUIRE INTERNAL REFERRALSFOR
MEDICAL SERVICES AND PRESSURE
PROVIDERS TO PERFORM
UNNECESSARY BUT LUCRATIVE
PROCEDURES. AT TWENTY EIGHTEEN
STUDY OF TWO MILLION CARDIAC
PATIENTS FOUND THAT THOSE
TREATED IN CONSOLIDATED
HOSPITALS WERE MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE HEART ATTACKS VISIT THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. BE
READMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL OR
DIE. THROUGH THESE STRATEGIES
MERGERS HAVE INCREASED THE
PRICE OF HOSPITAL SERVICES BY
UP 218% IN RECENT YEARS.
KEEPING MEDICAL CARE OUT OF
REACH FOR SO MANY PATIENTS AND
STRAINING OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS. CALIFORNIA BANNED THE
CORPORATE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE
FOR THIS PURPOSE. TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE WHO ARE UNTRAINED IN
MEDICINE DO NOT INTERFERE WITH
THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE THE
PHYSICIAN PATIENT RELATIONSHIP.
NOR PREVENT ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH CARE. A
PATIENT'S DECISION TO RECEIVE
MEDICAL CARE FALLS WITHIN THE
GAMUT OF THE PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE AND IS ACCORDINGLY
GIVEN ALL THE RESPECT
PRIVILEGES AND PROTECTIONS OF
THE PROFESSION STEMMING FROM
THE PHYSICIAN'S HIPPOCRATIC
OATH. CALIFORNIA LAW ALSO
EXTENDS TO THAT DECISION A HOST
OF LEGAL PROTECTIONS. DESIGNED
TO PREVENT UNDUE INTERFERENCE
IN THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE.
DUE TO IMPROPER MOTIVES
INCLUDING DISCRIMINATION AND
PROFITEERING. AND HOSPITALS
CALIFORNIA ALSO REQUIRES AND
POLICIES AFFECTING PATIENT CARE
INVOLVED THE HOSPITAL'S MEDICAL
STAFF WHICH LEGALLY MUST BE
SELF GOVERNING. THIS BILL WILL
STRENGTHEN THESE PROTECTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL PATIENTS.
REGARDLESS OF IDENTITY OR
FINANCIAL STATUS CAN ACCESS
AFFORDABLE COMPREHENSIVE AND
INCLUSIVE MEDICAL CARE BASED ON
MEDICAL CRITERIA ALONE. I URGE
MY COLLEAGUES TO VOTE IN FAVOR
OF SB SIX FOUR TWO TODAY AND
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS
DAVID CARILLO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION CENTER
AND FRANCISO SILVA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
MISTER CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER CONLOGUE OR MISTER
CARILLO ON IF YOU'RE ON THE
LINE PLEASE PROCEED. FINALLY
HEARING. YES WE CAN. GREAT
THANK YOU AB CREO CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION CENTER IN SUPPORT
TO THE HONORABLE COMMITTEE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW CALIFORNIA
AND FEDERAL COURTS WILL APPLY
TO DISTINCT ANALYSES TO SB SIX
POINT TWO TO DETERMINE WHETHER
EXCESSIVELY RESTRICTS RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY UNDER CALIFORNIA AND
FEDERAL CONSTITUTION. OF COURSE
THAT'S WHAT THE LAW IS A
PATIENT NEUTRAL PLEASE CONTACT
THE PROPER STUDENTS. SUBJECT
STAVING. IF IT IS WITHIN THE
LOGS ON THE- BY A RASH PURPOSE
EVEN IF IT INTERNET BIRDS
LIBERTY TO SOME DEGREE. SB SIX
FORTY TWO INSPIRATION NEUTRAL
IT DOES NOT TARGET FOR
DISCRIMINATORY TREATMENT.
INSTEAD IT ADDRESSES THE MATTER
THE STATE IS FREE TO REGULATE
MEDICAL SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC
AND IT SERVES A RATIONAL STATE
INTEREST BARRING CORPORATE.
INTERFERENCE IN MEDICAL
DECISIONS. WHAT INTENTIONALLY
BECAUSE THE REST OF THE BALANCE.
THE REGULATE NON. MEDICAL
SERVICES AND IT APPLIES
NEUTRALLY GENERALLY COME
MEDICAL. OR OF THE PHILLY. OR
ABSENCE. AT MOST OF MIGHT
CONFLICT WITH RELIGIOUS BELIEFS
ONLY INCIDENTALLY. ALSO NINETY
NOT DIRECTLY PROVIDING THE
SERVICE ISSUE A DOCTOR IS. AND
THE PATIENT IS THE ULTIMATE
BENEFICIARY. IF THE COURT FINDS
SB SIX FORTY IS NOT OFFICIALLY.
OR THAT IT UNDER BURKE
RELIGIOUS LIBERTY COURT WILL
STRICT. EVEN SO THIS LAW SHOULD
PASS MUSTER. NEARLY TABLE TO
CHEAT A COMPELLING STATE
INTEREST THE CIVIC. ENDING
ACCESS TO CARE DISCRIMINATION
FOR PATIENTS AND PROTECTED
CLASS. WASHINGTON STRICT
SCRUTINY AND WHICH FOR ME OF
ITS IT GOT AND- THE CALIFORNIA
COURT HELD ENDING THE- BASED ON
GENDER OR OTHER PROTECTED
CLASSIFICATIONS IS A COMPELLING
STATE INTEREST. LIKE OTHER
OSWALD EIGHTEEN TO ENDING SUCH
DISCRIMINATION DISPATCHING
TROOPS PASS TRICKS REMARKS. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THE TO THE
NEUTRAL MALL GENERAL
APPLICATION INTENDED TO COMBAT
THE NILE MEDICAL MEDICALLY
NECESSARY HEALTHCARE FOR NON
MEDICAL REASONS SPECIFICALLY
PROFIT AND DISCRIMINATION. AND
THAT OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REGULATION EVEN IF SOME
INTERNAL BURDEN ON WHICH
RESULT. THANK YOU AND I HAVE
FURTHER. THANK YOU. MR SILVA
HERE OF. THE FLOOR IS YOURS. SO
YES THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. THANK YOU ARE
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
GOING TO SCHOOL SO A LOT OF THE
CURRENT ACCOUNTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MORE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WHICH STRONGLY
SUPPORTS SENATE BILL SIX FORTY
TWO. WHAT POSITIONS HAVE SEEN
IS THE INCREASING
CORPORATIZATION OF HEALTHCARE.
WHICH HAS RESULTED IN THE
GROWTH. OF CORPORATE POLICIES.
IN THE YOU'LL YOU'LL ADAM
TREGIAN OF NON CLINICAL
CRITERION PATIENT CARE AT THAT
LIMITED ALL THE OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR PATIENTS. SB SIX
FORTY TWO C. SIX TO KEEP THE-
TIP THE BALANCE IN FAVOR
PATIENTS TO ENSURE. PATIENTS
ARE CONSIDERABLE HEALTHCARE
DECISIONS AND MEDICAL DECISIONS
ARE MADE. WITHOUT THE
INTERFERENCE OF MOTIVES THAT
HAVE NOTHING. TO DO WITH THE
QUALITY OF PATIENT CARE.
CALIFORNIA LAW HAS LONG TO
CARDIGAN WHICH WILL NOW
CLINICAL. EDUCATION CARE
HOWEVER WITH THE GROWTH OF CARE
MARKET CONSOLIDATION THERE HAS
BEEN A GROWING EFFORT BY
COMPANIES THE TOP POLICIES THAT
INTERFERE WITH. THE STATE AND
RESTRICT THE PATIENT'S MEDICAL
CARE. SB SIX FORTY TWO CORRECT
SUCH PRACTICES BY PROHIBITING.
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES FROM
UNILATERALLY ADOPTING POLICIES
THAT IGNORE THE MEDICAL STAFF'S
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY. ON
ISSUES OF PATIENT CARE. THIS
APPROACH CORRECTIVE THE
IMPORTANCE OF SHARED
GOVERNMENT'S AMONG THE
HOSPITAL'S GOVERNING BOARD AND
ITS INDEPENDENT MEDICAL STAFF
ENSURES THAT MEDICAL CLINICAL
DECISIONSARE NOT UNDULY
INFLUENCED OR CONTROLLED BY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE MOTIVES OR
INTEREST IN THE HOSPITAL. THE
COMMISSION FOR HOSPITAL MEDICAL
STAFF SHOULD BE EMPOWERED TO
PROVIDE CARE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PATIENT NOT BE
PRESSURED TO PROVIDE.
UNNECESSARY MEDICAL SERVICES
THAT MAKE THE HOSPITAL MONEY
ADDITIONALLY SB SIX FORTY TWO
ADDRESSES BUSINESS PRACTICES BY
PRIVATE. EQUITY INVESTMENT
FIRMS THAT SEEK TO CIRCUMVENT
CALIFORNIANS BANNING CORPORATE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE. GRADUALLY
PURSUE A RETURN ON THEIR
INVESTMENT BY REDUCING
CONTROLLING OR LIMITING MEDICAL
DECISIONS TOO OFTEN. PRECISION
RECOMMENDED CARE STILL LATER
OVERTURNED BY MILLION TO TEACH
BECAUSE YOU'RE NON CLINICAL
MOTIVES. THAT DECREASE ACTIONS.
A TRIGGERED MISTRESS. HELP OUR
AND THE TURN OF COST THANK YOU
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT OTHERS IN SOME I SEE
KNOWN A AS NO ONE ROOM ONE.
WITH TURN TO THE PHONE LINES-
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU KEEP UP
THOSE ARE ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SIX FOUR TWO.
RIGHT AGAIN FOR THOSE PLEASE
ONE THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOU A LINE NUMBER. WE DO
HAVE ONE AVAILABLE. MY NUMBER
FOUR FIVE TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT VENTURE ON BEHALF OF
COMPLAINTS THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBGYN STRYCHNINE AND THE
CALIFORNIA COULD YOU ADDRESS
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I KNOW
WILL GO TO THE LINE OF FIVE
FIVE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BUT I THINK
YOU KNOW WHAT KEEP KEEP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF AT CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. RIGHT ONE
MOMENT FOR A LAST LINE.
THE
LAST LINE NUMBERS FIVE FIVE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. KERN YES I AM MY NAME
IS B. SAYS THAT. AND I AM IN
SUPPORT ESPECIALLY WITH
COVIDIEN EVERY BEEN WITHHOLDING
OF TREATMENT- THAT DOCTORS AND
PATIENTS WANTED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM- ALL RIGHT THANKS
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE. NO
ONE ELSE IN THE POLITICAL
STUNT. OKAY LET'S TURNED
OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND MISS
MARIA SPERBER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IS ON THE LINE. YES THANK YOU
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARE
NUMBERS MARIE OCTOBER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. HOSPITAL'S
GOVERNING BODY HAS LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS RESPONSIBILITIES
AND THE RIGHT TO GOVERN
FUNDAMENTAL ASPECTS OF THE
OPERATION OF THE HOSPITAL IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THEIR FIDUCIARY
DUTY ACCREDITATION REQUIREMENTS
AND LONGSTANDING STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW. THEREFORE THE
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION MEXICO'S
SB SIX FOUR TWO. THREE THREE
FOUR TWO SIX ONE POWER
INDIVIDUAL POSITIONS TO DICTATE
TO A HOSPITAL WHAT TREATMENTS
AND SERVICES AT THE HOSPITAL
WILL OFFER. IT SEEKS TO GET
EACH INDIVIDUAL POSITIONS OF
POWER DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE
PHYSICIANS OF NO FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY OR LIABILITY
EXPOSURE FOR THE. CONSEQUENCES
OF THESE DECISIONS. NOR
OBLIGATION TO MANAGE THAT STUFF
OR READ THAT MAY BE RE. TO
EMPLOY THE VISION NO OBLIGATION
CAN. OR BALANCE THE IMPACT OF
ACQUISITIONS CHOICE AGAINST THE
NEEDS OF OTHER PATIENTS OR THE
HOSPITAL'S COMMUNITY AS A
WHOLE. FOR CALIFORNIA LAW
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANT ROLE
OF THE ORGANIZED MEDICAL STAFF
IN ENSURING THE ADEQUACY AND
QUALITY OF THE CARE RENDERED TO
PATIENTS. THE MEDICAL FACULTY
CORRECTLY MADE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE GOVERNING BODY FOR THE
ADEQUACY AND QUALITY OF THE
CARE RENDERED TO PATIENTS. ALL
THE GOVERNING BODY IS REQUIRED
TO HAVE OVERALL ADMINISTRATIVE
AND PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY
THE MEDICAL STOP WORKS OF THE
GOVERNING BODY CLINICAL
GUIDELINES AND THERE ARE
ESTABLISHED METHODS TO RESOLVE
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE TWO. SB
SIX FOUR TWO COMPLEXITY
FOUNDATIONAL PRINCIPLES OF
HOSPITAL GOVERNANCE. FIND
ALTERNATE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
HOSPITAL POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES AS WELL AS OVERALL
ADMINISTRATIVE AND PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE GOVERNING
BODY. MEMBERS HAVE A FIDUCIARY
DUTY TO ACT IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE ORGANIZATION
AND POTENTIAL PERSONAL LIABLE
LIABILITY IF THEY FAIL TO DO
SO. INSTEAD SB SIX FOUR TWO
WOULD GRANT THE ULTIMATE
RESPONSIBILITY TO INDIVIDUAL
POSITION AND THE MEDICAL STAFF
COULD NOT BEAR THE LEGAL
RAMIFICATIONS OF THE HOSPITAL.
WOULD FACE OF THE VISION THE
VISION IF THE PROVISIONS
PROVISIONS WHAT WAS IS ACCURATE
ONE. MORE OVER DIVISIONS ARE
NEXT. COMMITTED TO THE SUCCESS
OF THEIR PERSONAL FROM. NOT AT
ALL THE MEETING THAT HOW NEEDS
OF THE K. INDEED A- AND ME
BECAUSE WITH ABOUT. FOR EXAMPLE
A IT MAY- OWN IN. SURGERY
CENTER WHICH BY. BY WITH THE
HOT. YET ATHLETES FORTY WOULD
REACT ALTENBEKEN. OVER THE BUT
RESEARCH TO BE ON A THE
HOSPITAL THE INDIVIDUAL TO.
WITH I CAN. OUR HEARTS. ARE
BOUND AND BY FEDERAL STATE LAW
INCLUDING AND- THE GARY THAT
HAN FOR SIR ALL PIECE. AND IN
AN EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
REGARDLESS OF INSURANCE. LOS AS
WELL AS THE CROWD REQUIRE
REQUIRE HAN PROBABLY AND
ACCOUNT GOVERNANCEBODY THE
COMMISSION IS TO PROVIDE
PATIENT CARE LOOKING ACCOUNT
BUT- AFTER THAT BE CAN WHEN
OPERATE BUDGET. UP FOR THE ZERO
CHAMBER YOUR ABOUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISS BERMAN ALL RIGHT
OTHERS IN OPPOSITE. I SEE NO IN
THE GALA I SEE ONE IN ROOM ONE-
TO THE PHONE LINES ALL ENOUGH
YOUR NAME YOUR PHILLY YOUR
POSITION. NUMBER TRANSACTION HI
MISTER MATER WE TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES FEW KEY UP THOSE
OPPOSITION. S. B. FOUR TWO.
THREE ONE ON THE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR. RIGHT FOR WHAT
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO WE DO HAVE WHILE NUMBER
THREE SIX SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE
OF CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. WHEN I
WENT ONLINE UP FIVE FIVE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHNSON
CLAYTON ABOUT THE SCRIPT OPEN
UP TO. THANK YOU. WHINE OF FIVE
SIX TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHELLY
SCHLENKER ON BEHALF OF DIGNITY
HELD IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
GRATEFUL NOW GLOBAL LINE FIVE
SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEY
FERNANDO FLORES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. JUST
ONE MOMENT I BELIEVE WE STILL
HAVE ONE MORE. OUR. SHE. FIVE
SIX THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY SINCERE APOLOGIES I HAD
ISSUES WITH THE PHONE LINES OF
MY RETIREMENT PLAN TREMENDOUSLY
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN COURT
AGAIN I HAD PROBLEMS AND SAYS
SORRY. ALREADY THANK YOU THIS
MODERATE ANYBODY ELSE ON THE
PHONE LINE. NOTHING MORE THE
POINT OF THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURN NOW THE CHAMBER I
SEE NO MICROPHONES REYES- I'M
SORRY MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
I JUST WANTED TO. AND
OBSERVATION AYE WE JUST GOT
THIS BILL OF COURSE BECAUSE IT
WAS GOTTEN AMENDED BECAUSE OF
OUR NEW SENATOR HERE HE HAS TWO
BILLS ONE THAT. I GAVE HER IN
THIS NEW ONE IS GREAT AND SHE'S
A FANTASTIC AUTHOR AN ECSTATIC
TO HAVE HER HERE I JUST WANTED
TO. HELLO JUST PUT A COUPLE OF
THOUGHTS ON THE RECORD BECAUSE
IT'S SO NEW. AND WHEN I WENT TO
THE ANALYSIS. I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE MEANING OF THIS
BILL WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO DO. ARM DIGGING DEEP BECAUSE
THE FIRST OF ALL YOU KNOW I'D
WORKED ON THIS ISSUE OF CHOICE
IN THE ISSUE OF HOSPITALS AND
THEIR THEIR RELIGIOUS VIEWS.
MANY MANY YEARS AGO AND
CREATING THE CONTRACEPTIVE
EQUITY ACT WHICH TOOK ME FIVE
TIMES TO GET IT PASSED AND FORM
THE FOUNDATION WHICH ULTIMATELY
BECAME THE HOBBY LOBBY CASE.
ENDS AT THE SAME TIME HAVE SEEN
OVER THE MANY DECADES. THE
EXTRAORDINARY. DISCUSSION AND
ACTIONS BY THIS. LEGISLATIVE
BODY IN THE GOVERNOR WHO REALLY
TRY TO UNDERSTAND THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
HOSPITAL AND A DOCTOR. AND
BASICALLY WHEN YOU READ THE
ANALYSIS WHICH ACCURATELY
REFLECTS WHAT THE CONDITION OF
THE LAW IS. IT BASICALLY SAYS
DOCTORS CAN'T BE MESSED WITH
THEY HAVE THEIR PROFESSIONAL
OPINION. AND YOU CAN'T MAKE
DECISIONS ON PROFITABILITY'S OF
HOSPITALS AND THAT. BODY OF LAW
IS PRETTY SIGNIFICANT. NOW WE
HAVE A SERIES RECENTLY OF A
BUNCH OF MERGERS AND
ACQUISITIONS AS WE SEEN ALL
ACROSS. MANY SPECTRUMS AND WHAT
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THOSE
MERGERS AND ACQUISITIONS ARE.
SO WHEN I READ THIS I READ THE
NARAL CONSTRUCT AS IT RELATES
TO THE CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE.
BUT I'M CURIOUS ABOUT THE
LARGER ISSUE IN TERMS OF ITS
IMPACT. AND HOW YOU REALLY AS
WE DEAL WITH THIS LARGER
DYNAMIC AND WE DEAL WITH THE
ISSUE OF. WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
FOR HEALTH CARE FOR ALL OF THE
LIKE HOW DO WE INTEGRATE ALL
THIS AND I HAVE SOME
UNDERSTANDING SO I'M GONNA VOTE
FOR THIS BECAUSE- YOU KNOW.
COME TO THE CONGRESS A GREAT
LEGISLATOR I THINK THE WORK OF
THE FOR AND SHE BY I HAD A
CHACE TO TALK TO HER ABOUT IT.
BUT I JUST I JUST HAVE
QUESTIONS THAT WE GET A CHANCE
TO TALK TO HER ABOUT IT TO TRY
TO GET A DEEPER UNDERSTANDING.
YOU I'M JUST CONCERNED THAT WE
CONTINUALLY PUT BILLS AND BILLS
AND STUFF ESPECIALLY SOMETHING
AS COMPLEX AS HEALTH CARE. AND
IT WORRIES ME A LITTLE BIT SO I
JUST PUT THAT OUT THERE I'M
GONNA VOTE FOR IT BECAUSE IT
YOU KNOW I WANT TO GET A CHANCE
TO WORK WITH THEIR IT'S JUST TO
ME SAID GUT AND AMEND FOR. VERY
LEGITIMATE REASONS AND WANTED
TO ARTICULATE I THINK THE
FRAMEWORK WITH WHICH WE SHOULD
BE APPROACHING BY THIS MEASURE
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SHERMAN FOR INDULGING ME WITH
SO MUCH TIME. THANK YOU. SIR
HERTZBERG A CENTER LAYER- THANK
YOU MISTER. AN ACTUAL. THE
SENATOR- HUH NO WE'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO SAY NAMES ON A GET
IT THE GUY FROM NORTH HOLLYWOOD
OR WORD REACH FROM- HE ACTUALLY
WAS VERY PERSUASIVE BECAUSE I
WAS GOING TO ASK A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
BECAUSE THERE'S ONE PARTICULAR
PROVISION THAT SEEMS VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WAS TRYING TO DO LAST
YEAR ABOUT APPROVING THE- THE
TRANSFERABILITY OF HOUSES THAT
ARE HOSPITALS AND PUTTING. THE
UNREST CIVIL RIGHTS ACT IN THE
MIDDLE OF IT AS A BASIS FOR-
FOR CONSIDERATION OF THOSE
TRANSFERS OF HOSPITALS THAT
SEEMS VERY SIGNIFICANT TO ME
AND SOMETHING I WOULD LIKE. A
TO TALK ABOUT AND AT THE SAME
TIME ON THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION SIDE THEY'RE
FEELING LIGHT THEY'RE BEING
REQUIRED. TO DO SERVICES
DICTATE DON'T CURRENT DO
BECAUSE OF HOW THIS BILL WAS
STRUCTURED AND I SORT OF. WAS
PREPARED TO ENGAGE IN QUESTIONS
BACK AND FORTH BUT I THINK
AFTER SENATOR HERTZBERG'S
COMMENTS. BOB IT'S PERSUASIVE
IN THE SENSE THAT. THIS IS NEW
I'VE GOTTEN AMANDA I'M PART. A
FUNCTION OF THE CHANGE OF
HOUSES AND I WOULD JUST SITE
THOSE THINGS AS THINGS I WOULD
BE CONCERNED ABOUT AND WANT TO
SEE MORE WE HAVE CONVERSATIONS
AND FEEL LIKE I THINK THERE'S A
BUNCH OF WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE ON THIS. END AND FIVE AND
WOULD VOTE TO MOVE ALONG BUT
WOULD CALL OUT THOSE ISSUES AS
THINGS THAT I THINK ARE WORTHY
OF CONVERSATIONS AND SEEING HOW
THEY'RE GOING. TO BE RESOLVED
AS THE BILL MOVES FOR. THANK
YOU SENATOR SENT WHITE HOUSE
KEEPS ME SECURE I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A- TO. ON THE LIABILITY
I'D LIKE TO FOCUSING ON HE
LIABILITY THE BIGGER QUESTION
WILL BE. I'LL HAVE TO GO DEAL
WITH THAT. THE DOCKS ARE FOR
DOCTORS. IF THE LIABILITY PIECE
FOR THE HOSPITALS IS. REMAINS
THERE BUT THEY DON'T GET TO.
MAKE DECISIONS ON WHAT
PROCEDURES ARE BEING DONE. HOW
WITH THE C. AUTHOR HOW IS THAT
FAIR I GUESS. QUESTION A AUTHOR
M. SEMICON LONGER IF YOU CARE
TO ADDRESS IT NOW OUR NEW ONES.
WHATEVER YOU CHOOSE. I WILL SAY
VAX- THE LANGUAGE DOESN'T
CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT THE
LIABILITY OF HOSPITALS OR
MEDICAL STAFF- THE MEDICAL
STAFF STILL MUST INVESTIGATE
EVERY REPORT OF PHYSICIAN
MISCONDUCT AND IF THEY DON'T
THEN THE HOSPITAL GOVERNING
BOARD MUST ACT OF COURSE IF
THEY DON'T THEN THEY ARE
LIABLE- AND SO THEY'RE STILL
CHECKS AND BALANCES THAT REMAIN
THIS BILL DOESN'T- DO ANYTHING-
THAT WOULD COUNTER THAT HAVING
SAID THAT WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS JUST TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THE LANGUAGE IS
ADEQUATELY CLARIFIED BECAUSE IT
IS NOT THE INTENT- FOR THIS
BILL TO HAVE ANY IMPACT ON-
LIABILITY. THANK YOU BOB SAYING
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS- CENTER
CAMARADERIE ON. I KNOW YOU
WORKED HARD ON THIS ISSUE THAN
THIS IS A DIFFICULT AND
DELICATE ISSUE TRYING TO
BALANCE. THE HEALTHCARE
INTERESTS OF PATIENTS DOCTORS
AND HOSPITALS. DOCTORS OF
COURSE ARE DUTY BOUND TO THINK
IN TERMS THE BEST INTERESTS OF
THEIR PATIENTS AND HOSPITALS.
NEED TAKE A BROADER VIEW FOR
ALL THEIR PATIENTS. YOU'VE
HEARD. THE COMMENTS BY SEN
HERTZBERG AND SENATOR LAYERED-
AND I. HOPE AND TRUST THAT YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS SO THAT-
WE CAN REACH A PLACE OF GREATER
EQUANIMITY I'M GONNA SUPPORT
THE BILL- BUT I DO ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH CENTER LAYERED
CENTER HERTZBERG'S COMMENTS. SO
IS THERE A MOTION. SIR
HERTZBERG MOVES A BILL. RIGHT
MEDICI COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS SB SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR COM LOCKER
WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES- BURKE HI
I'M BURKE AYE PORGES. ABIERTO.
DID ASAL THE REST SO I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. BURGER
AYE JONES LAYERED HI HILLIARD I
A STERN STRIKE STERN I WAKE CAL
SKI. WIECKOWSKI AYE WIENER
WIENER I. THAT'S EIGHT ZERO SO
FAR ALL RIGHTY WILL PUT THE
BILL IN CALL. THEY SAY WELL I
SEE SEVEN ACQUIRE WHO IS NEXT
IN FILE ITEM. ONE ONE SECOND
EVERYONE. I APOLOGIZE TO THE
CALLER WOULD YOU WE TOOK THE
VOTE BEFORE YOU CLOSED THE CARE
TO TALK US OUT OF IT. NO I
DON'T WANT ANY OF THAT BUT WHAT
I WANTED TO SAY WAS I- FOR
THOSE OF YOU IN THE CHAMBER AND
ON THIS COMMITTEE I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT I AM AN HONEST
BROKER. AND I AM HAPPY TO TALK
WITH EVERYONE TO ANSWER ALL
QUESTIONS BECAUSE THE ONLY WAY
YOU GET REAL GOOD MEANINGFUL
BILLS PASSED IS BY BUILDING
COALITIONS AND LISTENING TO
EVERYONE TO MAKE SURE THAT
SSUES ARE ADDRESSED. I WANTED
TO SAY THAT OUR BILL DOES NOT
FORCE THE HAND OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IT SAYS THAT THE AG
SHALL CONSIDER- BUT IT DOES IT
DOESN'T SAY WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO WITH THE INFORMATION AND IN
FACT THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO
ANYTHING WITH THE INFORMATION
IT'S STILL RECOGNIZES THAT
THERE'S MEDICAL STAFF IN THE
GOVERNING BODY OF HOSPITALS AND
SO THERE S A SEPARATION OF
DUTIES. IT DOESN'T KNOWLEDGE
THAT ULTIMATELY HOSPITALS. YOU
KNOW OUR RESPONSIBLE. BUT THERE
ARE CLEAR DELINEATIONS ABOUT
PATIENT CARE AND THE
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR MEDICAL
STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT PATIENT
CARE IS PROVIDED TO EVERYONE.
I'M IN THE BILL IS FACIALLY
NEUTRAL IN A WAY THAT IS
APPLICABLE TO EVERYONE
NONPROFIT FACILITIES FOR PROFIT
FACILITIES EXCEPT AROUND. BUT I
WANT YOU ALL TO KNOW AND I
DIDN'T WANNA BE DISRESPECTFUL.
THAT I'VE HEARD THE CONCERNS
AND I DID TAKENOTES AND WILL
BE MAKING APPOINTMENTS WITH
YOUR OFFICES AND THAT THIS WILL
ALSO BE BEFORE THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE IN SO THERE WILL BE
TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED. AND ARE
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSED BEFORE
OR DURING THAT COMMITTEE SO
THANK YOU AND I HOPE IT'S STILL
EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU SO TO.
FIND THE NEXT SENATE MCGUIRE.
SENATE MCGUIRE WELCOME SB FIVE
FIVE FIVE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SECURE GOOD AFTERNOON AT FIRST
AND FOREMOST RESEARCHER I WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU
AND YOU'RE VERY CAPABLE STAFF
FOR ALL THE WORK ON THIS BILL.
A GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LOOK FIVE FIVE FIVE IS
GOING TO CREATE A NEW AND
INNOVATIVE SYSTEM FOR
COLLECTING AND DISPENSING
REVENUE FROM TRAINS IN
OCCUPANCY TAXES STATE TAXES
ALSO KNOWN AS T. O. T. FOR
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS
ACROSS THE GOLDEN STATE TO LOOK
IN CALIFORNIA EVERY CITY EVERY
COUNTY LEVY T. O. T. I. AND
THAT REVENUE IS. COLLECTED
TYPICALLY DO USE FOR GENERAL
FUND PURPOSES IT SUPPORT FIRE
AND POLICE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
GOOD ROADS CITY STREETS BUT
UNLIKE HOTELS AND MOTELS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS OFTEN HAVE A
CHALLENGING TIME COLLECTING
THAT TAX FOR SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS BECAUSE NUMBER
ONE HOST THE HOMEOWNERS ARE NOT
ALWAYS AWARE OF THE REQUIREMENT
TO BE TO COLLECT AND REMIT
THOSE TAXES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. CANDIDLY DON'T
ALWAYS KNOW WHAT PROPERTIES ARE
BEING USED FOR SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS THEREFORE WE
BELIEVE LIKELY TENS OF MILLIONS
OF NOT HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN DEBT TAX REVENUE
GOES UNCOLLECTED EVERY YEAR SO
HERE'S WHAT THE BILL WILL DO
IT'S GOING TO HELP CITIES AND
COUNTIES COLLECT THIS REVENUE
WHICH IS LEGALLY OWED TO THEM
BY CREATING A STATEWIDE DEAD
TAX COLLECTION PROGRAM THAT
WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION. FOR
THOSE JURISDICTIONS WHO CHOOSE
TO PARTICIPATE THIS IS
VOLUNTARY IT'S AN OPT IT'S
MODELED AFTER THE MARKET PLACE
DISORDER ACT THAT- WE WORKED
WITH THIS IN THE WOMAN BURKE ON
LAST YEAR WHICH NOW COLLECTS
SALES TAXES FROM. ONLINE
PLATFORMS LIKE AMAZON AND
WAYFAIR THIS PROGRAM FOR
VACATION RENTAL PLATFORMS WOULD
REQUIRE THESE PLATFORMS SUCH AS
AIRBNB IN VR BO TO COLLECT THE
APPROPRIATE BED TAX FROM
CUSTOMERS WHEN SHORT TERM
RENTALS BOOKED THROUGH THE
PLATFORM THE PLATFORM WOULD
THEN RE MET THE FUNDS COLLECTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA. DEPARTMENT
OF TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION.
TO AT THE CITY COUNTY IT'S
SIMPLE. THE PROGRAM WILL BE
BALLING FOR LOCAL AGENCIES AND
LOCAL AGENCIES WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO ENACT AN ORDINANCE
TO PARTICIPATE. THIS BILL
MEMBERS THIS BILL DOES NOT
PROHIBIT CITIES AND COUNTIES
WHO WANT TO CONTINUE WITH THEIR
OWN VOLUNTARY COLLECTION
AGREEMENTS. WITH PLATFORM SO
THERE ARE SEVERAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA THAT
HAVE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS WITH
FOR EXAMPLE AIRBNB IT DOESN'T
DISRUPT THOSE AGREEMENTS. THIS
JUST GIVES JURISDICTIONS WHO
DON'T HAVE THE VOLUNTARY
COLLECTION COLLECTION
AGREEMENTS WITH THE HOSTING
PLATFORMS WHICH BY THE WAY IS
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
AND COUNTIES. WHO DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO CREATE THE
AGREEMENTS OR HAVE EVER STRUCK
ONE WITH AN ONLINE PLATFORM. SO
TODAY LAYS IN GERMAN WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
JEAN HURST WITH THIS. SHE'S
REPRESENTING THE RULE COUNTY
REPRESENTS A CALIFORNIA AND WE
ALSO HAVE- THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA HISPANIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. BUT WE
HAVE- JULIAN- CONNECTED WITH US
WHO IS ON THE LINE TO BE A TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR MCGUIRE OF
MISTERS IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE. I
AM HERE MISTER CHAIRMAN READY
TO PRESENT ALL RIGHT THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU- THANKS
ONCE AGAIN MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JEAN HURST CALLING INTO
THE AND THE HALF OF THE WORLD
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES THAT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND HE FIVE
FIVE FIVE- AND- THE GOOD
SENATOR MENTIONED CHANGE
OCCUPANCY TAXES ARE AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT AS- COUNTY
REVENUE PARTICULARLY. IN THOSE
REGIONS THAT ARE HEAVILY.
DEPENDENT ON TOURISM. AND AS WE
EMERGE THE PANDEMIC AND BEGIN
TO WELCOME INDIVIDUALS BACK TO
OUR TOWARDS COUNTIES- WE ARE
THESE REVENUES HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT TO THE
RECOVERY. OF THE COMMUNITY. AND
TO THAT END HE FIVE FIVE FIVE
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
COLLECT TRANSIT OCCUPANCY TAXES
FROM SHORT TERM RENTAL UNIT AND
THE LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD.
WITH THE TRADITIONAL LODGING
FACILITIES AS A RESULT WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
AND RECKLESSLY SEXUALLY.
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUST FIRST
IS- JULIAN. CAN CAN AT
AVAILABLE YES WHICH DIFFERENCE
CHAIRMAN GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
YOU CAN ANY CALIFORNIA'S PANIC
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE AND THANK
YOU SENATORS- THE OPPORTUNITY
DRESS YOU UP THIS AFTERNOON THE
CHAMBER IS HAS OVER A HUNDRED
AND FIVE- HISPANIC AND BUSINESS
ASSOCIATIONS TRADE ASSOCIATION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WHICH IT
COVERS FROM THE NORTH TO NAPA
AND SONOMA COUNTIES TO THE
FOOTHILLS TO THE COASTAL
COMMUNITIES AND DOWN INTO THE
pTO DISREGARD GREAT STRIPES- THE
CHEC RIGHT TO THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF JERRY MCGUIRE'S. OF
STUFF CENTER MAGUIRE'S SB FIVE
BY FIVE. SB FIVE FIVE FIVE
OFFERS OR STATE AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES A QUICK AND
EFFECTIVE SOLUTION FOR
COLLECTING A DISPENSARY TRANSIT
TRANSCEND THE OCCUPANCY TAXES
TAX REVENUE FROM SHORT TERM
MIDDLE CLASS. HOSTED IN
KAPLAN'S. ADULT OF KOBE CITIZEN
CAL ARE PROJECTED TO PAY SEVERE
SHORTFALL. OKAY CHILDREN
RETURNS TO CAL. GOP WILL AS AN
IMPORT AND NEVER TO THAT WILL
ALLOW LOCAL THE BECAUSE WE CAP
INTO THE OUR DOLLAR AND WE
INVEST FACTS BACK INTO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. D. O. T. PAID A
PORTABLE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BE
REINVESTED IN FIRE POLICE
SERVICES LOCAL SCHOOLS
LIBRARIES AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THAT WILL
PROMOTE HEALTHY ECONOMIES AND
SAFE NEIGHBORHOODS. AND WHAT IS
GOOD FOR COMMUNITIES IS GOOD
FOR OUR SMALL BUSINESSES WE
URGE SWIFT PASSAGE OF SB FIVE
FIVE FIVE EIGHT CALIFORNIA'S
POST PANDEMIC ECONOMIC RECOVERY
TO SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SMALL BUSINESSES AND VITAL
PUBLIC SERVICES THAT RELY. ON
THE TRANSIENT OCCUPANCY TAXES
TAX REVENUE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF OUR COMMON.
THANK YOU MISTER KENNEDY ON
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I
SEE IN THE I NOT A ROOM ONE
TWELVE LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE FIVE FIVE. THAT
WOULD BE WONDERFUL. IN SUPPORT
OF. THE BILL GOES THIS LINE
FIVE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS UNDERESTIMATE
AS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
HALF MOON BAY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT OVER THE
LINE FIVE FIFTY SEVEN I'M SORRY
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA SO LISA
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SONOMA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE NEXT A LITTLE AND ONE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ADAM THOMPSON BUT ON BEHALF OF
AIRBNB SHOP SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO OTHER COMPETITION
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURN OPPOSITION I SEE NO
ONE LISTENS PRIMARY OPPOSITION
I SEE NO IN THE GALLERY TO SEE
KNOWN IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
MODERATOR ARE. ALL RIGHT- THERE
ANYONE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FIVE FIVE FIVE. I JUST MODEL OF
GOVERNMENT LINE NUMBER THERE'S
ONE QUEUING UP. IN ORDER TO
LINE A FIVE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY MEDICARE MEMBERS ON
THAT GROW ON THE HALF LEGAL
CALIFORNIA CITY SOME OF THE IN
BETWEEN WE ARE STILL CONVENING.
LOCAL OFFICIALS NOT LONG AT THE
FIVE FIVE FIVE. REALLY THANK
YOU DOCTOR MORE. OKAY AFTER.
OKAY AND- WELL WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE DATA
COLLECTION REQUIRED BY THE
MEASURE OUT WE DID WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OF COURSE YOU NEED TO
DO SOMETHING OF THIS PROGRAM IS
ON THE BUCK BOB OKAY HAD YOU
OPTED THAT THEY YOU HAVE ACCESS
TO THE FOR ALL THE APPROPRIATE
TAX- COLLECTING INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO ENSURE A PROPER
COLLECTION AND IF NECESSARY-
ABLE TO DO A FULL- THE-
COLLECTIONS. OKAY THE WORK WITH
YA I THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU I'M A TEACHER. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE. AT
THIS TIME WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE
ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT BRING IT
BACK TO THE CHAMBER QUESTIONS I
SEE NO MICROPHONES REYES- IS
THERE A MOTION. SEVERAL COUNTS
THE MOST A BILL. SENATE
MAJORITY COULD CLOSE THANK YOU
SO MUCH RESEARCHER I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A LONG DAY FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO CITIES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ONLY SEVENTY A
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION
AGREEMENTS WITH. THE ONLINE
PLATFORMS WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE TO BRING
EQUITY TO THE SYSTEM. THANK YOU
SENATE MCGUIRE. ALL RIGHT SIR
WHY KELSEY MOVES THE BILL
MEDICI COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS SENATE BILL FIVE
FIVE FIVE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
WHITE CASKET THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO-THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE I. AM
BURKE I BURGESS. CAMBIADO DID
ASAL. THE REST I CONSENT.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG I'D JONES. AIRED ON A
LAYERED ICE STERN JOURNAL STERN
AYE A WHITE CAL SKI. WHY CASKEY
AYE WIENER WIENER AYE A THAT
pWE'LL PLACE A BLOWN CALL THANK
YOU SIR MCGUIRE CENTER PAN I
KNOW CENTER PAN WAS HERE
EARLIER WAITING VERY PATIENTLY.
HE'S RUNNING NOW TO THE PODIUM.
YOU CENTER PAN THAK YOU FOR
WHAT YOU CATCH YOUR BREATH
THERE GO AHEAD WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU S. B. SB FIVE
NINE EIGHT. THANK YOU CHAIR-
BURKE- MEMBERS- SB FIVE NINE
EIGHT WOULD ALLOW EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS AT THE SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL TRANSIT WHICH IS IN MY
DISTRICT TO MOVE THAT UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICE CHARGES TO THE
JURISDICTION OF THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS PURPLE.
CURRENTLY MOST PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
DO FALL UNDER PER JURISDICTION
FOR THE RESOLUTION OF EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE KIND OF. CONFLICTS
MOST TRANSIT DISTRICTS HOWEVER
REMAIN UNDER THE JURISDICTION
OF THE STATE COURT SYSTEM DUE
TO HISTORICAL PRECEDENT. SO IN
ORDER TO RESOLVE A CONFLICT
BETWEEN SACRAMENTO REGIONAL
TRANSIT IN ONE OF ITS EMPLOYEES
ORGANIZATIONS A WRIT MUST BE
FILED IN SUPERIOR COURT BY WHEN
THE INVOLVED PARTIES. THIS
EXISTING PROCESS IS TIME
CONSUMING EXPENSIVE AND MAY
PLACE AN UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE
CHARGE WITH THE JUDGE WHO HAS
LITTLEEXPERIENCE WITH EMPLOYER
THE PERM CONFLICT RESOLUTION
PROCESSES STREAMLINE THIS
EXPENSIVE FOR THE EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS AND TAXPAYERS AND
SPECIFIC TO CONTRACT
RESOLUTIONS OF PUBLIC SECTOR. I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT THIS. BILL
IS SUPPORT BY BOTH THE THAT IS
THE SECOND REGIONAL TRANSIT AS
WELL AS THE- LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS AND- EXPECT THE
ASPIRIN I THAT NIGHT WITNESSES
SAID CHRISTOPHER MEYER BEHALF
OF APPS ME AND HUNTER STERN ON
BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. LOCAL TWELVE FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. THIS
MISTER MAYER OR MR STERN ON THE
PHONE MISTER HUNTER STERN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS KRISTOFF MAYOR AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES ARMY. WE
ARE ONE OF THE CO SPONSOR OF SB
FIVE NINETY EIGHT. WE BELIEVE
THAT PERMITTED THAT MORE
APPROPRIATE VENUE FOR EDUCATION
UP UNFAIR PRACTICE CHARGES FOR
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL TRANSIT.
AND AT SENATOR CANDIDATE THE
DISTRICT AGREES- WRITTEN
AMENDMENT THAT WILL ALLOW THE
BARGAINING UNIT THAT OUR
TEACHER MOVED TO THE
JURISDICTION OF HER AS THEY ARE
READY BY PROVIDING. WRITTEN
NOTICE TO PERMANENT DISTRICT.
ARTIST BOB PROFITED OUT OF
REACH FOR ONE BARGAINING WHICH
NOT PREPARED TO CURB JERRY AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
AND I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MR MEHRA
CISTERN. MISTER HUNTER STERN.
YES THANK YOU KAREN BURKE-
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS HUNTER
STERN I'M WITH THE IBEW LOCAL
TWELVE FORTY FIVE- SO NOT TO
REPEAT TOO MUCH- WE SUPPORT THE
BILL WE'RE PLEASED THAT
SACRORUM T. ALSO SUPPORTS THE
BILL OUR EMPLOYER- WE'RE
LOOKING FOR GREATER EFFICIENCY-
IN OUR RELATIONSHIP- WITH THE
DISTRICT- QUICKER ROUTE DISPUTE
RESOLUTIONS HAS CENTER PAN
MENTIONED AS WELL AS LOWER COST
TO THE DISTRICT AND IT TO ITS
CUSTOMERS- WE'RE ALSO. ONE OF
THE BENEFITS THAT'S NOT WRITTEN
INTO THE BILL BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY- BEING PART OF IT IS
GREATER COLLABORATION-
COLLABORATION BOTH BETWEEN-
SACK RT THE DISTRICT- AND ITS
EMPLOYEES AND ITS EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTATIVES AS WELL AS
GREATER COLLABORATION- AMONG
THE DIFFERENT EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTATIVES THE DIFFERENT
THE UNIONS ON THE PROPERTY- IN
THIS PROCESS ITSELF HAS CREATED
GREATER COLLABORATION AND ALL
OF THESE THINGS ACTUALLY CREATE
GREATER TRUST AND THEREFORE
STRONGER LABOR LABOR RELATIONS-
WITHIN THE DISTRICTS SO WE DO
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS AND WE
APPRECIATE. YOUR HEARING THE
BILL TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR STERN ALL OTHERS IN SUPPORT
IN THE GALLERY. YES WE HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AND KREMIN HERE ON THE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS WE ARE ONE
OF THREE OF THE EMPLOYEE UNIONS
ARE SPONSORING THIS BILL AND WE
WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
ALL RIGHT I SEE NO ONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY OF ROOM ONE TWELVE
I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE NINE EIGHT. BY
CERVANTES MISTER MODERATOR FEW
KEY WHAT DOES NOT SUPPORT. KOK
AND AGAIN THOSE IN SUPPORT OF
FIVE NINETY EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
LINE FIVE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH PROBABLY. NINE FIVE
SEVENTY ONE. RIGHT HI BASED ON
THIS IS KERR TEAM I'M CALLING
TO OPPOSE SB SIX SIX THREE. ALL
RIGHT WELL WE'RE ALL ON A
DIFFERENT BILL RIGHT NOW ALSO
MISS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD.
WHAT THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE NINE EIGHT. AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE FIVE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARED
SANDERS JERRY BROWN AND- TO
HALF OF THAT YOU KNOW YOU
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF- FIVE NINE EIGHT IN THE
APPRECIATE COMPLYING WORKERS-
SENATOR DR PAN AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THEM ON THIS IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE WOULD HAVE
KNOWN. BUT NO OTHERS INCLUDE.
HI AND THOSE IN OPPOSITION I
HAVE NO ONE LISTED IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION I SEE NO
ONE ROOM ONE TWELVE LET'S TURN
THE PHONE LINES FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATOR PANS. SB.
FIVE NINE EIGHT. AND AGAIN DOES
NOT POSITION PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND I DON'T SEE ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I SEE
NO MICROPHONES REYES- YES SIR
WHAT KOWSKI. SERIK ASKING MOVES
THE BILL- SENATE PAN DO YOU
CARE TO CLOSE ARE STRICTLY S.
WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU PERFECT
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM CHIEF COUNSEL STRADA
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
SENATE BILL FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY EIGHT BY SENATOR PAN
MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
SKIED THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE HI. NUMBER I BURGESS
CABALLERO DID I SO DID I SO I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE JONES AIRED ON
HILLIARD AYE STERN TURN ON
STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI AYE
WIECKOWSKI AYE WIENER. WIENER
AYE YOU HAVE EIGHT ZERO SO FAR
ALREADY THANK YOU WILL PUT THAT
I DO ON CALL THANK YOU CENTER
PAN. NEXT WE HAVE CENTER
LAYERED AS P. FOUR FOUR SEVEN
CENTER LAYER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND- FIRST
LET ME SAY IN PRESENTING S. B.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN THAT I WOULD
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
A PLACE OF FOUR YEAR SUNSET
INTO THE BILL. ARE ALSO LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON THE
BILL LANGUAGE. CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF ONLY FIVE STATES IN THE
ENTIRE NATION THAT REWARDS
DEFENDANTS FOR PROLONGING COURT
DOES PROCEDURES. LEAVING
VICTIMS UNABLE TO OBTAIN
JUSTICE SB FOUR FOUR SEVEN
EXTENDS OF VICTIMS RIGHTS AND
THE RIGHT OF THEIR LOVED ONES
TO PURSUE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
HUMAN SUFFERING EVEN IF. THEY
DIED PRIOR TO THE CASE
RESOLUTION. ALL TOO OFTEN
DEFENDANTS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
EXISTING LAW PROLONGING COURT
PROCEEDINGS IN HOPE THOSE
DELAYS WILL OUTWEIGH OF THE
VICTIMS OF THEIR OWN
NEGLIGENCE. COVERED NINETEEN IS
HIGHLIGHTED THIS INJUSTICE IS
INDIVIDUALS AND THOSE WHO WERE
GRANTED A TRIAL PREFERENCE ARE
UNABLE TO GET THEIR CASE IS
HEARD AND RESOLVED AND MAY DIE
WITHOUT EVER SEEING JUSTICE. S.
B. FOUR FOUR SEVEN REFLECTS THE
FACT THAT THE VICTIM SHOULD NOT
SUFFER DUE TO DEFENDANTS GAMING
THE SYSTEM. WHAT COVERED
NINETEEN RELATED COURT
PROCEDURE CLOSURES HAVE GREATLY
EXACERBATED THE ISSUE THIS
PROBLEM IS NOT NEW AND
DEFENDANTS MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THE OPPOSITION
IS ARGUING THAT WE SHOULD LIMIT
THE BILL TO COVERT NINETEEN
IMPACTED CASES ONLY. BY THIS
PROBLEM EXISTED FOR DECADES
PRIOR TO COVERT NINETEEN AND
WHILE COVERED NINETEEN RELATED
COURT CLOSURES HAVE GREATLY
EXACERBATED THE ISSUE IT HAS
LONG BEEN A TACTIC TO DELAY IT
DRAG OUT CASES UNTIL VICTIMS
DIE. BECAUSE THE WINDFALL THAT
REDUCES ACCOUNTABILITY. THE
OPPOSITION IS ALSO STATED THAT
CURRENT LAW IS SUFFICIENT AND
DOES NOT MERIT A CHANGE HOWEVER
WE ALL AGREED THAT OUR NATION
AND STATE TO THE VAULT OVER THE
PAST SIXTY YEARS WHEN THIS WAS
FIRST ENACTED IN THIS WAY. THE
BILL CONTAINS A SUNSET- WITH
THE COMMITTEE I'M AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL ALLOW AMPLE TIME TO
ACCEPT IT IT ASSESS THE IMPACT
OF THIS CHANGE. VICTIMS AND
THEIR LOVED ONES DESERVE
JUSTICE TO BE SERVED WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TODAY IS
LARA HOW BENEATH AND CRISTINA
SWIPE CARD- THANKS TO. THE
COMMITTEE AND MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY REP REQUESTED I
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED-
IF MISS ALBANY IS ON THE LINE.
THE FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER SHARON MEMBERS
MY NAME IS LAUREL ALBANY I'M A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
COSPONSORED THE BILL ALONG WITH
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION
CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE TODAY TO
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TO
PRESERVE DAMAGES FOR HUMAN
SUFFERING AND ASK YOU TO
ELIMINATE THE DEATH DISCOUNT.
THEY'RE REAL EXAMPLES OF HUMAN
SUFFERING FROM CASES WE HAVE
SEEN DURING MONTHS OF AGONIZING
PAIN FROM THIRD DEGREE BURNS IN
THE HOSPITAL. LOSING THE USE OF
THEIR LEGS. THE DEVELOPING AN
INSPECTOR'S RELATED CANCER THAT
SUFFOCATE YOU WITH YOUR OWN
CHEST ISSUE. KILIK MOST STATES
CALIFORNIA ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
THESE DAMAGES ARE REAL. AND
THAT SOMEONE WHO NEGLIGENTLY
CAUSES THOSE DAMAGES SHOULD
COMPENSATE THE VICTIM. BUT WE
ARE ONE OF A HANDFUL OF STATES
THAT WIPES OUT THOSE DAMAGES
WHEN THE VICTIM DIES GIVING THE
PERSON WHO HARD THE DEATH
DISCOUNT. THERE'S NO POLICY
REASON FOR THIS ROLE THAT
EXISTS BECAUSE DECADES AGO THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY LOBBIED FOR
IT. THE HARDEST ON ELDERS AND
CHILDREN ON STATE HOME PARENTS
AND THOSE WITH DISABILITIES
BECAUSE WITHOUT LOSS INCOME
MOST OF THEIR DAMAGES ARE HUMAN
SUFFERING DAMAGES. AND THIS
CREATES A SECOND INJUSTICE WITH
LAWYERS FOR NEGLIGENT
DEFENDANTS HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO
DELAY THESE CASES UNTIL THE
VICTIM DIED. WIPING OUT HUMAN
SUFFERING DAMAGES AND
BENEFITING THEIR NEGLIGENT
CLIENTS WITH A DENTIST CAL.
THESE MONEY DRIVEN DELAYED NOT
ALL HARM BUT THEY ADD TO THE
ALREADY HEAVY BURDEN ON OUR
COURTS AND WHILE THIS PROBLEM
EXISTED BEFORE COVE IT. IT'S
IMPACT IS THAT GREATLY
MAGNIFIED THAT THE CODE RELATED
COURT SHUT DOWN. I AM ASKING
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TO SUPPORT
SENATE BILL FOUR FOUR SEVEN TO
ELIMINATE THE DEATH DISCOUNT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
ALBANY. CRISTINA STRIKER ARE
YOU AVAILABLE. YES I AM ALL
RIGHT YOU MAY PROCEED. SO WHAT
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
FOR A PART I WAS MARRIED TO MY
HUSBAND GEORGE RECORDS OR FORTY
EIGHT YEARS ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIFTY PASSED AWAY FROM
MESOTHELIOMA A TERMINAL CANCER
CAUSED BY ASBESTOS. DON'T
MISDIAGNOSIS IN JUNE OF TWENTY
NINETEEN WHEN THE DOCTORS TOLD
US THE BAD NEWS I WAS
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATED I WOULD
THANK YOU VERY TO WHAT MY LIFE
MIGHT BE WITHOUT HIM BY MY SIDE
MCGEORGE OF SPRING CAMP TO
DIAGNOSE A SUBSCRIBER BUT IT
WAS A FAMILY MAN WITH THE TIME
TO DO WHATEVER TREATMENT
NECESSARY TO BE WITH ME AND OUR
DAUGHTERS. GEORGE MEDIALLY
UNDERWENT FOUR VERY DIFFICULT
ROUNDS OF CHEMOTHERAPY HE DID
NOT RESPOND WELL TO THE
TREATMENT IT WAS EXTREMELY NAS
IT WAS VERY TIRED AND
COMPLETELY OFF THE SEPTICTANK
AS A RESULT SHE LOST NEARLY
THIRTY POUNDS. THE DOCTORS
WHICH GEORGE TO AN
IMMUNOTHERAPY TREATMENT WELL HE
CAN TO RESPOND A LITTLE BETTER
I COULD SEE THE CANCER. WAS
PROGRESSING INSIDE HIM. THANK
TO ME ABOUT. PAIN OVER TIME THE
WE KNOW AND HARDER TIME FOR. WE
ACTUALLY DID PUT HIM ON OXYGEN
THERE IS ALWAYS MY ROCK AND THE
PILLARS DURING THANK YOU YOU
VERY MUCH SUFFERING. AND THE
WAS TAKING A MENTAL AND
EMOTIONALLY. I THANK YOU
AGAINST WITHIN SECTION ANYTHING
LANDED BACK IN THE HOUSE AND.
DR DEPARTMENTS THAT IT SHOULD
BE KEPT DOWN AND WOULD REQUIRE
GALLAGHER TREATMENT FOR THE
REST OF THE BILL. WITH THE
COULD BE REALLY IN THE HOT. THE
PHYSICAL PAIN AND IS A LOT WITH
SEPARATE FINDING AND IT'S-
MIGHT CONTINUE AS I. ALL THAT
HE WHEN. TO BUT JUDGE WAS DOING.
PERKS AFTER SERVING IN THE
UNITED MAYBE BACK IN THE-
FIFTY. BEGAN A LONG CAREER IN
THE AUTO INDUSTRY. THE WORK
THAT APARTMENT FOR OVER THREE
YEARS AT SEVERAL DIEGO AREA
NISSAN AND- DEALERSHIPS. IT WAS
DURING THE WORK THAT HE WAS
REGULAR CATTLE FOUND GREAT
CLUTCHES AND GET. THAT CAN
TRAIN AT THAT. HE WAS ALSO A
ALL THE MECHANICAL MAINTENANCE
WORK WITH- THANK PART. NISSAN
NEVER WARNED AT THE IT CAN FOR
THE IT THAT HAD. NO TRAIN THEM
ON THE TABLE PRACTICE. WE
BELIEVE WORK AT ME AND SERVICE
IN US NAY CROSS EXPOSED. THAT
THAT'S THE WORDS OKAY LED TO
HIS CAN'T. REFILED THIS SECTION
THE HE WILL TO HOLD ME KIND OF
TELLING AND A STATE. WE WERE
GRANTED A PRO. HIGHER TRIAL
DATE IN JUNE TWENTY **** DON'T.
THE CALL NINETEEN TEN CLOSE THE
COURT. ARGUED WITH THE OVER NO
AND CAN'T GET THICKER THICKER.
AND I WOULD MAKE YOU THINK THAT
ARE EVERYTHING TOWARDS ONE
THROUGH ALL THE PAIN AND ALL
THE WE NOW ALL THE AND- THAT
NEEDS OF ALL GET A- BECAUSE
GEORGE LIVE LONG ENOUGH. TO
MAKE IT TO THE TRIAL. MISTER
PROJECTED GOING TO FOR THE AND
ON. TO CUT YOU OFF FORTUNE WE
HAVE SOME TIME WITH. ON A SORRY
FOR YOUR LOSS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT I SEE NO
ONE OF THE GALLERY TO SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- NOW
TURNING TO THE PHONE LINES-
MISTER MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. FOUR FOUR SEVEN. BUT THEY
DIDN'T. AND THOSE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR FOUR SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO GO TO LINE FIVE
EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
CHIANG DUSTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ZURCHER MEMBERS CHRIS
ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALLED IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR FOUR SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THIS AND ACTUALLY
THE ONE FIVE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT SURE
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA COSPONSORED THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
ONE FIVE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MEDICARE
MEMBERS MARIE KONISHI HARMLESS
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
ACCESSIBLE TO LINE FOR SIXTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS. YEAH
YOU. AND NEXT A LITTLE WIND
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PAKISTAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEY THE
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE SUPPORT AS
ONE OF THE SPONSORS OFTEN ASK
HIS DATE THE PORT FOR THE
DISTRICT COUNCIL ACQUIRED
WORKERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES AND THE AFFECTED
WORKERS LOCAL SIXTEEN RETIREES
THANK YOU THANK YOU. IN JUST A
MOMENT. WE HAVE ONE MORE THAT
IS JUST CUTER. AND THEY'VE
DROPPED IN Q. WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME RT
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR AND IN
OPPOSITION I HAVE A- JAMIE HUFF
IS WELL AS MICHAEL BELOW- THIS
OFFER YOU AVAILABLE. YES- I AM
ALREADY. I BELIEVE MITCHELL
THAT WANTED TO GO FIRST MY
IPHONE MR BELOW I AM THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
AM MIKE FOLLOWED ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LAWYER
SPECIALIZING IN DEFENDING.
CIVIL CASES- WE HAVE GREAT
SPONSORS WERE NOT ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT THE BILL WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC HOPEFULLY A ONCE IN A
CENTURY EVENT WE'RE NOT
INSENSITIVE TO THE INABILITY OF
PLAINTIFFS TO GET TO TRIAL
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS TO TRY TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. BUT THIS BILL WILL
CHANGE LITERALLY A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE YEARS OF CALIFORNIA
LAW. WHICH WILL DRAMATICALLY
EXPAND DAMAGES AVAILABLE FOR
VIRTUALLY EVERY TYPE OF SUPPORT
CASE IN CALIFORNIA EVEN WHERE
THE PLAINTIFFS DIES- AND THE
DEATH HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE UNDERLYING TORT SO IT'LL
APPLY TO PERSONAL INJURY
EMPLOYMENT. MALPRACTICE
RITUALLY TOWARD CASE CALIFORNIA
LAW OVER. THE ENTIRE HISTORY OF
THE STATE HAS CAREFULLY
CONSTRUCTED A TORT SYSTEM SO
THAT DAMAGES ARE AVAILABLE TO
THOSE PEOPLE WHO SUFFER THEM.
AND WE ALLOW IN SURVIVAL
ACTIONS PUNITIVE DAMAGES AS A
DETERRENT WE DON'T SEE THIS AS
A WINDFALL WE SEE IT AS PART OF
A CAREFULLY CONSTRUCTED TOWARDS
SYSTEM. NOW IT MAY BE TRUE THAT
FORTY FIVE STATES ALLOW PAIN
AND SUFFERING PASS YEAH. BUT WE
BELIEVE FAR FEWER. STATES ALLOW
PUNITIVE DAMAGES IN SURVIVAL
ACTIONS WITHOUT LIMITS WE GRANT
PREFERENCE DESIGNATIONS IN
CERTAIN CASES TO GET PEOPLE TO
TRIAL- QUICKER. WE LIMIT
DEPOSITIONS TO TRY TO GET
PEOPLE TO TRIAL- QUICKER AND WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THE TOTALITY OF
THE TORT SYSTEM- SB FOUR FOUR
SEVEN WILL INCREASE DAMAGES FOR
VIRTUALLY EVERY COURT CLAIM
WHERE THE PLAINTIFF DIES PRIOR
TO JUDGMENT. AND THAT'S TRUE OF
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC DEFENDER.
THIS WILL APPLY TO ACTIONS
AGAINST SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CITY AND COUNTY. AND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. SO WE'RE VERY
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
DRAMATIC CHANGE IN THE LAW WE
APPRECIATE ATTEMPTS TO NARROW
THE BILL WE DON'T THINK THE
FOUR YEARS SINCE THAT GETS US
THERE. THE WORDING THAT WE HAVE
SEEN WHAT APPLY THE SUNSET TO
ALL CASES WHICH APPROVED PRIOR
TO ONE ONE TWENTY SIX SO THAT
EVERY EXISTING TORT CASES NOW.
LET'S EVENTS THAT ARISE DURING
THE FOUR YEAR PERIOD BELOW
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT'S OF LIMITATION. THANK YOU
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE OPPOSE
HI THANK YOU SIR. BOB MISS OFF.
THANK YOU SO MUCH COULD MR
NUMBER. MY NAME IS JAMIE AND
I'M WITH WILL JOHNSON ADVOCATE
HEALTH. NINETY TWO IN ORDER O
ABOUT BEFORE FOR SEVEN TWO WELL
WE DO HAVE GREAT RESPECT TO THE
OFFER AND HIS STAFF AND
APPRECIATE HIS WILLINGNESS TO
AMEND THE BILL TO PLANT THAT.
WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
COMMENDED BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THE REVISED VERSION STILL HAVE
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON OUR CIVIL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND ULTIMATELY
HURT CONSUMERS AND TAXPAYERS.
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE MOST
IF NOT THE MOST. CONSUMER FROM
THE CIVIL COURT IN THE NATION.
WE OFFER PREFERRED FILING
SYSTEM FOR ELDERLY OR THOSE
WITH HEALTH ISSUES TO CUT THE
LINE FOR EXPEDITED TRIAL WE
HAVE SHOWN. THAT DISTRICTS
DEPOSITION TIME FOR ME. TO DIE
ASSEMBLY DOESN'T DRAG ON WE
ALLOW YOU TO DAMAGES AND
SURVIVAL ACTIONS ON TOP OF%
COMPENSATORY DAMAGES. AND MOST
SURVIVAL ACTIONS ARE JOIN WITH
THE SURVIVORS OWN LONG TOLD US
ACTION WHERE SHE OR HE CAN
RECOVER AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THANK YOUNG AGAIN. SUPPORT AL
WIRE FROM OTHER STATES IT'S
BECAUSE ALL THE WAYS WE PROTECT
POINT IT SHOULD BE ALREADY
ALLOW FOR PUNITIVE DAMAGE
RECOVERY IN SURVIVAL ACTION WE
BELIEVE ADDING ANOTHER FORM OF
PROJECTED DAMAGES IS EXPECTED.
TO MEET EXCEPT A COUPLE OF
COMMITTEE BORNE BY CONSUMERS
SHOULD STILL HAVE HUGE
IMPLICATIONS ACROSS ALL SECTORS
OF OUR ECONOMY WILL INCREASE
COSTS FOR BOTH STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO ARE FREQUENTLY
EXPOSED. INTEREST THERE. WILL
BE A CRITICALLY IN AN APPALLING
FOR YOUR SONS THAT YOUR MAN IS
AWARDED TO APPLY DECATUR
ACCRUED IN THE NEXT FOUR YEARS
WHICH MEANS THE BILL PLAY A
KEY. STEP WILL NOT EVEN HAVE
BEEN FILED BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX
MAKING THE RECOVERY APPLICABLE
WELL BEYOND THE SENSE THAT. OUR
COALITION HAS AFTER THE BILL BE
APPLIED ONLY TO THE TEACHER
COULD PERSONALLY IMPACTED BY
THE RECENT COURT BACKLOG WE
STILL BELIEVE THAT THE BEST
APPROACH ALL DONE NOT BY SAYING
THAT. WE BELIEVE WELL REASONED
AND LONGSTANDING PUBLIC POLICY
SHOULD BE CHANGED ON A
TEMPORARY AND HOPEFULLY A ONCE
IN A LIFETIME SITUATION WE
BELIEVE THE RIGHT PRO A RIGHT
APPROACH ON THAT WOULD BE TO
LIMIT THE BILL TO FOCUS ON.
PERSONAL INJURY CASE- THE LADY.
ASIAN TO SB FOUR FOUR SEVEN
COULD QUEUE UP. AS MODERATOR WE
HAVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE SP FOUR FOUR SEVEN. YES WE
HAVE FOUR IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
RT. I AM GOOD LINE FIVE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBERS STATE BORDERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES WITH A LINER
COMMENTS THAT DOESN'T DEVELOP
AND HAVE RESPECTFULLY
APPROACHED. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
TO THE LINE FIVE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDON
MARQUEE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. IN MEXICO LINE
NUMBER FIVE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS MIKE MADIGAN'S
FROM CONSUMER WATCHDOG AND MY
APOLOGIES FOR OUR LATE BUT
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. THANK YOU. AND ACTUALLY
GET A LINE OF FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JENNIFER
BARRERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE CLOSED AT THE FOUR
FOUR SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AN EXTRA LINE FIVE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AMY BLOOMBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH FACILITY
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND
ACTUALLY GOT A LINE FIVE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS IS BOB NAYLOR OF
REPRESENTING SIX BEDS LINCOLN
ASSOCIATION OF MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND SMALL ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITIES WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS
FROM COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS I
SEE NO MICROPHONES REYES- IS
THERE A MOTION. SO I. CAL
SCHIMEL I'M SORRY CENTER WIENER
JIM QUESTION. I HAVE A
STATEMENT. MEANT YEAH OKAY GOOD
CENTER WE AYE I MOVE THE BILL-
THE BILL- IF MY CONCERN OR
BECAUSE HE IS NOT NO I SO- I
COME TO THIS AS SOMEONE WHO
SPENT FIFTEEN YEARS AS A
DEFENSE ATTORNEY- AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. AND I UNDERSTAND-
CIVIL DEFENSE ATTORNEY- AND SO
ON A ON SAW NOT JUST IN MY OWN
CASES THAT I HANDLED AS DEPUTY
CITY ATTORNEY DEFENDING THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO GROUNDS FOR LAWSUITS-
BUT ALSO IN OBSERVING OTHER
LAWSUITS FRANKLY ARBITRARY
NATURE OF THIS CUT OFF. AND THE
FACT THAT YOU WOULD HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE HAPPEN
TO PASS AWAY IT WOULD
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE
MONETARY VALUE OF DAMAGES- ON
OF THAT- OF THAT CASE AND THAT
WHICH IS IN FACT EVERYTHING IN
TERMS OF THE NEGOTIATIONS. AND
SO I THINK- IT IS ARBITRARY AND
NUTS WILL HAVE A FEW STATES
HAVE THIS RULE- AND I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO KEEP. IN
MIND. THAT THE SUFFERED THE
NONAKA DAMAGE RUN THROUGH THE
DAY OF THE- AND ARE CUT OFF. SO
IT'S STILL THE CASE THAT IF
SOMEONE LET'S SAY HAS A
HORRIBLE- INJURY AND AS A-
QUADRIPLEGIC OR A SERIOUS BRAIN
INJURY AND IS TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS OLD AND IS ANTICIPATED TO
LIVE FOR ANOTHER. FORTY OR
FIFTY YEARS THAT PERSON IS
GONNA GET DRAMATICALLY MORE IN
TERMS OF PAIN AND SUFFERING NON
ECONOMIC DAMAGES THAN SOMEONE
WHO IS INJURED. AND DIES ONE
YEAR LATER FROM THOSE INJURIES
SO THIS IS NOT THE CASE OVER TO
US THIS OPENING UP THE DOORS
AND YOU CAN AWARD WHATEVER YOU
WANTS. ON IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
A LITTLE BIT OF SUBJECTIVITY IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE JURY AWARDS-
BY IN MY EXPERIENCE JURIES ARE.
I AM AS A TRIAL ATTORNEY TRIED
A NUMBER OF CASES AND ON
SEVERAL CONTACTS OR CASES.
JURIES WERE PRETTY- LISTEN TO
THE EVIDENCE CLOSELY AND I
THINK GENERALLY DID A REALLY
GOOD JOB AND ASSESS DAMAGE AS
WELL SO THIS IS A LONG OVERDUE-
CHANGE SOME OF MY FORMER
COLLEAGUES ARE PROBABLY GONE-
I'M TRYING TO GET SOME PHONE
CALLS ABOUT THIS ABOUT YOU KNOW
AS A AS- A AS A FORMER. DEFENSE
ATTORNEY BUT I GOT TO SEE I
THINK ALL SIDES OF THIS AND
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT CHANGE AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SIR WIENER- IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER WIENER ANY OTHER
COMMENTS NO NO OTHER COMMENTS
ALL RIGHT. EARLIER THE CUTICLES
I THINK THAT THE BOTH THE
MISSUS WHITE CARD AND SENATOR
WIENER DID A GREAT JOB OF. OF
MAKING MY CLOTHES AND I JUST
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY AND
ALL SIDES. I THINK THIS IS IT
IS POWERFUL AND I THINK THE ONE
THING THAT THE COMMITTEE DID IS
WHILE I DO NOT THINK THE
OPPOSITION ARE. ARGUMENTS HAVE.
AS MUCH MERIT AS THOSE THAT
SENATOR WINNER JUST SAID. THIS
IT GIVES US FOR YEARS AS WE ARE
LOWER. THE COVERT BACKLOG TO
GROW ON TRUTH EXACTLY. A THOSE
CAN. AND I THEY BE VIEW. TO BE
WITHOUT MERIT BUT THAT. THAT A
SUNSET GIVES A SET OPPORTUNITY-
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU BRING USER
LAYERED. BENJI COUNCIL START
WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
THIS IS SENATE BILL FOUR FOUR
SEVEN BY SENATOR LAYERED WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER.
THE MOTION IS D. PASSED AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
THEN RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS NUMBER.
NUMBER AYE PORGES. SORRY AT ALL
HI DEBBIE AT ALL I DID ALSO DID
I SO I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG AYE. HERTZBERG AYE
JONES. NO JONES NO LAYERED.
AIRED HI STERN. STRONG STERN
HEIGHT WEIGHT CAL SKI WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WIENER WIENER AYE
FOUR SIX. YOU HAVE NINE TO ONE
SO FAR THANK YOU WELL WE'LL PUT
THE BILL ON CALL BUT JUST TO
REVIEW THE- LINE UP HERE NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO S. B.
THREE TWO THREE BY SARAH
CABALLERO AND S. B. THREE THREE
FOUR BY SENATOR ALSO THEN S. B.
338% AGAIN SALAS THAT SB FIVE
SEVENTY. TWO BY CENTER
HERTZBERG THAN S. B. TWO FOUR
ONE BY YOURS TRULY ALL RIGHT.
THE COVER GIRL THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT S. B. THREE TWO THREE
WHICH WOULD CREATE AB ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAY STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS FOR CLAIMS
AGAINST WATER AND SEWER AGENCY
RATE SETTINGS WATER AND SEWER
UTILITY BUDGETS ARE FUNDED BY
REVENUE COLLECTED THROUGH
SERVICE RATES THESE RATES
PROVIDE THE FUNDING NECESSARY
TO SUPPLY SAFE DRINKING WATER
UPGRADE AND IMPROVE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TO OPERATE
EFFECTIVELY. EXISTING LAW
ALLOWS LAWSUITS THAT SEEK
REFUNDS OR SEEK TO INVALIDATE
EXISTING RATE STRUCTURES YEARS
AFTER RATES HAVE BEEN ADOPTED
AND COLLECTED DELAYED LAWSUITS
CAN THREATEN AND AGENCIES
ABILITY TO REPAY DEBT
GUARANTEED BY REVENUE FROM
RATES DERAIL ONGOING
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND
GENERALLY UNDERMINE IN AGENCIES
ABILITY TO MAINTAIN STABLE
BUDGETS NECESSARY TO OPERATE
EFFECTIVELY. THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF LEGAL
CHALLENGES FILED AGAINST WATER
AND SEWER AGENCIES RATE
STRUCTURES OUT FOR INSTANCE IN
FEBRUARY A CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT
WAS FILED AGAINST EIGHTY ONE
WATER SUPPLIERS IN CALIFORNIA
CHEN CHALLENGING THEIR ABILITY
TO CHARGE RATEPAYERS FOR THE
COST OF PROVIDING CRITICAL
LIFESAVING WATER SUPPLIERS
SUPPLIES FOR FIRE HYDRANTS. FOR
SOME OF THE AGENCY SUED THE
CHALLENGE RATES WERE ADOPTED
FIVE YEARS PRIOR TO THE LAWSUIT
AND NOW WITH THE ADDITIONAL
STRAIN OF THE EXACT GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER PROHIBITING
WATER SHUT OFFS REGARDLESS OF A
CUSTOMER'S ABILITY TO PAY WATER
AND SEWER AGENCIES ARE UNDER
CONSTANT FINANCIAL STRAIN. AND
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
ARE AT RISK. SB THREE TWENTY
THREE AT CONSISTENCY EXISTING
LAW BY AUTHORIZING A LOCAL
AGENCY OR INTERESTED PERSON TO
BRING A VALIDATION ACTION IN
SUPERIOR COURT. TO DETERMINE
THE VALIDITY OF A FEE OR CHARGE
FOR WATER AND SEWER SERVICE. IF
A VALIDATION ACTION IS NOT
BROUGHT WITHIN A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS PARTIES WOULD BE
BARRED FROM CHALLENGING THE
VALIDITY OF THE FEET OR THE
CHARGE UNTIL THE NEXT TIME THAT
IT'S RAISED. THIS BILL IS
ADDITIONALLY IN LINE WITH
EXISTING PRECEDENT MODELED
AFTER THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TO
TWENTY DAY STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS ENACTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOR MUNICIPAL ELECTRIC
RATES FOR CHARGES. BY ALLOWING
CUSTOMERS TO BRING CHALLENGES
WITHIN A REASONABLE BUT LIMITED
PERIOD OF TIME THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD BALANCE THE INTERESTS OF
THE REPAIRS WITH THOSE OF THE
PUBLIC WATER AND SEWER AGENCY
AND THE CURRENT PRIVATE.
PRACTICE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
CHRIS ANDERSON OF AQUA THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES. AND PAUL COOK GENERAL
MANAGER OF IRVINE RANCH WATER
DISTRICT. ALL RIGHTY IS
CHRISSIE ANDERSON AVAILABLE
TESTIFIED. YES MISTER CHAIR OUR
STANDARDS IN CLOSURES OKAY.
GREAT WELL GOOD EVENING MISS
RETURN NUMBERS AGAIN CHRIS
ANDERSON ON BEHALF MISTER
STATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES FOR THEPROUD SPONSOR
OF SB THREE TWO THREE. JUST
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE I
THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THE ANALYSIS AND SENATOR
CABALLERO FOR EFFORTS ON THE
STILL. SB THREE TWO THREE IS
NOT A NEW OR REVOLUTIONARY IDEA
AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED THIS
BILL ALIGNS WITH LONGSTANDING
PRECEDENT IN EXISTING LAW THE
HUNDRED TWENTY DAY FACTUAL-LIMITATIONS RT IT'S PROVIDED
FOR MUNICIPAL ELECTRIC RATES.
CAN ACTUALLY BE TO PASS A DRUG
TEST BY WATER AND SEWER
AGENCIES AND OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FEES AND CHARGES.
THE LEGISLATURE CREATED THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS BECAUSE
IT RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
MINIMIZE FISCAL UNCERTAINTY FOR
PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT SERVICES.
IN SB THREE TWO THREE IF HE CAN
TO PROVIDE SIMILAR PROTECTIONS
FOR WATER AND SEWER SERVICE.
PUBLIC WATER AND SEWER AGENCIES
ARE LARGELY FUNDED BY RATE
REVENUE WITH THESE RATES BY
THAT. GROUP EIGHTEEN
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD DELIVERY
SYSTEM MAINTAIN RELIABLE
OPERATIONS AND MORE. LEGAL
CHALLENGES TO RAGE STRUCTURES
CAN HAVE A FINANCIALLY STABLE
ENOUGH FOR PUBLICATION SEAT. AT
THE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES POINTS
OUT TO EIGHTEEN IT'S BEEN
FERTILE GROUND FOR A MEDICATION
AND- THE RECENT CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT AGAINST EIGHTY ON WATER
SUPPLIERS IN CALIFORNIA
STIMULATING GRANDMA. DOWN TO
PROP TO EIGHTEEN ARE BEING
TESTED. IN THAT CASE YOU NEED
TO DEFEND AND AGENCIES I DON'T
MENTION THE TOP THEIR- THAT
DOCTOR THEIR RATE YEARS BEFORE
THE LAWSUIT WAS FILED. SB THREE
TWO THREE ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE
BY ALLOWING REPAIRS TO BRING
LAWSUITS WITHIN A REASONABLE
BUT- TIME. BY DOING SO THE BILL
STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF RATE
PAYERS AND NINE REPUBLIC WATER
AND SEWER AGENCIES LOCAL EIGHT
I NECESSARY FINANCIAL
UNCERTAINTY. FOR THESE REASONS
WE QUESTOR AIBO AND HAPPY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER HARRISON MISTER COOK.
ARE YOU ON THE LINE GOO
EVENING. THANK YOU EVENING HERE
BERGEN THINK YOU FOR THE ON. TO
DISCUSS OUR SPEECH TWO THREE
WITH TODAY- COOK MADERA MANAGER
FOR RANGE FOR DISTRICT WE ARE
PUBLIC RETAIL WATER IN SEWER.
SERVING THE CENTRAL OF OUR
COUNTY. TWO SIX CAN. OF S. B.
TWO THREE LIKE TO DESCRIBE OUR
FOR. PUBLIC AND TRANSPARENT
PROCESS OF RATES ARE THAT WE-
HERE AT HIGHER D. THE PROPERTY
WHICH REQUIRED OUTLINED IN THE-
NOW. OR BUT THEY'RE REALLY-
ONLY PART. OUR PUBLIC PROCESS.
MICHAEL WATER AND- OUR AGENCIES
ARE TO BE BEGIN RIGHT SO PRESS
WHAT THEY CALL OF SIR STUDY
THIS DETAILED STUDY EXPLAINS
METHODOLOGY FOR HOW RATES ARE
SET AND HOW COSTS ARE ALLOCATED
AMONG CUSTOMERS. OTHER PARTS TO
RETAIN STE BECAUSE OF SERVICE.
RIGHT SAID IS TIED DIRECTLY TO
ANY. BUDGET AND THAT IS WHERE
WE PUT THAT WILL BE PROVIDE THE
BASIS FOR THE PROPOSED RATES.
ARE WDAS RATE POLICY DECISIONS
EXPENSES PROPOSED RATE IMPACTS
AT MULTIPLE PUBLIC MEETINGS AT
LEAST NINE FOR OUR CURRENT RATE
SETTING PROCESS. PRIOR TO THE
RATES BEING CONSIDERED FOR
PROPERTY OWNER IN CUSTOMER.
THEY PROP TO EIGHTEEN NOTICE AT
LEAST FORTY FIVE DAYS PRIOR. TO
A PUBLIC HEARING ON THE
PROPOSED RATES. IS WRITTEN
NOTICE PROVIDED DETAILS ON THE
PROPOSED RATES ALONG WITH THE
REASONS FOR ADJUSTING RATES.
THAN THOSE ALSO INCLUDES
INFORMATION ON HOW RATEPAYER
CAN COMMENT OR PROTEST THE RATE.
THAT ARE TO BE THE REVERSE PER.
TO EACH OF THE PROTEST LETTERS
OR COMMENTS THAT WE RECEIVED.
ONLY A TO THIS VERY PUBLIC AN
EXTENSIVE PROCESS OUR RATES
CONSIDERED FOR ADOPTION BY
REPORT. BECAUSE THIS IS A VERY
TRANSPARENT PROCESS WE BELIEVE
THAT A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS
JUDGE LIMITATIONS NEARLY ONE
THIRD OF A YEAR. STRIKES THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN.
REQUIRING PROMPT RATE
CHALLENGES AND STILL ALLOWING A
SUFFICIENT TIME FOR RATEPAYERS
CHALLENGER RAGE INCLUDING
ELECTED THANKS CENTER TO COVER
YOUR AUTHORING. SB THREE TO
THREE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THIS EVENING
COULD ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. RAMOS CORP ALL RIGHT
I SEE NO WITNESSES A GALLERY NO
WITNESSES ROOM ONE TWELVE.
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE LINE. ON
THE PHONE LINE IF YOU'D PLEASE
QUEUE UP TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. THREE TWO THREE MISTER
MODERATOR ISRAEL ONLINE
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO THREE TWO EXCUSE ME. SB
THREE TWO THREE. YEAH THERE'S
LIKE WE HAVE SOME LINES AT THE
WILL START LINE FOR EIGHTY.
PLEASE AHEAD. THAT MATURE
NUMBER PRODUCT LOWER RIVER
VALLEY. UNLIKE ANYTHING I
WANTED CHECK IN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TONIGHT. SIX ONE FIVE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING JAMIE MINOR ON
BEHALF OF EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT AND SANTA
MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK THE MUCH. THANK
YOU. LET'S GO TO ONE SIX
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT OF A SPEECH THREE
TWO THREE THREE. THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY THE LINE SIX OH ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BELIEVED TO
SHOP ON THE HALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WINDS FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CARE ROUGHLY HALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE LINE
FIVE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRD ID
BRITAIN WITH THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTYWATER AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND ACTUALLY GO TO LINE SIX OH
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ERIC O'DONNELL ON
BEHALF OF YOUR BILL LINDA WATER
DISTRICT IN A SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED POSITION FOR THE
REASONS OUTLINED IN OUR
COALITION LETTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE CAN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALREADY LET'S SEND OPPOSITION I
SEE NO ONE OF THE GALLERY I SEE
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- ON
THE PHONE LINES TO HAVE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION. S. B. THREE TWO
THREE. WE HAVE ONE THREE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU-
THIS IS SCOTT KAUFMAN HOW ARE
DRIVERS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE OPPOSED TO IF YOU WOULD
PERMIT ME I HAVE A BRIEF
STATEMENT. ALREADY WILL TAKE
YOU AS PRIMARY OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
BILL'S SPONSORS FOR ACCEPTING
ONE OF OUR AMENDMENTS BUT OTHER
CONCERNS REMAIN. THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT IN THE CITY OF
ONTARIO BE SUPERIOR COURT SAID
THAT SOME APPLICATION TO THE
VALIDATION STATUTE WERE OF
DOUBTFUL CONSTITUTIONALITY
BECAUSE- AN AGENCY MAY
INDIRECTLY BUT EFFECTIVELY
VALIDATE IT ACTION BY DOING
NOTHING TO VALIDATE IT. THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE CASES OF DOUBTFUL
CONSTITUTIONALITY. THE
VALIDATION OF THAT YOU INTENDED
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT IS THE DEBTORS SUCH
AS WHEN THE GOVERNMENT BORROWS
MONEY OR AGREED TO PAY FOR
GOODS OR SERVICES. SB THREE TWO
THREE- ONCE THE VALIDATION
STATUE TO PROTECT THE
GOVERNMENT WHEN THE PUBLIC IS
THE DATA BETTER. SB THREE TWO
THREE TRYING TO VALIDATION THAT
YOU'RE GONNA TED. BECAUSE WATER
AND SANITATION VITAL TO HEALTH
AND THEREFORE SHOULD BE ON OF
SHOULD BE SHOULD NOT BE ON
AFFORDABLE BECAUSE WATER AND
SEWER FEES CAN BE LEANED AND
THREATEN HOMEOWNERSHIP. THE
RULES FOR VALID WATER AND SEWER
CHARGES ARE PART OF THE STATE
CONSTITUTION. THE VALIDATION
STUDY WAS NEVER MEANT FOR CLOSE
CONSTITUTIONAL CASES FROM
COURT. TO PREVENT UNFAIRNESS IN
AGENCIES AT LEAST BE REQUIRED
TO BRING ITS OWN VALIDATION
ACTION WITH ON WHICH WITHIN A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS. TO OBTAIN
THE PROTECTION OF THE STATUTE
THE AGENCIES WILL TELL YOU THIS
IS COST PROHIBITIVE BUT IT'S
FAR MORE COST PROHIBITIVE FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER TO BRING
SUCH AN ACTION AND EVEN MORE SO
FOR RATE PAYERS TO PAY A
POTENTIALLY ILLEGAL FEE
INSULATED FROM CHALLENGED.
DESPITE THE ABSENCE OF NOTICE
TO THE PUBLIC REVIEW BY A COURT
ENTRY OF JUDGMENT OR OTHER DUE
PROCESS. FINALLY THE KASUR CASE
AGAINST ANYONE WATER DISTRICT
IS BEING USED TO JUSTIFY THIS
BILL DOES NOT JUSTIFY. THAT
CAITLYN ANOMALY BEING CHARRED
BEING CHALLENGED ON
JURISDICTIONAL GROUNDS
GENERALLY LITIGATING WATER
RATES INCREDIBLY CONSUMING AND
ISN'T DONE WITHOUT GOOD
MOTIVATION AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORT I. ASK YOU TO OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE ON THE NOT TO. WELL. WE
HAVE A LINE THREE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD RIGHT. HELLO MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE SILVA AND I
AM CLOSER TO THEM. THANK YOU.
IT WOULD HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHTUP
ON THE FLOOR I SEE NO
MICROPHONES UP. THEIR MOTION.
CENTER HERTZBERG MOVES THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. OTHER
DISCUSSION DISCUSSIONS-
CABALLERO YOUR CLOTHES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS I THANK
YOU MEANT TO CANCEL START OF
YOU CALL THE ROLL SENATE BILL
THREE TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR
COVER YOU AT ALL AND THE MOTION
IS BY SENATOR HERTZBERG MOTION
IS TO PASS. A BURKE HI AMBERG I
FORTUS CABALLERO HI AMIRA I DID
ALSO. THIS I. DID SO I.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
HIGH HERTZBERG AYE JONES HI
JONES I LAYERED. LAYERED ICE
STERN STERN AYE STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI I Y. CASKEY AYE
WIENER. WIENER AYE YOU HAVE TEN
SO FAR IN YOUR MISSING ONE ALL
RIGHT WITH THE BILL ON CALL
NEXT WE HAVE A SENATOR ALSO SB
THREE THREE FOUR CENTER THERE
ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
FROM YOUR DESK. WE WANT. OUR.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB THREE
THREE FOUR- THE DETENTION
FACILITY ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT PRISONS AND
DETENTION FACILITIES TWO ONE
ADHERE TO ALL APPROPRIATE STATE
LOCAL HEALTH SAFETY FIRE IN
JAIL STANDARDS MEET AND
MAINTAIN SPECIFIC INSURANCE
COVERAGES SUBMIT QUARTERLY
COMPLIANCE REPORTS. OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS TO THE INSURANCE
PROVIDER COMPANY AND THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
AND INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING
COMPLIANCE- AND TERMINATE
UNSURE IS COVERAGE OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT MET. AS WE
ARE ALL ACCUSTOMED TO SEVERAL
PROFIT DETENTION FACILITIES
HAVE A HISTORY OF POOR
CONDITIONS IN THOSE FACILITIES
IN RESPONSE CALIFORNIA HAS
TAKEN A DEFINITIVE STANCE TO
IMPROVE THOSE CONDITIONS- IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE PROHIBITED
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM CONTRACTING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- TO
DETAIN NON CITIZENS- IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AB THIRTY TWO.
PROHIBITS THE OPERATION OF A
FOR PROFIT PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITY OR PRISON AFTER
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
UNFORTUNATELY. THE PREVIOUS
FEDERAL MINISTRATION AND BE
COMPANIES RUSHED IN TO ENTER
INTO A SERIES OF CONTRACTS IN
APPARENT ATTEMPT TO CIRCUMVENT
SB THIRTY TWO. MEANWHILE MEN
AND WOMEN ARE STILL DETAINED
AND IMPORTANT CONDITIONS THERE
NUMEROUS REPORTS DETAILING
CONDITIONS AND ABUSIVE
TREATMENT OF PEOPLE AND THEY IN
THESE FACILITIES INCLUDING A
TWENTY SEVENTEEN US DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY REPORT.
FINDING THAT THE OTHER LAND THE
DETENTION FACILITY FAILED TO
MEET MANY OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
OWN STANDARDS AND OPERATORS DID
NOT ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS
DESPITE REPEATED WARNINGS.
REPORTS ON THE CONDITION OF
DETENTION FACILITIES DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC DEPICT A
LACK OF RELIABLE ACCESS TO EVEN
SOAP SANITIZER OR OTHER UP BP
AND NOT ALLOCATED SPACE FOR
SOCIAL DISTANCING. THAT
INCLUDES SEVENTY ACCOUNT OF
SEVEN DETAINEES SHARING FIVE
BARDS BARS OF SOAP. THE SAFETY
AND WELFARE OF THOSE DETAINED
IN FOR PROFIT CRIMINAL AND
CIVIL DETENTION FACILITIES IS
THREATENED NOW EVEN MORE AND
HAS BEEN DURING THE PANDEMIC.
CENTER IS THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL APPLY EQUALLY TO FOR
PROFIT FACILITIES ENGAGED IN
CIVIL DETENTION AND CRIMINAL
DETENTION WITH MAY I HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM- FROM
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LOT US
OFFICE KINDRED ZAHLER. DEPUTY
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR AND CONNIE
CHOI POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRATION POLICY
CENTER. AND MS LAWLER CAN ALSO
HELP WITH ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BURKE THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO MISSILE OR ARE YOU
ON THE PHONE. YES PLEASE
PROCEED. THIRTY NINE HUNDRED
DOLLAR HERE ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND THE DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE. GENERAL ARE VERY
PROUD TO BE THE COULD SPONSOR
OF SB THREE THREE FOUR WITH THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER AND YOU
WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR OUT
OVER HER TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP
IN OFFERING MEASURES. TO FIGHT
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO
RESTRICT THE USE OF PRIVATE
PRISONS AND DETENTION CENTERS
SEVERAL FACILITIES CONTINUE TO
OPERATE IN THE STATE TODAY AND
THEY CONSISTENTLY FAIL TO MEET
MINIMUM LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS.
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO
CONSEQUENCES TODAY IF THEY DO
NOT. MEET THE BASIC STANDARDS.
HELLO CRIERS FRIDAY IT'S A TO
THE TO THE SAME HIGH AND SEE
STANDARDS CURRENTLY FOLLOWED BY
CALIFORNIA STATE AND LOCAL.
PUBLICLY MANAGED FACILITIES
THERE BY REDUCING RISK ON
ABILITY TO POTENTIAL LOSSES FOR
INSURANCE COMPANIES. EIGHT
THREE THREE FOUR SHOULD PROVIDE
A POWERFUL MOTIVATION FOR
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT PRISONS AND
DETENTION FACILITY SHOWED HERE
TO LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
STANDARDS WHILE ALSO ENSURING
THAT THE FACILITIES MAINTAIN
COMPREHENSIVE INSURANCE
COVERAGE. BUILDING ON THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLTURE'S
REPEATED EFFORTS TO REGULATE
AND RESTRICT THE USE OF PRIVATE
PRISONS AND DETENTION
FACILITIES IN THE STATE.
ANOTHER IMPORTANTLY INSURE THAT
BASIC HEALTH SAFETY AND HUMAN
RIGHTS ARE AFFORDED TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION. FIFTEEN
IN OUR STATE. ACTUALLY REQUEST
YOUR EITHER ON THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU SOLAR OF THE SKY CHOI.
THE AVAILABLE. YES MA'AM THANK
YOU FOR YEARS. GREAT EVENING
MEDICARE NUMBERS AND MY NAME IS
CONNIE CHOI POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND WE'RE PROUD COULD
PROGRESS. EIGHT THREE FOUR. SB
THREE ARE ENSURE THE HEALTH HE
RIGHT OF THE LOCAL INTEGRATE
FULL AFFECT AMERICANS HAVE.
UPGRADE. HE FOUR MEN AND THEN
HOW HE CAN ARE CONTINUALLY EVEN
VIOLATE. AT THE END OF TO HOLD
BASIC THAT BY TALKING CORRECT.
LIKE THAT YEAR AND CORPORATION
OF AMERICA HAVE BEEN WELL DONE.
OVER THE. FOR THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT EXTRACTS OFFICE AT
THE GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY.
THAT KIND OF PRISONS WHERE
POORLY. CHARLOTTE HAITHAM
FEDERAL. SHRINE NUMEROUS OTHER
OF ALSO THE- ENTRY AND. THAT-
APPLE ABOUT INTO COURT LIVING.
FIVE EIGHT HAVE ONLY EXACT OF
THE PAST YEAR BY THE CALL AND
THEN A WITHIN OF DEATHS IN IN
DETENTION CENTER. AMONG THE
REPORTED OUT WITH THAT BOTH
THAT THE COUNTRY CENTER SAN
DIEGO WHERE AT LEAST A HUNDRED
IN A P. IN CUT. AND TWENTY FIVE
BACKGROUND THE POSITIVE LAST
EIGHT. AND WHERE THEY NEED. FOR
COMBINATION IN THE. ME AND FOR
THE NUMBER CRUNCHING TO RISE
ACCORDING TO I VERY OWN NINETY
TRACK I AN FOUR EARLIER WEEK IT
AND EIGHTY PEOPLE HAVE THE
POWER FOR NINETY AND-
BACKGROUND. THE TENSION FROM
HER DAD IT IS CRITICAL FOR THE
PER BECAUSE- ACTUALLY HOW THE-
INCOME WITH YOUR CREDIT RELATED.
WELL WELL IN. NINETEEN WILL
OUTWEIGH THE HEARING THAT I'VE
EVER MENTIONED CENTER EIGHT.
SO- I THINK I'M PRETTY BECAUSE
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR- THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THREE FOUR THERE ARE NONE
OF THE GALLERY THERE ARE NONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WILL TURN TO
THE PHONES MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE WHO
ARE. INTERESTED TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE THREE FOUR.
WE WOULD BE MOST GRATEFUL. WELL
ONE SIX OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS WEARING
SHERMAN WITH SOME RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THREE THREE
THREE FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
ERIC HERS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IN
MARYLAND NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE
AT THE TIME ORANGE LET'S TURNED
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO ONE LISTED
IN PRINCIPLE OPPOSITION I SEE
NO ONE OF THE GARY NOLAN ROOM
ONE TWELVE LET'S TURN THE PHONE
LINES MISTER MODERATE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION TO. S. B. THREE
THREE FOUR. HEY WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME ALREADY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I SEE NO
MICROPHONES REYES- SIR MOTION
SIR LAYERED MOVES THE BILL.
CENTER THE RUSSELL. DID YOU GET
A CLOSE. SPECTRAL ESCRIBO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
MENTERI COUNCIL STRADA YEAH
THIS IS THE SENATE BILL THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR THE RUSSELL AND THE
MOTION IS BY SENATOR THERE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG. AMBER
GUY BURGESS. THE VEHICLE HI
CARRIE AT ALL I DID I SAW. THAT
I SO I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG I'D JONES
NO JONES NO LAYERED HI LAYERED
I STERN- WHAT CAL SKI HI MY CAL
SKI I WIENER. WIENER ICE SO FOR
YOU HAVE. EIGHT TO ONE ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT THE LONG
CALL ALL RIGHT NEXT. WE HAVE
SOME OF THE CONSOLIDATES
AMERICAN SALAS. SB THREE THREE
EIGHT. THE COURTESY. SHARES I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS MENTION ON
PAGE ELEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS-
BUT I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB THREE THREE EIGHT AND I
THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH US AS WELL IT'S AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO PROTECT
THE CENTRAL FRONT LINE TRUCK
DRIVERS THAT ARE CALIFORNIA
PORTS WERE STILL WORKING HARD
EACH DAY DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN BEYOND
THESE TRUCK DRIVERS HAVE BEEN A
TORY ASLI EXPLOITED BY BAD
ACTORS IN THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY
WHO ROUTINELY CLASS OF
MISCLASSIFIED THEM TO CUT COSTS
WRONGFULLY EXCLUDE WORKERS FOR
MINIMUM WAGE. WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND THE RIGHT TO
JOIN A UNION DURING THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC MISCLASSIFIED
WORKERS HAVE ALSO BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SICK DAYS AND BASIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROTECT PROTECTIONS LIKE
PP EVEN THOUGH MISS
CLASSIFICATION IS ILLEGAL IT'S
OFTEN CHEAPER FOR TRUCKER CME
TRUCKING COMPANIES TO SETTLE
WAGE CLAIMS FOR PENNIES ON THE
DOLLAR THEN TO PROVIDE THEIR
WORKERS WITH THE PROTECTIONS
AND PAY THEY DESERVE. SB THREE
THREE EIGHT ADDRESSES THE
ONGOING PROBLEM BY BUILDING OFF
THE EXISTING LAW FORTINO TWO TO
BE EXACT WHERE AND TRUCKING
COMPANIES THAT WALK AWAY FROM
UNPAID WAGE CLAIMS GET ADDED TO
A JOINT LIABILITY BAD ACTOR
LIST SB THREE THREE EIGHT ADS
COMPANIES TO THIS BAD ACTOR
LISTED THE OF UNABATED SERIOUS
CAL OSHA VIOLATIONS THE BILL
ALSO SPECIFICALLY TARGETS PRIOR
OFFENDERS HAVE MISCLASSIFIED
THEIR WORKERS. FINALLY SB THREE
THREE EIGHT REQUIRES COMPANIES
TO CONDUCT AN AUDIT TO SHOW
THAT THEY A FIX THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEM IN ORDER TO GET OFF OF
THIS BAD ACTOR LIST I WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION TO MAKE
THE BILL STRONGER AND WITH THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TODAY WE
WILL STRENGTHEN THE FOCUS OF
THE BILL TO TARGET ONLY THE
WORST OF THE WORST BAD ACTORS
THOSE WHO ROUTINELY DENY THEIR
WORKERS OR HAVE UNABATED
SERIOUS CAL OSHA VIOLATIONS
WEAK WHICH CAN CAUSE SERIOUS
HARM OR DEATH. WE CERTAINLY
KNOW THAT OUR TRUCK DRIVERS AT
OUR PORTS ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
WERE CRITICAL TO MAINTAINING
THE SUPPLY CHAIN TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY HAVE SHANE GUSMAN
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL AND
CAITLIN V. GO. FROM THE IN.
BROTHERHOOD OF. PORT DIVISION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MR CHART THE PROBATE USER
GONZALEZ. SERVICEMEN ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. YES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SHANE GUSMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT AND PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL. FOR US THE
POINT OF THIS BILL IS TO
ADDRESS THE LONG HISTORY OF
DRIVER MISS CLASSIFICATION.
THAT HAS OCCURRED IN THE
TRUCKING INDUSTRY EVER SINCE IT
WAS DE REGULATED FOR DECADES
AGO. NO WHERE IS THE EVIDENCE
OF THIS PROBLEM GREATER THAN
OUR IN OUR LARGEST PORTS. THEIR
EXPLOITATION IS THE DOMINANT
ECONOMIC MODEL. TRUCKING
COMPANIES HIRE WORK FORCE OF
MOSTLY IMMIGRANT DRIVERS WHO
ARE FORCED TO ACT AS IF THEY
ARE IN BUSINESS FOR THEMSELVES
RESPONSIBLE FOR PURCHASING OR
LEASING THEIR OWN TRUCKS.
PAYING FOR ALL OF THE FUEL AND
MAINTENANCE. ALL RIGHT EXCEPT
IN AN EXTREMELY LOW NON
NEGOTIABLE RATE. IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON TO HAVE MONTHS WHERE
THE COST OF MAINTAINING THE
TRUCK IS ACTUALLY MORE THAN THE
DRIVER MAKES. ON TOP OF THIS
THESE DRIVERS GET NO HEALTH
CARE NO MINIMUM WAGE NO
OVERTIME NO WORKERS COMP NO
PAID SICK SICK DAYS. AND
ABSOLUTELY NO PROTECTIONS
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THESE ARE
THE FACTS ON THE GROUND.
HUNDREDS OF COMPLAINTS. LABOR
COMMISSIONER INVESTIGATIONS AND
LAWSUITS HAVE UNIVERSALLY
CONCLUDED WITH FINDINGS THAT
THE PORT DRAYAGE DRIVERS ARE IN
FACT MISCLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
COUNTLESS NEWS ARTICLES HAVE
CHRONICLED THIS PROBLEM FOR
MANY YEARS NONETHELESS THE
PROBLEM PERSISTS. THE TEAMSTERS
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND OTHERS
HAVE TRIED TO HELP THESE
DRIVERS. FOUR YEARS
UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY THEY ARE
MISCLASSIFIED AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS HAS MADE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO ACT
COLLECTIVELY. FOUR YEARS AGO WE
REALIZE THAT THE REAL WAY TO
TACKLE THIS PROBLEM IS TO GET
AT THE ROOT OF IT. THE GIANT
COMPANIES THAT BENEFIT FROM THE
SYSTEM NEED TO TAKE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY WE SPONSORED SB
FORTINO TO LARA. WHICH PROVIDE.
FOR JOINT LIABILITY OF THE
COMPANY HIRED ONE OF THESE BAD
ACTOR TRUCKING FIRMS TO SHIP
GOODS. HOWEVER TOO MANY
LOOPHOLES HAVE LEFT THE HALL
THE BILL INEFFECTIVE. IN
ACHIEVING SYSTEM THAT SYSTEMIC
CHANGE. WE NEED TO SB THREE
THREE EIGHT TO FILL THESE
LOOPHOLES AND MAKE SURE THE
EXPLICATION ENDS ONCE AND FOR
ALL THANK YOU THANK YOU. LAS
VEGAS. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CAITLIN VEGA ON BEHALF OF
SUPPORT DIVISION THAT THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
TEAMSTERS COSPONSORED SB THREE
THREE EIGHT SB THREE THREE
EIGHT PROPOSES THREE IMPORTANT
CHANGES TO MAKE A LOT MORE
EFFECTIVE IN RAISING LABOR
STANDARDS AT THE PORT. HEALTH
AND SAFETY VIOLATIONS IT
CREATES A CATEGORY FOR PRIOR
OFFENDERS TO CONTINUALLY
MISCLASSIFIED AND ADDS AN AUDIT
REQUIREMENTS WHICH ENSURE THAT
ILLEGAL CONDUCT HAS STOPPED FOR
A COMPANY IS REMOVED FROM THE
LIST WE HAVE MET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
SEVERAL TIMES ON THIS BILL AND
TODAY WE ARE ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS ON MANY OF THE
ISSUES THEY BRING. ON HEALTH
AND SAFETY THEY ARGUED THAT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROVISION
CAPTURED TOO MANY TYPES OF
VIOLATIONS INCLUDING MINOR ONE
AND THAT EMPLOYERS SHOULD HAVE
DUE PROCESS AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CURE THE VIOLATIONS WE ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY NARROWING THE
DEFINITION OF HEALTH AND SAFETY
VIOLATIONS ONLY APPLY TO A
FINAL DETERMINATION FROM
TELEVISION WITH A VIOLATION BUT
NOT ABATED AND WHERE THE TIME
PERIOD FOR KILL HAS PASSED THE-
EXISTING LAW ON FINAL UNPAID
JUDGMENTS. ONLY INCLUDE THE
MOST SERIOUS VIOLATIONS OF THE
WAGE AND SAFETY LAWS THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN REMEDY ON PRIOR
OFFENDER THE OPPOSITION ARGUED
THAT COMPANIES COULD BE DEEMED
PRIOR OFFENDERS FOR MINOR
TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS WERE
NARROWING THE DEFINITION OF
PRIOR OFFENDER TOOK ONLY APPLY
TO COMPANIES WITH THE FINAL
JUDGMENT FOR VIOLATIONS RELATED
TO THIS CLASSIFICATION. THIS
MEANS THAT ONLY COMPANIES THAT
ENGAGE IN THIS CLASSIFICATION
AND THEN CONTINUE TO CONNECT
LABOR LAW VIOLATIONS WE'LL GET
DEEMED AS PRIOR OFFENDERS WE
ARE CONTINUING TO MEET WITH THE
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT THE
PROCESS FOR COMING OFF THE LIST
IT'S A FAIR AND TIMELY OUR GOAL
IS TO ENSURE THAT A COMPANY IS
NO LONGER VIOLATING THE LAW AND
WE ARE OPEN TO THE BEST WAY TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT. AT THE END OF
THE DAY WORKERS LIVES ARE IN
JEOPARDY WORKERS ARE DRIVERS
ARE BEING REQUIRED TO PURCHASE
PP. BECAUSE DR THE COMPANIES
WILL NOT PROVIDED. AND THEY ARE
GOING ENTIRE AND PROTECT AND
PROTECTED EVEN IN THE MIDST OF
AN AND PANDEMIC. A WE WANNA
THINK CAN FOR A THREE DISTANCE.
MEASURE AND WE FOR YOUR- THANK
YOU. FOR VEGAS ARE. OTHERS IN
SUB I SEE AGAIN TO SEE NO ONE
IN TO. OF THIS MODERATE WHO
QUEUE UP THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE THREE
EIGHT. AND WE HAVE LINE SIX OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MURS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT.
THANK YOU. AND ACTUALLY HAVE
LINE FOR SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHEN
MEMBERS THAT THE GRANT WHILE
THE TNC W. WESTERN CAPE COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ONE SIX NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NUMBER OF YOUR COOLEY
TSHOMBE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND BURKE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
OTHER LINE SIX OH SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS COULD
NOT SEE HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE. THE BILL.
OKAY. LET'S GO TO LINE SIX
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JEREMY ARNOLD FOR CLERGY AND-LAITY UNITED FOR ECONOMIC
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WHAT A LINE SIX ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MIKE WITH
MICHAEL CARRICK PRESIDENT OF
MARKET DEMOCRATIC LEVEL OFFENSE
LIVED IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MICHAEL WILLIAMS ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR
NEW ECONOMY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THREE THREE EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. IN LINE SIX
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS IDEOLOGICAL OF WITH THE
CROP OF AMERICA AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE SIX TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI CAN YOU FOLLOW FROM
GARMENT WORKER CENTER WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHTY-
LET'S NOW TURN TO OPPOSITION. I
BELIEVE MISTER CHRIS SHIMODA IS
IN OPPOSITION MR SHIMON ARE YOU
ON THE PHONE. YES MR ALL RIGHT.
THE SMALLER THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CHRISTIAN OUT
OF THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION PERSONALLY LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR SPONSORS AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL WE DO BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ARE A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING OUT
REMAINING CONCERNS AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD. CHIEF AMONG
REMAINING CONCERNS IS THE
REQUIREMENT FOR DLSU TO PERFORM
AN AUDIT OF THE CONDITION OF
BEING REMOVED FROM THE JOINT
LIABILITY LAST WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THE AUDIT REQUIREMENT IS
REDUNDANT AS COMPANIES ARE
ALREADY REQUIRED IN THE CASE OF
CAL OSHA THE CURRENT FURNISHING
FORM ONE SIXTY ONE AS GROUP OF
ABATEMENT. PROVIDE PROOF OF
PAYMENT A WAGE QUITE CLAIMS AND
JUDGMENTS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR TO DISPENSE OF THOSE
OBLIGATIONS IRAN TODAY
COMPANIES WHO HAVE ABATED
UNDERLYING VIOLATIONS ARE
CLAIMS AND HAVE ALREADY PROVEN
THIS TO THE PROPER AGENCY WILL
STILL BE FUNCTIONALLY OUT OF
BUSINESS WHILE WAITING
CARDIOLOGY AUDIT A PROCESS THAT
COULD TAKE ANOTHER THREE TO SIX
MONTHS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THESE REMAINING
CONCERNS AND WOULD LIKE TO
AGAIN THANK THE AUTHOR.
SPONSORS AND THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR SHIMODA-
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION I SEE NO
ONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. MODERATOR
ISRAEL ON PHONE LINES. AND WE
HAVE NO WINNING QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S COME BACK
TO THE FLOOR ANYBODY ON THE
FLOOR- QUESTIONS NO QUESTIONS
ON THE FLOOR SO ASSEMBLY
GONZALEZ IS THERE MOTIONS AND
LAYERED MOVES THE BILL- SENATE
GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU. YOU ALSO FOR
YOUR FLEXIBILITY AMEND ABILITY
WORKING ON CLEARLY THIS AUDIT
ISSUES SO I KNOW AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD YOU CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT ISSUE THANK YOU
ABSOLUTELY AND THANK YOU MR
TRYING AGAIN THANK YOU TO IT TO
YOURSELF AND ALSO YOUR- CHIEF
CONSULTANTS I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE WERE
PROVIDED AND WILL CONTINUE
WORKINGWITH THE OPPOSITION
CERTAINLY TAKE THAT NOTED BUT
WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING HERE AT OUR PORTS IN
THIS I THINK WE'LL STRENGTH IN
WHAT WE'RE DOING I ALSO WANT TO
THANK. MY PREDECESSOR-
INSURANCE OMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AS WELL HAVE TO GIVE HIM A
SHOUT OUT FOR ALL OF HIS WORK
IN STARTING THIS AND NOW I'M
BUILDING OFF OF THIS SO BUT
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER NAY
VOTE THANK YOU- MEANT TO CANCEL
START IF YOU CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GONZALES WITH A MOTION
BY SENATOR LEHRER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND THEN RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE HI. I'M BURKE I BOARD YES
NO BARGES NO COVERAGE AT ALL
HI. I DID ALSO THE DRESS SO I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. I HERTZBERG.
IT'S BURGER JONES. JONES NO- A
LAYERED HI LAYERED HI- OKAY I
WAKE SKI HI WHITE HOUSE I
WIENER. WIENER I SO FOR YOU
HAVE. SIX EIGHT TWO TWO SO FAR
ALREADY WILL PUT THAT ON CALL.
MEMBERS WE HAVE TWO MORE BILLS
LEFT NEXT SENATOR HERTZBERG HAS
A BILL WHERE THERE'S NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION AT LEAST NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE AND THEN
FINALLY S. B. TWO FOUR ONE BY
ON BURKE. SO JERRY- HERTZBERG
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED FROM
YOUR DESK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IDEA I'LL MAKE IT BRIEF BECAUSE
THERE'S NO KNOWN OPPOSITION.
BASICALLY THIS IS A FIGURE OUT
FIX IT AND STREAMLINED
GOVERNMENT GETTING RID OF DUMB
PROCEDURES BILL. BASICALLY WHAT
HAPPENS IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR. GOES OUT INTO GETS COURT
ORDER OR GETS AN ORDER OF
CITATION AND THEN THEY'VE GOT
TO GO TO COURT WAIT IN LINE
REDUCE IT TO AN ABSTRACT OF
JUDGMENT. AND IT SHOULD BE
UNNECESSARY PROCEDURE BECAUSE
WHAT HAPPENS IS JUST GETTING A
LEAN ON ON BUILDINGS OF PEOPLE
WHO'VE- HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
THESE VIOLATIONS AND THE DELAY
IT IT TAKES OFTEN. TO GO FROM
THE GETTING THE ABSTRACT TO THE
PROCESS PARTICULARLY RECENTLY
WITH THE CHALLENGE THE PANDEMIC
ARE NOT NECESSARY AND IN FACT
HAVE AN ADVERSE CONSEQUENCE
BECAUSE SOMETIMES. FOLKS WILL
SELL THEIR BUILDINGS AND THE
ASSET FOR WHICH YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET A LEAN DISAPPEARS. SO
THIS IS JUST A SIMPLE WAY TO
HATE THAT WORD STRIKE THAT
COUNCIL AS A WAY TO. CHECK TO
MAKE IT DOES THE PROCESS WORK
IN A MUCH EASIER WAY WE JUST
SIMPLY DO A NOTICE IF THERE'S
THAT WORD AGAIN NOTICE OF
CITATION. AS IT SAYS IN THE
BILL AS OPPOSED TO AN ABSTRACT
OF JUDGMENT I HAVE RENEE-
BAYARDO FROM SEIU HERE WHO'S
GOING TO SPEAK BRIEFLY. AND
CATHERINE LEóN THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE ON THE
LINE PARTICULAR QUESTIONS IF
NECESSARY THANK YOU.
ASTRONOMICAL RESEARCH PROGRAM
TO STAND MISS LEON IS ON THE
PHONE. NOW SO IF WE TURN TO
MISS LEON. I YES MISTER CHAIR.
COPY ME ON TURN WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND I'M-
PREDOMINATELY REQUEST. SO I WAS
GOING TO. BE GRANTED BUT HE
HAD. ALL RIGHTY- AND HOW ABOUT
RENEE BY ARDAL. IS RENEE
BAYARDO AVAILABLE. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD CHECK TO
SEE IF MISS OR MISTER BAYAT
BAYARDO IS ON THE LINE. IF OF
RENE BYRON WAS NOT ONLINE YET.
AND RENEE BAYARDO- CALLS IN
THEN WE'LL COME BACK LET'S LOOK
TO THE GALLERY THERE'S NO IN
THE GALLERY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
SUPPORT. LET'S GO TO PHONE
LINES FOR OTHERS IN SUPPORT
INDIFFERENT A BUYER WHO SHOWS
UP AND WILL HAVE. A RENEE BAIO
DON'T HAVE TWO MINUTES. MISTER
MODERATOR THOSE IN SUPPORT. I
WOULD GO TO LINE FOR SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
TURNED MEMBERS DADDY GRANDMA
HERE TO W. WESTERN STATE
CONCIL IN SUPPORT THANK THANK
YOU. AND THEN WE GO TO LINE SIX
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT OUR RENEE BY ARTICLE.
FEED SEARCH THE PHONE LINE TO
SEE IF. YOU'RE A BUYER WAS ON
THE LINE. IF NOT LET'S TURNED
OPPOSITION I SEE NO OPPOSITION
WELL LET'S GO TO PHONE LINES
FIRST I KNOW NOBODY. OPPOSITION
NO PRIMARY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. OF MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU'D Q. A FOLKS IN OPPOSITION
TO SB FIVE SEVENTY TWO I SEE NO
ONE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO WATER ROOM
ONE TWELVE IN OPPOSITION. ON
THE PHONE LINE. IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
ONE QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT- LET'S BRING IT BACK HERE
TO THE FLOOR I SEE NO
MICROPHONES RISED. CENTER
LAYERED MOVES THE BILL SIR
HERTZBERG WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. HI VOTE PLEASE ALL RIGHT
AND SHE COUNCIL IF YOU'D CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS SB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG NOW WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR LAYERED THE MOTION
IS DO YOU PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS I'M BURKE HI I'M
BURGER AYE PORGES. NUMBER ONE.
FORGES YOU CANCEL OR JUST I'M
ALL ABOARD DECIDED NOT VOTING.
YEAH GHETTO HI HAVE A AT ALL I
DID ALSO GET US SO GONE HI
GONZALEZ I. AYE HERTZBERG AYE.
JONES I LAYER ON LAYERED STERN.
WHITE HOUSE SKI ARE Y. CASKEY
AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE. SO FAR
YOU HAVE NINE TWO ZERO. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THE BILL ON
PAUL. ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA HAND
THE GAVEL OVER TO VICE CHAIR
PORGES- AND ASK COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO REPORT THE CHAMBER
THIS IS THE FINAL BILL. FOR
TODAY. AND I MUST IT MUST SAY
CHAIRMAN YOU'VE DONE A YEOMAN'S
JOB. OF PRESIDING OVER JUTISH
TODAY ALL RIGHT CENTER NUMBER
DO YOU ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS ON
PAGES ELEVEN THROUGH TWELVE
COMMON NUMBER FOUR. I DO ACCEPT
THE MOMENTS ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO PLEASE
PRESENT. ON YOUR BILL TODAY
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR AND
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO COMMITTEE
STAFF IN PARTICULAR ROLES
MEREDITH FOR THEIR HARD WORK IN
HER HARD WORK ON THIS BILL
WE'VE ACCEPTED SOME AMENDMENTS.
TO RESPOND TO CONCERNS ABOUT
THE ACCURACY OF THE RECORD- SO
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS THAT WHEN A
WITNESS TESTIFIES REMOTELY IF
COUNCIL OR THE JUDGE. THEY
BELIEVE THAT IF THEY BELIEVE
THAT THE RECORD IS NOT GOING TO
BE KEPT ACTOR LEAVE THEY
BELIEVE THERE'S SOME SORT OF
TECHNICAL GLITCH THEY CAN STOP.
THE REMOTE PRESENTATION THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY AND REQUIRE
THE WITNESS TO APPEAR LIVE-
THERE ARE TWO ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL BUT BOTH DEAL WITH CORE
DEFICIENCIES WE HAVE A GREAT
DEAL CHALLENGE. CHALLENGE WITH
RESPECT TO ACCESS TO JUSTICE
IT'S BECOMING MORE AND MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR ALL PARTICIPANTS.
TO SEEK JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA
THIRTY TWO PORTIONS OF THE BILL.
THE FIRST PERSON THE BILL.
DEALS WITH OF THE ISSUE
CONCERNING COURT REPORTING IN
OUT OF STATE COURT REPORTING
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT THE
BILL DESIGNATES. IN RESPONSE TO
CONCERNS BY COURT REPORTERS
DESIGNATES. A COURT REPORTER
BASICALLY WHO HAS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT AT THE
STATE COURT REPORTING AND COURT
REPORTER SO IT DESIGNATES A-
PERSON OR AN ENTITY TO BE A
COURT REPORTER- THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE. FOR THE OUT OF
STATE ACTIVITIES. IT ALSO
ALLOWS FOR REMOTE TESTIMONY
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
IN LIGHT OF THE COVERT CRISIS
THERE ARE WITNESSES WHO
TESTIFIED. FOR EXAMPLE A
CUSTODIAN OF RECORDS IS SIMPLY
COMES IN TO TESTIFY AS TO THE
AUTHENTICITY OF RECORDS OR HOW
THE RECORDS ARE KEPT. THERE'S
REALLY NO REASON WHY THAT
WITNESS NEED TO TESTIFY IN
PERSON AND THUS THE WITNESS IF
TWO PARTIES STIPULATE CONTEST
BY REMOTELY AND IF ONE PARTY
WON'T STIPULATE BUT THERE'S A
MOTION THE JUDGE BELIEVES IT'S
APPROPRIATE. THEY CAN'T COME IN
TO TESTIFY AGAIN IF THEIR
TESTIMONY IS INTERFERED WITH
EITHER BY BECAUSE BECAUSE THE
TECHNOLOGY OR SOME OTHER REASON
THEY CAN BE REQUIRED TO COME.
AND TESTIFY IN PERSON IN LIFE I
HAVE- WITH ME ON THE PHONE LINE
THE TWO WITNESSES MISTER GREG
RESEAL AND ALSO- THE VINO HURT-
CHAIR OF THE- FIRM REGISTRATION
SUBCOMMITTEE THE COURT
REPORTERS BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU- AS WAS STATED WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND WE
HAVE A DIVISION OR HEARD FROM
COURT REPORTERS BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS A GROUP
GREGORY ZERO FROM CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA.
MODERATOR CAN YOU CONFIRM THAT-
THESE INDIVIDUALS THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE ON. AND THAT
THEY WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH.
GOOD EVENING THANK. GOOD
EVENING SB HURT YOU KNOW
EXCELLENT STREAMING MY NAME
GIVING HER TIME THE PUBLIC
MEMBER OF THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD THANK YOU CHAIR- BURKE
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF SB TWO FOR
ONE FOR THE CONSUMER AND
NOTABLY THE FIRM REGISTRATION
PORTION. LEGISLATURE AS
CAREFULLY SET OUT PROCEDURES
GOVERNING PREPARATION AND
DISTRIBUTION OF THE OFFICIAL
TRANSCRIPT NOT JUST ONE AREA OF
THE CODE BUT NUMEROUS PLACES
AND ALONG- BEFORE YOU THE BOY
TO BUILD TO SIR. AND PROTECT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY GROWING
DISREGARD FOR THE EXISTING LAWS
BY NONWHITE BE OWNED FIRMS. AND
THE BOARD EMPHASIZES CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS BECAUSE MANY OF THESE
FIRMS WILL NO PROBLEM
SUBMITTING TO FIRM REGISTRATION
AND FILING LOW LONG. AND THEIR
OWN HOME STATE. AS WELL AS
OTHER STATES IN WHICH THEY DO
BUSINESS TEXAS GEORGIA ARIZONA
AND NEVADA. CRB IS PROPERLY
POISED TO HOLD NON LICENSEE
OWNED FIRMS ACCOUNTABLE TO
REFUSE TO FOLLOW SIMILAR LAWS
IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE SUPPORT
SB TWO FOUR ONE. THE TYPE OF
COMPLAINTS RECEIVED BY THE
BOARD INCLUDE BILLING
IRREGULARITIES AND TRANSCRIPT
MISCONDUCT ALLOWING ONE SIDE
YOU HAVE ACCESS TO THE
TRANSCRIPTS BEFORE THE OTHER
THERE BY GIVING THEM AN
ADVANTAGE. IN PREPARING FOR
LITIGATION. DEPOSITION ALSO
MUST BE IN AND EACH PARTY MUST
BE TO EQUALLY AND- THE BOARD OF
WORK WELL WITH ATTORNEY OFFICE
THE ACTUAL ENFORCEMENT ARM OF
THE BOARD FOR THE SIMPLE
SOLUTION TO HOLD ALL PROVIDERS
OF COURT REPORTING SERVICES. TO
THE STANDARDS ESTABLISHED BY
THE PLUCKY NO WHERE THEY ARE
STATED LOCATE. OR WHO OWNS THE
BUSINESS. SINCE THE EIGHTIES
THE MORNING WELCOME TO BUSINESS
MY BECAUSE CARPET AND FREE. IS
GOOD FOR THE CONSUMER IT'S
BIRTH HEALTHY REYES THE QUALITY
OF. LOWERS PRICE AN EXTRA OUR
TO GOODS AND SERVICES. WHAT IS
GOOD FOR THE CONSUMER IT'S THE
BALL ON A TO STAY IN AND THE
LAWS AROUND OFFICIAL TRANSCRIPT
THAT WERE GIVEN. TO IT BY THE
LEGISLATURE. WE THANK PREDATOR
AMBER AFTER THE DEDICATION SIX
PER. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF SB TWO FOUR ONE
FOR EQUAL PROTECTION OF ALL
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISS HURT AND NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO MISTER GREGG
REZERO- WITH THE- ADDED-
COMMENT THAT IF WE COULD PLEASE
KEEP IT UNDER TWO MINUTES THAT
BE WONDERFUL. I WILL DO MY BEST
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS GREGORY G. ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA TESTIFYING AS A CO
SPONSOR OF SB TWO FORTY ONE. PM
SPEAKING ON THE REMOTE LIVE
WITH THIS PORTION OF THE BILL.
SB TWO FORTY ONE HAS SUPPORT BY
BOTH DEFENSE AND PLAINTIFF
COUNSEL AS IT HELPS CREATE BOTH
SAFETY AND EFFICIENCY IN THE
COURTS. LIKE MANY OTHER
PROFESSIONS THIS PANDEMIC IS
CREATED SERIOUS ISSUES FOR THE
COURTS AS WE NOW FACE A YEAR'S
WORTH OF BACKLOGGED CASES DUE
TO THE CLOSURES. NOW THE TIME
TO FOCUS ON MAKING THE COURTS
MORE EFFICIENT HELP MAKE UP FOR
THOSE BACKLOGS. WHILE ATTORNEYS
MANY TIMES HAVE TO CALL NON
CRITICAL WITNESSES TO PROVIDE
BASIC FOUNDATIONAL EVIDENCE AS
AN EXAMPLE WHEN TRYING AN
AUTOMOBILE ACCIDENT CASE. WHERE
MY CLIENT OBTAIN EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TREATMENT. I MIGHT HAVE
TO CALL A HOSPITAL
ADMINISTRATOR TO PROVIDE ABOUT
THREE TO FIVE MINUTES WITH THE
TESTIMONY. TO SIMPLY SAY THAT
THE BILL IN FRONT OF THE JURY
IS BOTH ACCURATE AND REAL.
FORTUNATELY FOR THAT
ADMINISTRATORS STAFF TO TAKE
THE DAY OFF FROM WORK MANY
TIMES ON PAGE. DRIVE MANY MILES
WHATEVER COURTHOUSE EDUCATION
BEING TRIED AND- FINING PAPER
PARKING BEFORE SITTING IN A
COURT HALLWAY. WAITING UP TO
THREE TO FOUR. TWO TO THREE
HOURS TO PROVIDE THAT SAME
THREE TO FIVE MINUTES WITH THE
TESTIMONY. THIS IS ONE EXAMPLE
OF MANY OF NON CRITICAL
WITNESSES THAT DO NOT NEED TO
COME TO COURT. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE'S BEEN SOME
CONCERN THAT WITNESSES MIGHT
NOT BE HEARD MAKING IT
DIFFICULT TO PRESERVE THE COURT
RECORD FOR APPEAL. TO TRIAL
LAWYER FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS I
DO NOT SHARE THIS CONCERN ALL
TRIAL LAWYERS KNOW THAT WE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO PROTECT OUR
CLIENTS ABOUT RIGHT. JUDGES
ALSO HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
PROTECT THE SAME. RIGHT
ADDITIONALLY ATTORNEYS HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFULLY MAKING CORPS
TO KEEP PARENTS IS BY PHONE IN
DEPARTMENTS FOR OVER FIFTEEN
YEARS. WHEN THE JUDGES NOT
HERE'S HERE'S THE HE OR SHE-
SIMPLY SAYS PLEASE SAY IT AGAIN.
THIS PHONE CALL THE PRINT
SYSTEM HAS BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
EMPLOYED FOR A LONG TIME AND SB
TWO FORTY ONE HAS USED OUR
EXPERIENCE. IN BEEN MODIFIED
SEVERAL TIMES TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS AS SUCH WE URGE YOUR
AYE VOTES THANK YOU AND I WILL
REMAIN ON THE LINE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER ZERO YOU
ACTUALLY HAD SIX SECONDS LEFT
CONGRATULATIONS. ARE LET'S MY-
MAKE YOU AYE I DO MY BEST.
LET'S BEGIN WITH WITNESS HERE
IN THE SENATE GALLERY. SEEING
NONE ARE MOVING ON TO A ROOM
ONE TWELVE IT ALSO SEEING NONE.
BOB WILL MOVE ON TO- SUPPORT
WITNESSES- WAITING TESTIFIED V-
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY FOLKS
IN THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWO FOUR ONE. YES THAT'S
LIKE WE HAVE FOR IT THIS TIME
WONDERFUL CUME UP PLEASE. OKAY
ONE SIX TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT'S RETURN MEMBERS
MICHAEL OF FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEFENSE COUNSEL MR RAISIO IS
CORRECT WE JOIN THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS IN ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT.
WE GO TO FIVE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI I AM A
CERTIFIED- CALIFORNIA CSR AND I
AM IN GREAT SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE LESLIE THANK YOU.
NEXT TO THE LINE SIX OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SIX OH
THREE. YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM SORRY HI I'M I'M ACTUALLY
IN OPPOSITION I THINK I WOULD
PUT INTO THE INCORRECT CUES.
ALL RIGHT IF YOU LIKE TO CALL
BACK WILL LOAN- PUT YOU IN THE
QUEUE IN OPPOSITION MA'AM. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. OKAY IT WILL
GO TO LINE SIX TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
AYE THEY'LL ACTUALLY AND I AM A
PROUD COURT REPORTING AGENCY CO
OWNER AND I PROBABLY SUPPORT SB
TWO FORTY ONE. WE GO TO LINE
SIX THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS SARAH MCDEVITT COURT
REPORTER AS CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTER NUMBER ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN FIVE AND I SUPPORT SB TWO
pMODERATE TO HAVE ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE QUEUE. WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE LINE MY NUMBER SIX THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
PERSONAL ADULT MAN THE
CORPORATE AT THE CHIU FORTY ONE.
ALL RIGHT WATER CAN YOU A
DOUBLE CHECK TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO TESTIFY. DID ANYONE ELSE
WANT TO TESTIFY PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT SEVEN TWO
HAS TWO LINES QUEUING UP JUST
ONE MOMENT. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIX TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE CAN BE WALDRON
PROMPTED JERRY AND I OPPOSE THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT MODERATOR
ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE IN
SUPPORT. AND I HAVE NORTHERN Q.
AND DECIDE THANK YOU ARE HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WERE
NEVER GOING TO FALL THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM OPPOSITION
MODERATOR I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
LIBBY SANCHEZ FROM SEIU
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS IN
IGNACIO HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS.
ASSOCIATION ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR ARE BOTH
OF THEM ON THE LINE. YOUR
FRIEND HERE WONDERFUL IF YOU
CAN KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO TWO
MINUTES EACH THAT WOULD BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE COULD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS LED THE
SANTOS ON BEHALF OF THE SEIU
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
OFFICIAL COURT REPORTERS
WORKING IN COURT. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
REGRETFUL OPPOSITION TO
ATHLETES CHIU FORTY ONE.
CONTRARY TO WHAT PROPONENTS
HAVE ARTICULATED THERE IS NO
LIMITATION IN THIS MATTER THAT
IS APPLIED ONLY TEN
NONESSENTIAL WITNESSES MEANING
IT APPLIES TO EVERY SINGLE TYPE
OF WITNESSES INCLUDING AN
EVIDENTIARY. TESTIMONIAL
PROCEEDINGS. I DAY I HEARD FROM
A CORE REPORT ABOUT THEY'VE HAD
BEING ABLE TO PRODUCE THE
OFFICIAL VERBATIM RECORD DURING
THE PANDEMIC HE'S PROBLEMS HAVE
RANGED FROM DROPPED LINE FOR
BOULDER COUNTY AUDIO PEOPLE
TALKING OVER ONE ANOTHER MAKING
IT IMPOSSIBLE TO DISCERN WHO
THE SPEAKER IS. OVER DOLLARS
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS USES OF
NEW PATENTS OPPOSING NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING PARTIES BEING
ON ONE LINE WITH ONE TRANSLATOR
WITH THE COURT REPORTER UNABLE
TO HEAR ANY PART OF IT. UNLIKE
THE REST OF US FOR WHOM THESE
TECHNOLOGICAL DIFFICULTIES ARE
MERE INCONVENIENCE IN THIS
LITTLE. IS OFFICIAL COURT
REPORTERS ARE TASKED WITH
PRODUCING THE OFFICIAL VERBATIM
RECORDS THERE IS NO EXEMPTION
UNDER EXISTING LAW PERMITTING
THEM TO REPLACE TESTIMONY WITH
NOTATIONS OF AN ARTICLE OR
UNINTELLIGIBLE WHEN THEY CAN'T
HEAR YOUR LICENSES ARE ON THE
LINE FOR GUARD BUT- AND THIS
IS. SOME HYPOTHETICAL SCENARIO
THERE ARE CURRENTLY MULTIPLE
FINALLY BEFORE THE C. R. BOARD
ALLEGING FACT SECTION THE
TESTIMONY WERE NOT ACCURATELY
TRANSCRIBE DURING REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS ARE APPEARANCES IT
MIGHT BE ESTARá CAN'T HEAR
WHAT IS BEING SAID OR BY WHOM
THEY CAN'T TRANSCRIBE. THIS IS
A PROBLEM FOR THEM AND THEIR
ABILITY TO DO THEIR JOB AND
MAINTAIN THEIR LICENSES IT'S A
PROBLEM FOR EVERY PARTY NEEDS
TO RELY ON THE OFFICIAL
VERBATIM RECORD FOR PURPOSES OF
PURSUING THE RIGHT TO APPEAL.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY
PROBLEMATIC GIVEN THE NATURE OF
HEALTH PARTIES AND COURTS WOULD
DECIDE UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL WHETHER A WITNESS MAY
IF YOU'RE REMOTELY THERE'S NO
OBLIGATION IN THE BILL
REQUIRING THAT A PARTY MAY BE
FULLY MUST BE FULLY INFORMED
ABOUT THE RIGHT HERE SHE MAY
POTENTIALLY BE WAITING. BY
AGREEING TO A SCENARIO WHICH
COULD PROVE TO SELL FAULTY IS A
RIGHT THE PONTIFF HE'LL BECOME
A CENTERS. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
WRAP FINALLY. I JUST WANT TO
MAKE FINAL THAT. THAT AMEND
THAT WORKS TO. REQUIRED
RECORDING OR ARE NOT GOING DO
ANY BECAUSE FOR CORPS STILL TO
BE PLAN AND IF WE HEAR WITH THE
RECORD RECORDING. IT'S MAKE THE
TRIP. ANYMORE USEFUL FIFTY TO
BE A HUGE EXPENSE FOR THE CORE
WHICH BE MUCH SPENT ON MAKING
SURE THAT THE COURT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MESSAGES FOR TAKING
TIME IN YOUR SCHEDULE MODERATOR
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON. TO MISTER
NOT CO HERNANDEZ. ARE YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER AT NASSAR
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF. THE
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF. UNITED
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES IN OPPOSITION.
NEARLY ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY. MR AND SHOWS THE
MEMBERS OF SECURITY I'VE BEEN
HEARING THE SAME PROBLEMS
RECORDING THE SAME PROBLEMS. IT
RUNS TO AL CAL. THREE POINT OUT.
ONE OTHER THING ABOUT THE BILL
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE PANDEMIC OF THE
CONTRAST THE PROBLEMS DURING
THE PANDEMIC THIS BILL IS
REALLY IN AT. JUNE STATUTES
THAT WILL APPLY TO BE UTILIZED
BECAUSE PANDEMIC WE ARE QUITE.
DISAPPOINTS THAT THIS BILL IS
MOVING TOWARD WITH VERY LITTLE
INPUT FROM STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS
THE COURT REPORTERS SO THAT WE
CAN SHARE ALL OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE SEE ON A DAILY BASIS.
AND WE BELIEVE IT IS MORE
BENEFICIAL TO GET A WORKING
GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS TO
DISCUSS REMOTE APPEARANCES- AND
HOW IT'S WORKING HOW IT'S NOT
WORKING DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
THEY COME UP WITH A GAME PLAN
OF WHAT TO DO. POSTGANGLIONIC
WE ALL KNOW MORTGAGE ZERO THREE
IS IN EFFECT RIGHT NOW AND WILL
REMAIN IN THE FACT FOR UP TO
NINETY DAYS PAST- THE LIFTING
OF THE CAP OF THE PUBLIC OUT OF
ORDER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THERE IS NO RUSH.
TO PASS THE STATE ALSO BE
ASKING WE CONSIDER THAT ON THE
POINT REGARDING. OUT OF STATE.
FORMER DISTRESS. PETER AND HIS
PUSH FOR SOMETHING SIMILAR FOR
MANY YEARS WITH A LOT OF.
OPPOSITION FROM OF MR. BUT LET
ME BE VERY CLEAR. THERE ARE
GAPS STAFF THAT IT WE- IS STILL
GOES FORWARD. WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A LAW OF. WITH ARE WRITTEN FOR
A OF THE- RIGHTS IN. AND
PERFORMS A LOCAL IN. CALIFORNIA
FOR OUT OF. FIRMS THERE'S MANY.
THAT WILL MAKE IT SO. TO
ENFORCE THE NECESSARY. ARE THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE RIGHT BACK HERE.
THE WHOLE. LAUNDRY LIST OF
PROBLEMS. THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCE
WE ASK AFTER THIS BILL NEEDS TO
BE AMENDED PROVISION THE BILL
BE AMENDED. TO STRENGTHEN- THE
OVERSIGHT AND STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS ON OUT OF STATE
PROGRAMS THAT WE CAN INSURE
INTEGRITY OF. OUR THE
DEPOSITION INDUSTRY FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE ARE CLOSED THANK
YOU MISTER HANDERS. ARE LET'S
MOVE ON TO ME WITNESSES HERE IN
THE SENATE GALLERY. SEEING
NONE. ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WE SHOULD NOT TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION SB TWO FOUR ONE.
ALSO SEEN- MADRUGA BE MOVING ON
TO OPPOSITE WITH THIS WAITING.
VIA TELL. IF YOU KEEP. LOOK AT
THE QUEUE AND LET US KNOW HOW
MANY- ARE THERE. WE HAVE
THIRTEEN IN Q. ALL RIGHT IF. WE
COULD PLEASE REMIND THE FOLKS
THAT WE ARE WISHING TO HAVE
THEIR NAME. THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR POSITION. OKAY WE'LL
START WITH ONE SIX THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR
HEARING ME MY NAME IS DIANE
EVAN **** I'M A CONSTITUENT IN
DISTRICT THIRTY THREE I AM AN
OFFICIAL COURT REPORTER FOR A
LOS ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT AND
MEMBER HE'S HEARING AND HE AYE
YOU SEVENTY ONE AND WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENT I AM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE LION FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS KIMBERLY DEAR SO AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE PROTECT YOUR
RECORD PROJECT IN YOUR
ADAMANTLY OPPOSE THE
CONTROVERSIAL BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD ALIGNED SIX
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS JOANNE PRICE I'M IN
CALIFORNIA THE S. R. NUMBER
THIRTY THREE TWENTY ONE
OFFICIAL REPORTER FOR THE
FEDERAL DISTRICT COURT IN SAN
FRANCISCO I HAVE BEEN REPORTING
FOR FORTY SIX YEARS AND I
STRENUOUSLY URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
ON. SB TWO FORTY ONE. WE GO TO
LINE SIX THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER TURN
NUMBERS MY APOLOGIES THIS IS
ANDREW LANGLEY- ABOUT NIELSEN
MARK SUMMER I WAS DROPPED- IN
WHEN I WAS IN LINE TO SUPPORT-
WE WERE. I CALL ON BEHALF OF
THE DEPOSITION REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION IN EVERY ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS OF THE FACT THAT BY
THIS BILL I'M WEARING VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING
OUT OF. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ZERO ONE ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KELLY
SHANE MINE I MAY CALIFORNIA.
REPORTER NUMBER THIRTEEN FORTY
SEVEN. REPORTER AND CO FOUNDER
AS HE WHY ARE SHORT PROJECT
DIRECTOR PROJECT AND I AM
STRONGLY- AND I'M STRONGLY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOUNG. WE GO
TO LINE. TWO FOR FIVE THAT. ONE
TWO FIFTY FIVE. OKAY MOVING ON
TO LINE FIVE FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. INDEED TO SHELL AND
THE OFFICIAL COURT REPORTER
FROM VENTURA COUNTY I THE
NUMBER OF SB I USE SEVEN TWO
ONE AND CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FINISHES HERE LOOKS LIKE
WE STILL HAVE ELEVEN MORE IN Q.
FOUR ONE FIVE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD EVENING
THIS IS A FOCUS NEXT OFFICIAL
COURT REPORTER FOR THE LOS
ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE EPRA AND THE
FBI YOU. ONLINE THE WRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THIS IS
A BIG MISTAKE THANK YOU. HAVE A
GOOD ONE FIVE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CAROLYN GASPARE I'M A RETIRED
COURT REPORTER AN AVERAGE
RETURN OF THE JEDI TWO YEARS
I'M AN SEIU MEMBER AND A PAST
PRESIDENT QUICK CALIFORNIA
COURT REPORTERS ASSOCIATION
SHLOMO STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO
FORTY ONE THANK YOU. THE LITTLE
ONE SIX TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVE ON
THE LINE FIVE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIVE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING THIS
IS MICHAEL HENSLEY PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF AND OUR ENTIRE
MEMBERSHIP THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THAT B. TWO FORTY ONE
THANK YOU. WE GO TO LINE SIX
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER MY NAME IS CAMERA
SUMPTER AND THE COURT REPORTER
FOR THE TULARE COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT IN CALIFORNIA IN A NUMBER
OF C. C. R. A. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWO FORTY ONE. THANK
YOU. GO TO ONE SIX TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN ONE
HUNDRED WALDRON. SORRY MANY
ASSEMBLY WALDRON I AM CONFIDENT
FOR CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION AND A MEMBER OF
SEIU AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. ONE SIX FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MARY PIERCE I AM CSR SIX ONE
FOUR TRICKS LIKE WITHIN SIX FOR
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS AND I FULLY
SUPPORT THIS FEATURE FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU FOR. WE GO TO ONE SIX
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS JAMIE ASKARI
CSR ONE THREE THREE ZERO EIGHT.
IN THE PROUD THREE LAUNCHER FOR
THE LAST FOURTEEN YEARS CAN I
WAS NOT ABLE TO GET THROUGH TO-
SHOW MY SUPPORT I PROBABLY AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY
ONE AND I THINK SENATOR UMBERG.
AND HIS STAFF. WE GO TO ONE SIX
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS CRITICAL YOU
DON'T NEED I'M A COURT REPORTER
MEMBER OF SEIU ALSO ON THE
THEORY BOARD. OPPOSE SB. TWO
FORTY ONE. WE GOT A LINE TO
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TWO FIFTY FIVE. OKAY WE'LL MOVE
ON THE LINE SIX FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS.
AND I'M A WOMAN ALONE ACCORDING
TO MOM ALL BUSINESS. BOB CORKER
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND INCREASED
STRONG OPPOSITION. I'LL BE
CLEAR. IT WILL GO TO LINE. SIX
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS TO
RESTORE RIGHTS I'M A MEMBER OF
THE R. EIGHT AND IN THE R.
EIGHT I'M A DEPOSITION REPORTER
AND I'M IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THE NEW YORK CHIU FORTY ONE
THANK YOUNG. WATER HOW MANY- DO
WE HAVE LEFT IN THE QUEUE. IT
WAS LIKE WE HAVE TO MORE
CURRENT. WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHTEINMAN AND CARE YES OUR
NUMBER IS ONE ONE NINE TWO
THREE AM OFFICIALS SACRAMENTO
IN OFFICE. ON THE FIERI BOARD
AND I STRUGGLING OPPOSE. AND WE
COME TO LINE TO FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND. TO FIFTY
FIVE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY.
HELLO CAN CAUSE ARE OPEN BOTH
IN CALIFORNIA I AM CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED SHORTHAND REPORTER
LICENSE NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE OH
NINE FOR THIRTY TWO YEARS. I
ALSO OWN AND OPERATE BECAUSE
OUR DEFINITION REPORTERS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SENATE BILL TWO
FORTY ONE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MODERATE CAN YOU- DO
A FINAL LOOK SEE IF ANYONE ELSE
IS IN THE QUEUE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB TWO FOUR ONE. IF ANYONE
ELSE WANTS TO SPEAK PLEASE
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE OKAY. THANK YOU TO ALL
OUR SUPPORTERS AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS.
MEMBERS I BELIEVE CENTER DRAWS
SO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OR
VICE CHAIR I WANT TO THANK OUR
CHAIR- FOR RAISING THE
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT HE'S HAD-
WE HAVE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS FOR AWHILE NOW AS
I SERVED AS CHAIR BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FIVE- YOU KNOW I'M
SURE I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE BUT
I'M REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
BACKLOG OF THE CASES THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE FACING AT THE END OF
THIS EMERGENCY. FIVE HEARD
CONCERNS FROM THOSE AS WE HAVE
THIS EVENING SUPPORTING THE
BILL AND ALSO THOSE OPPOSED TO
THIS- PERMANENT APPROACH- AS
THEY SAY WERE WE SHOULD
PROBABLY SUMMARIZE OUR
EXPERIENCES BOTH GOOD AND GET
BAD BEFORE A PERMANENT A
DECISION- WE ARE AT IN THE
POINT HERE WITH OUR TECHNOLOGY
OF BEING ABLE TO CREATE SOME
COURT EFFICIENCIES AND BETTER
COURT OPERATIONS AND WE HAVE TO
BALANCE THAT OUT WITH PROJECT-
ABOUT PROTECTING ACCESS TO
JUSTICE A OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
BIBLE NOBLE COMMUNITIES SO.
THAT'S WHERE I'M AT RIGHT NOW
MIKE SUBCOMMITTEE IS STILL
REVIEWING THE PROPOSALS WE HAVE
NOT YET APPROVED ANY OF THE
LANGUAGE ON HOW TO DEAL WITH
BOTH ACCESS TO JUSTICE COURT
EFFICIENCIES AND OUR REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY- BECAUSE WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THE PROPOSALS I WILL
BE ABSTAINING FROM TAKING A
POSITION ON THIS BILL. TODAY
THANK YOU SIR DRAWS ON ANY
OTHER. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WISHING TO SPEAK I SEE NO
MIKE'S UP. ALL RIGHT DOESN'T
REMEMBER IT WAS LIKE TO CLOSE-
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR BUT LET
ME FIRST COMMENT ALL WITH
RESPECT TO COURT REPORTERS- AS
A PRACTICING LAWYER. WHO'S BEEN
IN PRACTICE FOR SOME TIME.
COURT REPORTERS ARE INCREDIBLY
DILIGENT AND THEY ARE
INCREDIBLY PROTECTIVE OF THEIR
RECORD AND THEY DO AN EXCELLENT
JOB I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY
TIMES A COURT REPORTER HAS TOLD
ME THAT. EITHER THE ANSWER WAS
MUFFLED- MY QUESTION WAS
MUFFLED OR SOME SUCH THING AND
DONE AN ABSOLUTELY OUTSTANDING
JOB MAKING SURE THERE'S AN
ACCURATE RECORD AND THEY HAVE
AN INTEREST IN ACCURATE RECORD.
WHAT THE LAWYERS HAVE BEEN OF A
GREATER INTEREST IN THE JUDGE
HAS AN INTEREST IN THE RECORD
IN OUR SYSTEM IS SUCH THAT
WE'VE GOT. TO COUNCIL AT LEAST
PLUS THE JUDGE WHO'S ALSO
INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE THAT
THE RECORD IS ACCURATE SO WITH
RESPECT TO REMOTE TESTIMONY
WE'VE TAKEN THE AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS.
I THINK THERE'LL ALWAYS BE A
PLACE FOR COURT REPORTER IN THE
COURTROOM TO MAKE SURE. THAT
THE TESTIMONY. IS ACCURATELY
PRESERVE OUR IN TERMS OF
WITNESSES THE BILL DOES NOT. RE
CLUE TWO PARTIES FROM
STIPULATING TO WITNESS IT DOES
REQUIRE BOTH PARTIES TO
STIPULATE SO BOTH PARTIES ON
EACH SIDE STIPULATE TO A
WITNESS TESTIFYING REMOTELY
THEN THEY THOSE LAWYERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS. A FAIR HEARING IN A
FAIR OPPORTUNITY FOR THE TRIER
OF FACT TO VIEW THEIR
CREDIBILITY. IF ONE PARTY DOES
NOT CONSENT THEN THERE'S A
MOTION BROUGHT TO THE JUDGE AND
THE JUDGE CAN MAKE THAT
DECISION BASED ON SEVERAL
CRITERIA- SO HAVING SAID ALL
THAT I. APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FROM THE VARIOUS CHORAL AND
EDITORS AND I VOTE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU CENTER TO HAVE A
MOTION ON SPEECH. FOUR ONE.
WELL THAT'S SIX. THAT'S RIGHT
HALF AN HOUR AGO SO JOE DID. I
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS THE
BUT FIRST OF IN REFER TO THE CA
ON A PER. AMENDING PAGE ELEVEN
THROUGH TWELVE COMMENT NUMBER
FOUR. COUNCIL WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AT YES THIS IS SB TWO
FORTY ONE BY SHARE- BURKE. AND
THE MOTION IS BY SENATOR JONES
THE MOTION AS STATED TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE HI I'M
BURKE AYE PORGES. GORGEOUS I
CAMBIADO HI. I DID AYE SO. DID
S. AND VOTING GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ NOT VOTING HERTZBERG
AYE HERTZBERG AYE JONES JONES I
LAYERED. THEY'RE NOT VOTING NO
I SAID FIVE I'M SORRY SOURCE I
LAYERED. I LAYERED I THINK YOU.
STERN STERN STERN I WAKE CAL
SKI BY WACO SKI I WIENER WIENER
I. THAT'S NINE EIGHT THAT'S-
NINE AND EVERYONE HAS VOTED- SO
I GUESS THIS BILL IS OUT WITH
NINE EYES. IN A NUMBER OF THE
REMAINDER NOT VOTING. ALL RIGHT
I THINK SO. I'VE BEEN HERE THE
WHOLE TIME. THE. THE NEW
YORKER- THANK YOU YEAH. YEAH.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA WE'RE
GONNA LIFT THE CALLS HERE BOMB
WE'RE GONNA START. LITTLE BIT
OUT OF ORDER ON S. B. FOUR FOUR
SEVEN BY CENTER LAYERED- TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE AN-
ACCURATE RECORD OF THE MOTION.
SO BUT TO PRACTICE OF BEFORE WE
OPEN THE ROLE ON THE ITEM ON
THE PROPER MOTIONS BILLS TO DO
PASSED AS AMENDED. MENDOCINE
COUNTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
YES- THE REMAINING MEMBER IS
SENATOR BORGES'S ON S. B. FOUR
FOUR SEVEN. NO BARGES NO NO SO
THAT'S NINE TWO TO NINETY TWO
THE BILLS OUT. K. RIGHT GOING
BACK TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CHAIR VOTING I JONES. JONES
I STERN. STERN I HAVE A ELEVEN
TWO ZERO. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ELEVEN ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT. NEXT
BILL IS S. B. TWO THIRTY EIGHT.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING NO.
CABALLERO NO COVERAGE AT ALL NO
HERTZBERG HI I WISH WHICH WAS
JUST. I'M SORRY I DIDN'T. EIGHT
I'M SORRY HURTS WE HEAR VOTING
NO HERTZBERG AUTHORED I HEARD A
TECH. THAT'S IT LAUGHS AND
SENATOR HERTZBERG WHAT'S YOUR
VOTE NO. SENATE HERTZBERG VOTE
NO. SENATOR JONES HI SENATOR
VOTING I SENATOR LAYERED.
SENATOR LAYERED VOTING NO
SENATORS. START A- I'M SORRY
STERN. STERN KNOWS USED AS NO.
MMHM- I'M SORRY THAT BILL IS.
TO I. NINE NO ALL RIGHT TO AYES
NINE NOES THE BILL. SOMEONE
WANTED TO BE. VETERANS ON MY OR-
THE NURSERY IT'S RIGHT. YEAH I
WILL SUPPORT A MO TO RE THIS
BOARD MAXIMO RETURN THAT THAT
MORE BEGRAND ALL RIGHT. SALMON
NEXT ON THE NEXT ONE TO OF US
HAVE IMPAIR THAT DOESN PERMIT
US TO OF THE WORD NO SO SAN.
THIS NEXT BILL S. B. TWO FORTY.
BY CENTER MO. WITH THE VOTER NO.
W. ALL NO. GOT DON'T KNOW DID I
SO NO THE RUSSELL NO. HERTZBERG
NO HERTZBERG NO. AN THAT'S IT
AND THAT'S TO NINE. CHAIR ON
BURKE. THE BILL FAIL. TO THE
NINE. GEN RICAN. THEIR BORDERS
MOST READ WITHOUT OF MOST TO
GRANT. THE NEXT BILL IS S. B.
SIX SIXTY BY SENATOR NEW WITH
THE CHAIR VOTE I. GORGEOUS LOW
BOARD. NO CABALLERO NOT VOTING
COPYRIGHT NOT VOTE DID ASAL.
THANK THE REST SO I HEARD STE
HI HURTS I THAT'S. THAT'S A TWO
TWO SENATOR EIGHT THE BILLS OUT.
HI CENTER HERTZBERG I SENATOR
JONES NO SENATOR JONES NO C. OF.
ONE TO THREE FIVE SIX. GET NINE
TWO ONE SIDE WON THE BILL'S OUT.
THE NEXT BILL IS S. B. FIVE
FIVE FIVE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI FORGES
ON GORGEOUS HI CAMBIADO HI WTO
I JOAN I JONES I THAT'S A LOT
TO SEE. SEVEN ZERO BILLS OUT.
THE NEXT BILL IS B. FIVE NINETY
EIGHT BY SO PAN. WE THE CHAIR
VOTING I BORJAS LOW PORGES NO
CARRIER HI COMMITTEE ALL I
JONES NO. JONES NO THE NINETY
TWO. THAT IT TO THE BILLS OUT.
THE NEXT BILL IS- S. B. C.
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR LONGER.
WITH THE VOTING I BORJAS NO
PORGES NO COVERAGE AT ALL NOT
VOTING EVERY AT ALL NOT. JOE NO
JOHN NO. YOU HAVE A TO TWO
EIGHT TO THE BILL OUT. THE NEXT
BILL IS A B. THREE TWENTY THREE
BY SO COVER YEAH WITH SENATOR
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I PORCHES.
PORTIS NOT VOTING. THAT IS.
THANK. THAT'S TEN TWO ZERO ZERO
BILL OUT. THE NEXT BILL IS S.
B. THREE THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR
DID ASK AND THIS IS A HASN'T I
VOTE BY THAT SHE- SENATOR
GORGEOUS. NO SENATOR JUST NO
SENATE STERN. THIS IS A SB
THREE THIRTY FOR SENATOR STERN.
TONIGHT STERN I THINK WANT ME
MORE SIX THAT'S NINETY TWO
NINETY TWO BILLS OUT. THE NEXT
BILL IS S. B. THREE EIGHT VICE
GONE. AND THE TWO VOTING. STERN
STRONG STERN I YOU HAVE NINE
TWO TWO NINE TWO BILLS ARE. THE
LAST BILL S. B. FIVE SOME TWO
BY SENATOR HURTS. WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I FORGES. NOT
VOTING STERN. THREE NINE STERN
AYE THAT IS. TEN TWO ZERO ZERO
THE BILL AS ADUT- IN WITH THE
MAN COUNSEL THE OTHER BILL TO
BEGIN THERE ARE NO OTHER
BUSINESS BE CONDUCTED WE WILL
ADJOURN TILL NEXT TUESDAY APRIL
TWENTY SEVENTH- SOLA. BRING US
BAG ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THE
GERMAN.